the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
we've passed the Midway point at the U.S
Juniors and Senior championships in St
Louis rested and recharged players Came
Out Swinging following the rest day
melecatian is running away with the
seniors title notching his fifth win for
a two-point lead over the field despite
a topsy-turvy round in some near upsets
leaders in the Juniors Drew their games
to remain in a three-way tie for first
Alice Lee continues to impress
maintaining a narrow lead after her
fourth win but Zoe Tong is right behind
her after another incredible Victory
leaders are asserting dominance and
Challengers are pressing day seven of
impeccable chess coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome to round seven of the US Juniors
and seniors chess championships we are
here at the warches hall of fame where
some of the best chess exhibitions in
the world some of the rising stars and
legends of the US chess are competing
upstairs let's go and follow the action
the Saint Louis chess club is proud to
present the 2023 edition of three
tournaments in one junior girls juniors
and seniors featuring The Best of young
talent and talented veterans are a
coverage from San Luis begins now
[Music]
and I'm here with Grandmaster Yasser
Sarah Juan okay it's it's been great I
mean the decisive number of games that
the tournament's just flowing right
along right and we have only three
rounds left so I think we can expect
even more battles absolutely hello
everyone and Welcome to our broadcast of
these three national championships if
you like decisive games you certainly
came to the right show and I tell you
these matchups for round seven are the
most important of all the tournaments
let's take a look let's begin with the
standings right and let's start with
girls standings we have a soul leader
Alice Lee is having a fantastic
tournament five out of six closely
followed by Zoe tank four and a half and
then there is a two-way tie karissaib
and with three and a half points each
and in the Junior
in the Juniors we have actually a
three-way tie so far for the first place
so it's gonna be a lot of you know on
the field today
Andrew Hong and Arthur go all with four
points and in the Legends in the legend
we have one incredible player Malik said
catchy and five and half points out of
six and then we have a four-way tie a
lot of players are right behind him I
mean right two points behind him right
behind us
Gregory kaidan of Maxim loogie and Alex
shabalov with three and a half points
each and tell us about the format for
these three national championships the
format is three ten play around Robins
meaning each player plays everyone else
in their respective tournament the time
control is classical chess 90 minutes
for first 40 moves followed by 30
minutes for rest of the game and 30
second increment from move one there are
no draw for no draw offers allowed and
the traditional scoring system 1.4 in
half a point for a draw and zero points
for loss I said we're zipping right
along but tell us about the remaining
schedule key yeah we have one round a
day we start at 1pm central time today
round seven then we have two more rounds
to go and if necessary we will have
playoffs on Tuesday July 25th wonderful
and as always we're very fortunate to
have in studio Christian
as we see Malik said he's really zoning
in because he knows today is a big match
and Christian you're going to tell us
about the big matches of today and they
exist boy do they ever oh absolutely
good to see you guys we are finally
entering the final stretch of these
three incredible national championships
and the action is only hitting up let's
take a look at who our main protagonists
are in each of these three events and
we're going to start with the senior
section we see Grand Master melissette
caccion we just zoned in on that focused
man as you can see I'm blemished in the
tournament so far only a drawing round
three he had some luck along the way but
you need luck in order to perform at
five and a half out of six possible
points that's just an incredible line
score that we see this is the tournament
of his life and he could potentially
clinch the title today so let's see
what's going to happen in today's rounds
as you can see he's focused he knows
what's at stake he's waiting for his
opponent and what an illustrious
opponent he has I mean look at the road
ahead today he's going to be facing Kai
danov in round eight Patrick Wolfe and
in round nine Alexander shabalov the
defending U.S Senior champion and by the
way kaidanov if he wins against malicide
and you know he's going to try to do so
he is only going to be one point behind
the leader going the final two so big
big matchup in round seven let's see
what's happening in the U.S junior girls
this is a one lady story and that is
freedom Master Alice Lee she is bringing
to the table so much experience at only
13 years of age right now also I'm
blemished as you can see we're
following from Malik said going straight
into another leader and by the way she
is leading with five points out of six
she is ahead of her nearest competitor
half a point ahead of Zoe tang and one
and a half points ahead of a player that
she will be facing today and that is
Carissa Yip in round eight Iris move and
in round nine Shreya mangalam but I have
to say today's round with the black
pieces against Carissa if I mean this
one is going to be a huge huge clash and
what's happening in the junior section
you might be wondering well this one is
much tighter at the top as you can see
three players are sharing the Kohli
davimanyu Mishra Andrew Hong and
arturuguo the only one undefeated in the
tournament so far is abhimanyu and I
have to say he escaped some difficult
positions uh you don't have to go uh far
in the past yesterday
he escaped in such a difficult end game
I have to say he was two moves away from
pretty much going into a resignable
position unfortunately for Kirk gazarian
he wasn't able to find the final blow
and ABI Manu escape with a draw today he
will be facing this young man right here
Artur actually this is one of the
co-leaders as well he's been having an
amazing Stellar event he could have
easily gone on a four out of four in
fact he's not facing abhimanyu he's
facing Andrew Hong this is the Battle of
the co-leaders Andrew Hong put a lot of
pressure yesterday against Balaji
dagupati unfortunately with the white
pieces with the clock ticking down he
wasn't able to find the finishing
touches and right now he is going into
this one with the black pieces on equal
ground with arturagua and abhimanyu
Mishra guys we have some amazing battles
ahead of ourselves let's I'm excited for
round seven guys me too no question
about it those are key matchups but Kate
do the honors as we see the players
coming in to the tournaments really
find his place is he playing in the main
hall or in the Attic he's wondering the
same thing he's trying to find his board
right there he is there it is
let's take a look at the parents right
let's start with the girls junior so we
have Wu against Atwell Leo against tab
tank now the big matchup Yip against Lee
Marquee matchup for sure as the two
favorites in the tournament face off
right then Mo against Xi'an and mangalam
against prasanna and tell us about the
appearance for the juniors in the
Juniors Mishra against Wang Zhu again
gazarian Deku party against Liang go
against honk that's the key matchup here
absolutely and Stillman against Jacobson
and the seniors we know one right so we
start with a root against loogie and
here we go kaidanov against kachian wow
I'm very excited to see how this game is
gonna go against
shabalov against Benjamin it's a big
match right and akopian against Navica
they've been fighting hard what have the
players been fighting for Kate they are
fighting for a very general first prize
fund so in the girls junior Championship
we have twenty thousand dollar prize
fund with first place taking home six
thousand dollars all the way to ten
Place five hundred dollars
and uh for the juniors yeah and the
Juniors the price one is forty thousand
dollars and first place is gonna win
twelve thousand dollars all the way to
ten Place one thousand dollars there
and we have the Champions bonus right no
the seniors first let's go for the
teachers all right that's that's a
really big price one seventy five
thousand dollars with first place
winning 20 000 and last place three
thousand dollars still a very nice
paycheck yeah I was looking at the
Players they're getting so excited uh we
are too as around seven some very very
important matchups is uh
some of them are there very early but
now we are really about to start to
first move he's been having some
difficulties with white pieces
especially in the opening getting an
advantage out of the opening uh a lot of
the players said uh it was predictable
in his opening choices let's see if
Justin Wang will be able to take
advantage of that predictability as well
E2 E4 oh that's different we've seen I
believe D4 in the last game played
enthusiastically Justin didn't even
write down that no
it was like he was ready
by the way uh in the game of Carissa yep
and Alice Lee we're seeing a center wow
counter with E4 and D4 that's very very
unexpected here well in Queen C4 that's
not an opening you see very often it
it's funny I always thought that the
move d4 was wrong and uh let me use uh
because I thought that you with it with
white you needed to nurse an advantage
you can't just create one by force
because we're even you know we've got
two equal alarm and the move d2d4 was to
me is an attempt to force onto a
position when black hasn't done anything
wrong and that was why I always thought
that this line with Queen uh Queen takes
D4 was uh premature the players are
playing so fast I was about to say I
mean everybody knows everything
30 seconds per move you can you can take
a take five seconds here and there to
just just think about your move but no
they know what they are doing well they
are snapping out the moves and I must
say this move so again Alice is playing
like she knows exactly what she's doing
so we'll leave it to her but if you gave
me this position and said okay what are
your candidate moves and I would have to
go a little bit deep a7a5 it is not the
immediate candidate move that I would
think about I think a lot of players
would be reaching for the deep deep on
here to play D6 and Bishop E6 I'm
thinking Christian that a5's theory oh
yes and in fact the top engine move in
the position wow Alice definitely knows
what she's doing well A5 is a
multi-purpose move right because you're
not only defending defending the bishop
and potentially threatening ideas of
Knight to E5 now that the bishop is no
longer on pre but he also have ideas of
potentially following it up with A4 A3
at the right moment right you will be
attacking the white King on the queen
side so A5 makes a lot of sense
and of course most likely you're going
to follow it up later on with D6 Bishop
E6 or Knight to E5 the idea is that you
mentioned yeah sir but A5 cannot be a
move that hurts Black's position okay
take us through what the precepts of
theory suggests that white I wouldn't I
wouldn't well first of all this position
hasn't been reached that many times
right and uh A5 I think there is only a
couple of games in fact D6 four games in
this position A6
um three games and A5 2 games G4 by the
way was played still the best move in
the position and perhaps both of these
players are actually very much aware of
what to do P5
computer moves and these are the best
computer moves it takes D5 Knight E5
this is what we're expecting upon
sacrifice
the question is how are you going to
follow it up after a queen to D4 you
don't want to go to E2 obviously because
that's going to open up any sort of
attacks on the e-file to F4 sure you can
go there but maybe the queen on F4 is
not going to be uh well placed it seems
like C6 is a very powerful move
the question is what if I just simply
take B take C6 so just simple chests
like this now we see the bishop on B4
nicely protected by the pawn on A5 the
queen doesn't really have a task the
queen is just going to be attacked by
black species Knight to G6 maybe at the
right moment Knight to D5 or Bishop
takes C3 and then Knight to D5 black
seems to have a lot of play and it's
still quite unclear how are you going to
develop your pieces on the king side
Bishop to D3 doesn't work because of
Knight on uh because of the Knight on E5
maybe Knight to E2 but if you do that
Rook to B8 once again how do you
continue your development where is your
attack because I know where my attack is
my attack is on the B file my attack is
against your king where is your attack
you've launched this uh Pawn forward the
G Pawn but I don't have any weaknesses
you need to have something to attack
with you need to have something to hook
with the G Pawn potentially a Pawn on H6
that's not there right so you still need
plenty of moves to materialize your
attack and in the meantime I'm just
checkmating you on the queen side this
one is look I mean look Alice knows what
she's doing this is why it's quite
surprising and this is a psychological
blow for Carissa because
you play e45 D4 you at least hope you're
going to surprise your opponent right
right because almost nobody plays this
and then at least comes
out novelty is the best Novelties in the
position in this obscure line a counter
sacrifice with D5 I mean this is just
incredible play an incredible knowledge
by Alice Lee I mean talk about guesswork
because okay what I do know about the
Center calendar and it is very limited
knowledge I want to say but I like on
move four uh Queen E3 is by far exactly
most that's the main line I thought
that's the only movie that's actually
absolutely and then you play Queen C4
and your opponent immediately hits you
with every you know
um uh engine generated uh
reinforced move tape it's kind of
ridiculous Queen to D4 and now C6 is
still the best move if I you had
mentioned that Queen F4 yeah you don't
want to go there but Queen D4 keeping
your queen nicely centralized make a lot
of sense to me yes and then immediately
again you were talking about 30 seconds
I don't need no 30 seconds I know
exactly what I'm doing bang C7 C6
in the words of Walter Brown immediately
immediately Bishop to F4 I mean these
ladies know exactly what they're doing
Bishop F4
down and we don't have time to analyze
it because he plays so fast wow wow yeah
give us a chance to do our commentary
right okay tell us what's going on after
we I mean they're just following the top
Engine line wow which before Queen takes
C3 and now Knight takes D5 most likely
going to come in a matter of seconds 30
seconds boom boom Knight takes D5 and
I'm assuming the Queen's gonna go back
to D4
very quickly so if I take the Knight
Bishop takes E5 I'll be very happy for
you to capture the queen on C3 right to
go into like two pieces I will capture
the queen on oh you will you're not
gonna give a check no check I think F4
would be okay so if you take I take the
queen on d8
take on the eighth
I will take on A2 first
you go King B1 I take on d8
you take I give you a check on E6 and
then I go route to D1 yeah
wow but look at how fast Knight takes G4
let's just sorry I mean we we've only
looked at one game round seven we knew
round seven was going to be a Barn
Burning but boy talk about what's going
okay just snap snap Queen D4 Knight
takes G4 a la Tempo incredible uh Chris
absolutely incredible help the best move
once again this is a peace sacrifice
right because after F takes G4 I will
take back on G4 I don't have any big
blows that's going to immediately
recapture my piece but I just simply
take on G4 and that's that's it that's
enough for enough for compensation
incredible absolutely incredible opening
preparation by Alice Lee I have no idea
how she guessed this D4 right I have no
idea how she gets Queen to C4 to this
obscure line Queen to E3 as you
mentioned is the main line by far and
the Christian computers evaluation after
taking the night during capturing you
don't want to take it night no no no I
don't want to take this it's already
lost
oh wow if you take the Knight it's lost
because I don't have a good score for
the Rook right it's two pawns but also
this guy's hanging you've got uh Bishop
takes D1 I mean it's not you can't move
the Rook because the check
and if we put something in the way you
just take it
uh let let's just see this so if you
take it take it C4 I'm assuming there's
some horrible refutation to this
I'm assuming
what's the hardware what's the horrible
refutation to this
let's try to figure it out
where is the refutation
so I have a couple of ideas can I go
Queen F6 Queen F5
that might just be
bad news
[Music]
I have rookie four but I'm ah Rook D2
rookie I'm much more worried about
Bishop to D2
that's three pawns ah Rook C8 is coming
yeah yeah that might be a problem and I
can play Bishop C3 to block that because
I open up that room
what a crazy prep oh my word
well I we we knew it was going to be a
bar and burner coming into today's round
but we've got so many key match-ups of
that I mean our attention has been
focused here let's just go to uh Malik
set for oops sorry that wasn't supposed
to happen uh I wanted to see what
Gregory Gregory kaidanoff is in one of
those situations if you wants to compete
for first he's got to win with the white
pieces full stop A7 A6 it is like the
turbulence variation of the slob defense
with B7 B5 at one time this was actually
a very popular line of play for black
but like so many things in uh opening
Theory it just kind of fell out of
fashion I certainly don't know why A2 A4
by Gregory
um Christian I'm not really aware of
this move a2a4 in this specific position
it's a bit of a sideline yes
it's very much a sideline Bishop to E2
seems to be the main Yeah by far yeah
right yes by far H3 also move Bishop D2
A4 is all the way down at three percent
of the moves
um being played in this one 56 games in
my database with the move A4 it kind of
asks for an immediate reaction right
right are you going to take on C4 are
you going to go B4 like how are you
going to deal with this tension I
suppose B4 to just before is the main
line yes push the Knight away yes B4 is
the main line Knight to E2 right seems
to be the right way to continue after
that
and exactly the 92 comes with an
immediate threat that is Knight to E5
exactly you don't want to see that with
the tempo right so most likely you have
to go Knight bd7 and the way you go from
here well we'll definitely keep an eye
on this I just want to make a quick take
a quick oh he played B4 yes yeah on the
board so yeah I want to take a quick uh
glance at the Jacobian versus Igor
novikov game because this is this is one
of those and there are so many lines of
the night off that are incredibly sharp
and you know like Razor's Edge type of
moves Bishop H3 the idea here is as
clear as a bell you want to play G4 you
want to play Knight F4 and yes
you want to sacrifice it a piece on E6
Square whether it be the bishop on H3 or
the
um uh knight uh on D4 at one one time
until the move Bishop H3 was discovered
it was always felt that if black could
play B5 B4
chase the night away play d65 you
equalize right because it's not so easy
like if if the Rook were for example on
G1 here here it'd be very clear you'd
play G5 so that when I take you can't
recapture with the Knight since we don't
have that until the move Bishop H3 was
discovered the black was considered to
be safe but once Bishop H3 and G4 became
played then
this variation took off yeah and white
really doesn't care if black captures
the pawn on e4 right right I think there
was a capture but just go immediately
there was a game of Peter laco very
important game uh I think one of the the
world championship in Mexico I'm not
sure if I'm remembering that correctly
but yeah this was uh very very sharp now
the move played by Igor Knight D7 to B6
threatens Knight to C4
uh you kind of win a Tempo in terms of
being ill to defend the E6 pawn b2b3 and
I'm telling you they're playing really
really quickly so I'll tell you exactly
why look at this position yeah
this is from a copian versus novikov U.S
Senior Championship 2022. there we go
there's a recipe here so they're
repeating what they played last year
that one novikov made an immediate
mistake he played the move Knight to E5
which is giving as you can see the
question mark is giving white the
advantage after uh Bishop to F4 G5 is
also a move that takes the initiative
into White's hands so this was
definitely a bad bad move for black
yesterday yeah yeah now we have Knight
to B6 which is the main line yesterday
in fact so definitely something but
novikov stopped for a second so perhaps
he did not anticipate that acopian is
going to repeat what they played last
year exactly what they played last year
because right now he's starting to think
once again and we've seen he was ready
but Knight to E5 probably was the first
time that he started thinking in uh last
year's game and he made a mistake with
that one he got a losing position but
guess what he in fact turned that game
around and won that game I believe it
was round one or round two if I'm not
mistaken
um but big game that was a copy and
definitely had good and bad memories
from that one because he had a winning
position he ended up losing he's
definitely trying to get the winning
position in this one as well and I have
to say I mean last game for a Coke from
acopian was just a masterpiece against
Maxim loogie he's definitely riding that
high riding that boost of confidence and
right now with the white pieces he needs
to make a move he needs to win and he's
continue winning in order to be able to
catch potentially the leader
after pause uh Igor played the move E6
E5 and we saw Vladimir just walking
around he's like he hasn't sat at the
board it seems he's displayed all of his
theoretical moves and after the move E5
Christian what uh what
this Theory say about the position
well it's interesting Knight to F5 at
least according to my database is the
only move that has ever been played
right
um but King to B1 doesn't seem to be a
terrible move
just a peace sacrifice you just want to
ignore that the Knight is attacked and
just what you want to do and you're not
even supposed to take that you're you're
supposed to go Bishop C5 I'm expecting
Knight F5 I don't think we're going to
seeking to be one any sort of crazy
stuff I think we're just going to go
with Knight F5 which is by far the main
line then black has some options you can
take on F5 can engage in that trade or
you can take on e4
um still it seems like perhaps
Vladimir is not aware of the fact that
it's his move Igor made a move
it's a championship girl
around to see what's happening on those
boards well he's looking at Melissa he's
looking at the leader right now he wants
to see what's happening in that game
that's the big one uh well for me
capturing on F5 I play E4 takes F5 and
I'm thinking you know white is ready to
you know
blast open the center and yeah if you if
you do play a move like D4 a moment ago
you were going to talk about a peace
sacrifice this one looks
very very attractive
I I'm thinking that this is like a super
sharp variation and you're just like
saying yeah you can play King B1 and I'm
like what
is the main line by far so I is the only
move that has been played before
right but you you didn't give us any
variations you just said Knight F5 is
the main move well it's a big question
are you going to take on e4 and I still
have look I need some time to go through
the variation so that I don't feed the
nonsense I don't I don't ever want
videos you know what I mean I want to
feed you beautiful variations you have
to give me some time yesterday
C4 seems to be the main line and now
white has a couple of options F4 is one
of them try to blast open the center
like that or you can go Knight eg3
reinforce tonight on F5 now if you
continue taking good luck defending this
one after a G5 everything opens up I
have Knight D6 coming into play I have
the other night jumping to E4 once for
example Knight to D7 I2 E4 something is
going to land on D6 and that's not going
to be good news for your king so this
one is looking really I mean look how
beautiful these lights are in the center
so definitely big big uh tasks defensive
tasks ahead of them sells both of them
by the way because white has to
calculated a lot of variations if he
doesn't know them already and Igor right
now he's signaling with his thinking
that perhaps he's not remembering every
single detail Bishop takes F5 was his
choice yeah I like that get rid of that
Knight you know what get rid of that
Knight empty the CH Square for my Rook I
can start seeing some potential for
black species as well for an attack on
the C file and I really don't like to
have that Knight on F5 hovering around
my my king
uh thank you Christian let's just jump
to the junior uh tournament and pick up
our tournament co-leaders Kate Arthur
versus Andrew hung uh
Bishop B5 check kind of like a signal
that you don't want to go into the open
sicility and you want to avoid a
theoretical battle then after Knight D7
you do want to go and do an open
Sicilian and you don't want some
Sidelines a little bit exactly C5 takes
D4 Queen takes D4
a7a6 Bishop E2 so a little bit of a
difference a little bit of a wrinkle
here if you had played D4
C takes D4 Queen takes D4 Knight C6
Bishop B5 you're going to be forced to
part with your light Square Bishop yeah
yeah and that's a actually a very nice
variation I've been playing it for so
many years to check over variation but
by by playing Bishop B5 check revoking
the Knight to D7 now you get a variation
where you don't necessarily have to give
up your light Square Bishop but you did
give black this Tempo move A7 A6 Knight
F6 castles G6 Knight C3 Bishop G7 Rook
D1 castles now the players are moving
very quickly here so I'm assuming this
is all Theory uh that I don't know but
it looks like only after a goal is
playing fast right Andrew honk now 1
hour 16 minutes so either he started
thinking in this move or yeah he's been
thinking for 10 minutes so he was
probably not expecting move E5
uh I would say certainly not uh help me
out and tell me what I'm missing so if I
take
I'm assuming you're going to take with a
knight taking advantage of the pin so I
am not trading but I'm just wondering
about a very funky move Knight H5 uh so
I'm stopping Bishop F4 or at least I
think I'm stopping Bishop F4 and I want
to take this Knight
do you want to play what if I go F4 yeah
but that's the question is that a move
that you want in the position I mean I
don't know
uh if it's something we're happy with
um I think we are yeah because now we
have even 95 95 maybe
they're amazing I can start with D4 to
be super uh aggressive even B4 B4 yeah
also
I was
I was hoping that uh I I had this move
as an answer to B4 but your knight D5 is
also really off-putting right because
you're hitting E7 with the tempo and I
well if I take I'm I'm afraid you might
recapture take on E7 I don't know it's a
really really sharp game in this key
matchup of our tournament leaders Kate
right so we have three Wi-Fi for the
first place Andrew Hong and Arthur girl
with four points and here we have them
facing each other so very important game
for Arthur girl and Andrew Hong
absolutely and Arthur has been showing
very good opening preparation I have to
say um I cannot recount the last game
where he was not necessarily worse but
out prepared in the opening he's really
been showing Stellar opening preparation
and right now once again he's bringing
the fight to his opponent this is some
sort of some sort of obscure line as
well exactly not taking on E5 first but
Knight H5 it makes much more sense right
because there's no more F4 at least in
this position and this is just in fact a
pawn sacrifice I will go Queen to H4 you
take on E5 and now I have a couple of
funky moves one of them is Bishop to G5
this looks very natural but another one
is A4
just simple A4 stopping your counter
chances on uh the queen side the
expansion with B5 just playing for some
sort of a strategical Advantage I'm
trying to take away squares from your
pieces and saying that I have enough
time later on to develop my attack and
you don't have good squares for you once
again squares for your pieces Queen to
C7 is met with Knight to D5 Queen to A5
I would assume I'm going to take
directly on E7 right Rhys
re-stabilize the material balance in the
position and that's going to be very
good for white so very intriguing
position what I'm worried about is that
Andrew is spending a lot of time right
now and this is not an easy position to
navigate with the black pieces
definitely a lot of pressure on Arthur
on Andrew and Arthur I have to say has
won the opening battle
wow uh wow what a pawn sacrifice I I
mean I'm a long long long time player
boy ages ago a different lifetime ago I
love to play the Dragon
and the reason I like to play the dragon
because I fell in love with the name
but everyone everybody doesn't want to
play the dragon you know come on you
want to play the dragon I mean you got
to be cool right so playing the dragon
and being upon up my goodness I mean
yeah I would I would think that this
position is very good for uh for for
black but it's like this movie
I mean that's that's powerful true but
you know like it's it's a strange thing
um
I don't really see weaknesses in the
position I do have a problem though like
if I try to you know bring my knight
back you'll recapture the pawn and I'm
thinking I know it looks stupid but I
want to play you know ideas of of this
and just ask you what you want to do if
you go A5 that's okay I mean you you you
you take some squares over there on the
on the key on the queen side
E6 Queen C7
I don't know F7 F6 looks a little bit
strange but
for the moment I'm just giving myself
selfless square and if I have to go to
F4 and you take twice and then I'll
follow it up with E5
I don't know Kate you tell me yeah it's
an interesting move what's your initial
take uh do you like the pawn sacrifice I
do I do like that you like The Rook on
D1 you like the pressure and the bishop
won C8 it's going to take time before
that guy is developed Knight on H5 I
kind of like your F6 move though trying
to get the Knight to F4 and holding on
to that pawn since you at least got it
something for that you know active voice
pieces look if you're gonna suffer for
the extra fun you might as well suffer a
whole hug right I mean go all in and
this game for the uh for for our
tournament co-leaders I mean it's very
very promising Christian what other
games have caught your attention as we
puzzle over this Pawn sacrifice well
another big one is the one between
abimanu and Justin Wang and let's take a
look at what's happening in this one and
we've talked about abimanu being caught
in the opening just in one definitely
tried to do that as well in today's game
and he essayed the they're a Russian
defense which I'm sure came as a slight
surprise for abimani but take a look at
this at this point after Bishop to G5
Queen to C7 one hour and 35 minutes for
Justin Wang 1 hour and 29 for abhimani
so abhimani knew what he's doing as well
C4 is the main line in the position and
I'm sure this was something that
probably black has prepared ahead of
time Bishop to E8 follows up Queen to H4
Queen to H3 with taking on C4 and then
covering up with Bishop to F7 it leads
to a position which gets simplified and
in general is considered to be quite
close to equality but right now I'll be
Mario chooses Rook to E3 a very
interesting option I have to say and if
you it's very important how you react
right now if you react with Bishop to E8
which is what you were doing after C4
this doesn't work anymore because now
you don't have time to cover up E7 and
uh weaknesses on the e-file Queen to age
for supporting Bishop E7 Bishop to F7 or
Bishop to G6 let's say Bishop to G6 you
don't want to give up the F5 pawn bishop
to E7 Rook to E8 but now I have Rook to
E1 right that's why you put the Rook on
E3 first not only you want to swing it
on the H file and create mating attack
on the H file but also you want to put a
lot of pressure on the E file so I
really like what white is doing in this
position this move Rook to E3 has
stopped Justin Wang from one hour and 35
minutes he's down to one hour and 18 so
close to a 20 minute think right now
he's trying to figure out the details uh
in the position what changed with this
move to E3 Justin will have to spend
some time we'll have to spend some
mental resources try to understand
exactly what changed and how to respond
to it and a Christian talking about deep
think when we look at a game Carissa yep
and Alice Lee
curry sauce stuck I mean she's thinking
for 20 minutes
I mean I think before that's that's a
very I guess unexpected move and I mean
what a great preparation from honestly
and Carissa is just thinking I would be
yes I I would be absolutely stuck too I
mean
you guys saw the variations after Knight
to G4 but by the way I'm being told
gazarian is in fact losing in this
position
what just happened
wow take a look at this so night we C4
was the last move Bishop takes C4
right now if you taking to B1 this is
supposed to be losing I'm I'm trying to
wrap my mind around this why is it so
bad it has Echoes of the game between a
cobium and a novikov right the 95 Knight
C4 right yeah right but losing but why
is it plus three plus three I'm trying
to understand why right if you continue
development I understand now I go G5 and
you have some problems on the D file
right with the queen already on C4 but
what if I just simply go D6 right okay
this is a very natural way of I still
put it I still continue with G5 let's
say you go if you go Knight to D7 I have
a feeling maybe even G6 yeah and then B3
and then you lose on e60s
now I understand
I understand right but really is it that
bad but then I've got to ask King B1
okay if uh Queen C7 G5
H5 what would you like to do the queen
C7 Queen C7 yes G5 Knight H5
I'm assuming you take I would take yes
G6
and I say Bishop G5 right and
here I'm just a pawn down and
a pawn down and the problem is that
you're also getting viciously attacked
that's that that's the big problem in
the position yeah right there's Knight
takes B5 if you go right take take and
now I actually take five years
Queen is coming to before we check night
come on
yeah this is very very difficult and he
took on C4 with the queen
I mean guys this is really really bad if
King to B1 is plus three and gazerian is
speeding into this losing position one
hour and 27 minutes he's playing a la
tempo right and Christian is there a big
difference if I don't start with King B1
and I just start with G5 what assume not
but let's see okay so if you start with
G5 apparently B4 is a way to create
counter play
because the A2 Pawn is hanging oh so you
have to uh just focus on the defense
first and the problem is I think B4 is
going to be met with Knight A4 and I'm
not sure you're defending uh the B6
Square exactly Queen C7 I continue with
G5 yeah this one is looking really bad
so King B1 tucking the king in just
allows you to meet B4 with Knight A4
yeah yeah it takes away the one threat
that black has in the position the pawn
on H6 is a big problem yeah the hook
because exactly it's the hook right once
I go to G5 you have other either the
option of giving me the H6 spawn which
is simply going to be a pawn up or
opening up the H file which is equally
as bad because once the H file opens up
you're not castled I have my Rook on H1
ready to pounce on the H file this one
is looking really bad for black indeed
now the more I look at it the more I
start understanding how bad this is okay
uh going back to our game of Carissa uh
Yip and Alice Lee again this great
rivalry uh Alice has actually gained
five minutes on her clock right
let's be very very clear she's gained
time on her clock try somewhere to move
Knight E2 and basically Carissa has said
the problem is capturing the Knight is
simply great for Alice and she said okay
I'm gonna sacrifice upon pretend like I
had it all prepared as well I mean I'm
getting a room T1
and I'll get some compensation plus by
the way at this exact moment you might
say Carissa's got the two Bishops so
she's got a compensation but does she
Christian does she have a compensation
uh Carissa or was it upon blunder
no she doesn't have a compensation well
I mean it very much depends on what
Alice is going to do next Alex has the
opportunity of creating continuing to
create threats with a very powerful move
Queen to H4
wind H4 wind wage for not an easy move a
very hidden move at least to my eyes
clearly uh but it has a clear threat
right Knight to F2 so if we take then by
the way Queen to H4 seems to be the only
move uh gives black the advantage but if
you don't play it white has the
advantage whoa yes so important critical
moment right now I mean Alice is ready
to make a move I mean this is yeah I
feel like she she was expecting that she
was getting ready I mean
does she know everything she's only 13
years
she solves chess what is this
so Queen H4 I'll take the Knight okay
you take the Knight I take with the
bishop I continue and I'll go Rook G1
because I vacated the G G1 square and a
moment ago I was trying to coordinate a
mate and now I go ad8
and you just played like hey like
nothing is happening exactly finishing
development getting all the pieces to
join the party I have to say this is
really really difficult this is really
difficult stuff this is not normal chess
alien chess I I don't think this is easy
to find over the board if you don't know
it I mean pretending here that like okay
black is pieced down but compensation
like you know what you're doing uh wow
okay so I I kind of get it I kind of
understand that maybe you know you've
got threats of taking and taking on D1
so if I just say okay my Bishop's a
Target I get out of Dodge
I make a pin and by the way you can't
take the Knight because of the pin but
also mate and if you move the Knight I'm
gonna take the bishop
you've got to play 93 right normally I
would be quite
um
supportive of this move Knight to it
when karissa's chances practical chances
the problem is
the more I look at the position I don't
see any other moves for black but this
queen to H4 followed by Rook Adas
you cannot go back to E5
you cannot go to F6 because of C4
so you don't really have moves in the
position right if you don't go Queen to
H4 Knight F6 C4 you lose a piece 95 you
lose a piece knight issue is six
obviously you don't want to do that
Knight to E3 I just simply take on E3
you cannot do that you're pinned right
so you cannot move the Knight
at least we established that and I think
that's an important thing to establish
right for uh for black I mean you can do
move like B5 right just stopping C4 uh
but then maybe you actually capped
over the early capture the inclusion of
b592 hugely improves White's position
because of this move Rook G1 right
having the queen on H4 so the d8 square
is vacated and The Rook can get there
I'm still like at a loss to I I'm I'm
struggling to understand this position
after Rook d8 Bishop D2 I suppose you're
gonna win my queen with Knight E3 but
yes 93 that is it but what's the body
count here isn't it so how do you do it
you take take and now the question is
how do I defend that G7 Pawn maybe I
don't even have to you're just gonna
take can I take oh but then we have the
Rook takes I know that was what I was
thinking this is what I was thinking
crazy position right right
but there's no nothing to say
amazing there's no Checkmate uh amazing
that much to established what if you
take with the bishop wow
wow so uh what a preparation by the way
this is the first thing that Alice's
made since Carissa
started the game right first thought of
Alice Lee actually in the game
everything else that was just but again
memory look the engine is saying Alice
is doing amazing in this position only
with Queen H but it's not easy guys it
really is not because Queen to H4 check
this uh sequence out okay Queen not only
that you have to worry about taking on
G4 and Rook to G1 but what do you do
after Bishop D2
actually kind of curious what your
immediate reaction is spinning
the only move
is Queen F2 yeah you have to sit right
not easy right this queen to H4 followed
by Queen to F2
all these moves you know
with the engine it's easy to understand
them right but without their
applications
yeah yeah
so yeah I think Alice is going to spend
a little bit more time I started at one
moment she was ready to play but I think
now she is still needing more time so
help me out once more I apologize here
Queen H4 yes Rook to G1
okay he wrote the G1 that's I guess it's
Knight F6 that's a different movie yes I
go Knight F6 now I do there's no more C4
yeah so Queen to H4 not only that you're
creating threats you're also dodging
this pin on the D file very wow
there's no more C4 because I was really
banking on C4 actually C4 Knight I
wanted to chase the Knight to the B4
Square go Bishop G5 Force the trade of
queens and
I yeah sorry just to just to put it on
the board for a moment
no it's time for Alice to go in the tank
um she probably did not analyze this
because again it's a bad move according
to the engine it doesn't show whenever
you analyze this position
it and right now she will have to figure
it out over over the board it's it's
always frustrating when you when you
have a great piece of preparation your
opponent doesn't go through the main
line it's like just like the main line
uh sorry let's just go to around the uh
the the tournament hall for the girls
Championship because Zoe's in the
competition too and she's competing very
very well thank you for asking what
about me uh let's see what happened as a
Lapin with h2h3 and yes if you if you
wanted to ask what happens if you take
the font don't do that I've only lost
like three or four games like this you
know maybe more actually this has really
occurred to me I'm not ashamed to admit
that I have fallen for the old double
attack we used to call this the Danny
kopeck system uh where we put the bishop
out early it's kind of a funny line
because it's so transpositional if I
showed you this position at the start
well just this position you go oh yeah
this looks like a normal chest but then
if I showed you how we got here you'd go
like what what are you doing Bishop D3
D5
transposing into elephant right and I
think we saw similar position Zoe
playing already right once with the long
Castle the Knight on A3 but this is this
is not supposed to be a good line for
for black where you develop the queen
too early because we're supposed to be
able to play Knight
to D2 and Knight to
C4 pudding you know we we put pressure
on the E5 pawn and it's it's not that
easy for black with the Knight on F6 to
play yeah I know G5 G4 just really
quickly let's go why not
You're Gonna Play G4 yes wow severe
capture I'm gonna recapture with my
knight and then I'm defending the E5
three times exactly very happy but here
you can take right yes
this is frustrating it and if I go
I don't have time to play Bishop takes
E6 in this position okay so no Bishop B3
I think it's G4 Knight takes G4 okay
Bishop takes is an option but let's say
good night first
um
where am I supposed to I don't know what
I'm supposed to do Bishop to B3 or
I don't know if I'm worried about your
king side attack or not uh but let's say
I go Bishop to B3 in order to trade here
so you can take on D3 right
so yay I've got this great idea yay yay
and something like this I'm very happy
about my Pawns
uh it's a compensation but it's an
interesting uh line G5 G4 and well we'll
keep an eye on this one let's just go
around again iris's Iris versus
uh something calm yeah the players are
just
chill chill okay but the last yeah
that's not calm
what's going on today any weather there
okay this has actually become popular
and I've been seeing that this was an
old old ideas about vinic Petrosian
they're going back into the uh
Dusty part of the chess library here
with this G4 H4 business
Bishop E2 Knight H3 G5 look at this with
G5 so I can talk I can take it and
passant but maybe I'm actually helping
black with that right H take black is
Happy are we sure that black is happy
I mean it looks strange right that we
could uh how come we can't take
advantage of the open app file
he asks
puzzled in non-understanding I guess you
go G5 yeah
weird stuff let's just see the game
position because that was a really
impactful visual when we came into the
position F5 dang
crush on G4 that makes sense clear well
if if white is has to go into a
defensive posture
because there's also like Knight C4
right I'll be happy if you trade your
light Square Bishop because maybe then
the pawns or night squares I know every
week well it just seems somehow that
well black is dictating things here at
the moment and again F5 on the board uh
Rochelle on the back foot let's go let's
go to uh sharia's game with Gracie
and Bishops of opposite color and crazy
I I know that this is a favorite
variation of Ding and laryn and he plays
the Black side of this and he has really
good results and every time I look at
the position I think black is bad it
like has a bad position yeah it feels
because the video D5 looks really nice
the bishop on F6 on the other hand
white can go F4 G4 right I feel like I
would prefer a white here as well except
being Lauren does really good with it
Gracie's just played the move Queen back
to C7 which is okay
intriguing
um we'll keep an eye on this one
um
Christian I want to toss it over to you
and I'm today's games are very puzzling
I mean I'm really struggling to keep
things I have to say because we have so
many intriguing games and so many crazy
openings right and I will try to take
you through as many as I can take a look
at this so Rook to E3 was played that we
were discussing about C4 and Rook to E3
being the second best movie in the
position the second most played move in
the position but definitely something
that created some unpleasantries for
Justin because he didn't know how to
react but he did react quite well after
a very long thing Rook to F7 makes a lot
of sense the threat was Rook to H3 you
have to find a way to defend the H7 Pawn
you don't want whenever The Rook is
landing on H3 to go H6 because after
Bishop takes H6 most likely you you will
enjoyed right this is pretty much over
so we don't want to see that you want to
play G6 that's why now we see the Rook
on F7 so it makes sense very good
reaction by Justin Wang not only that
but remember what was the weak Square in
that Bishop to E8 line the E7 square
right so right now with the Rook on E7
you no longer have ideas of Bishop to E7
at least they're not coming as easy and
immediately
I'll be one who plays the move C4 great
move still following some sort of uh his
preparation and uh again asking black
how are you going to react and it seems
like the best reaction which is very far
from natural in the position is C5
C4 C5 and guess what the next move is
for white
Rook E1
yeah
because this is theory and I think
abhimanyu is very much aware of this
Theory point of rookie one like just
getting out of Dodge of C takes D4
basically and you don't want to do C3
instead yes I don't think you want to do
C3 because I can take and then take on
you take take I take on C4 right right
and the queen is defending the pawn on
C4 so you don't have time for that the
question is why wouldn't you start with
this it takes D5 and the answer is
because you have to wait for me to First
Take on D4 otherwise I go C4 I don't
take the pawn on D4 I go C4 I pass by
now you go Bishop to it or Bishop to F1
F4 it seems like black has a lot of
compensation and your attack is pretty
much over because without the bishopon
D3 is going to be very difficult to
control my expansion on the queen on the
king side with the move F4 right which
is going to help my case quite a lot
because once I get that four on the
board first of all Bishop on G5 life
it's not that easy to get it back home
right Rook F5 potentially targeting that
Bishop 25 Bishop 5 Bishop G6 I finally
find a way to activate my pieces in the
position so this one is looking like a
great version and a great sacrifice for
a black you have to wait a couple of
moves but by the way none of this is
going to win A5 because we have a move
on the board Queen to A5 this has been
played once three years ago four years
ago in 2019 I would assume this was some
sort of Correspondence game
decent move according to the engine the
question is
um I think this is a very good move
because it throws abhimanyu out of his
theory it's a very obscure line Queen to
A5 only played once I don't think I'll
be Manu has analyzed this
so yeah
enjoying 25 minutes time Advantage yes
yes so he he definitely finally
he's having a game out of the opening
right he hasn't been he's not facing any
sort of like 30 move deep Theory anymore
now they're on their own great I like
and we didn't mention it but also uh
there's a bonus for the winners of the
Juniors the Champions bonus because the
winners of the Juniors and junior girls
will be awarded a 10 000 scholarship
generously jointly funded by the Duane
Barber foundation and U.S chess and
along with that we get an automatic
qualification to the US and U.S women's
championships in October that's a
fantastic opportunity right okay
I love the game that's going on between
Gregory and malikset I mean talk about a
battle for first place and it's one of
those positions where you can look at
the position from both players and say
these are my trunks this is terrific
look at me I'm doing really really well
and in this position the last move was
Bishop E2 I I had stopped myself right
here and I was thinking to myself okay
I'm a pond Grabber you know what I'm
going to do I'm going to play the move
E5 I'm going to drive the Knight pack
you're supposed to go either to H7 or G8
you're not sure yeah you go G8 I go see
so I can have maybe h8 H6 F5 exactly and
you're going to take my Pawn so your
Pawn up you've doubled my pawns
everything's really beautiful until you
start noticing that there are issues uh
you're not going to be able to I'm going
to win this Pawn on B4 back once I win
the pawn on B4 back I might be playing
Rook B6 right and this is a type of a
position where if I'm on the black side
I can say look at this I went upon I've
done this I've done this I like this and
then if I'm on the white side I go yeah
but I've done this yes always I love
this bag has something yeah something
something that they can cheer themselves
on about but what we do have instead of
this sequence with C5 and E5 is the move
Bishop E2 Gregory is saying okay if you
try to move your knight too early there
might be a breakthroughs after some five
and I'll blow open the position uh your
first initial
take when you see this position yeah I'm
wondering what black wants to do with
his King because Castle in short side
looks very natural right I'm a little
bit maybe slightly worried about the G
file being open but the King on H7
should be pretty pretty safe the
question is whether I do want to Castle
my king or really start thinking about
grabbing the opponent H4 first exactly
so that is I think the big decision for
me if I just voluntarily go
well but do you like White's position or
do you like Black's position
kind of feel like white because I like
Center this three Pawn C4 D4 E4 in the
center are really strong right so I
think I would pick white okay intriguing
and again I I can make a very uh cogent
argument for you know why you should be
choosing black and and so on uh another
game I mean really if you want to talk
about Dusty libraries check out the game
between uh shabalov and Benjamin because
uh if you see this the first thing you
think about is the same is uh variation
of the nimso Indian where you play A3
you force him to take and for decades
top players world champions have been
debating whether these double pawns on
the C file are worth the loss of the two
Bishops and for shabalov he said okay
I'm going to build up this big Center
and I'm gonna play on the king side as
well I'm not a afraid of your playing
Knight A5 and capturing and I'm just
going to go all out on the king side as
is his want Knight to G4 maybe this move
is actually pulling the brakes just a
little bit as the move Knight A5 is
likely to be mad yeah I I I I like my
father I still like my boss
but I'm really curious about a copian
and novikov because when we left it that
was just great that was just a barn
burner going on you know Knight F5 tags
D4 Bishop F2 a copy and saying please
please let it be my move I'm going to be
playing ideas of f4 rookie one breaking
up the team in the center you've got to
do something and again both of those
things really fast like they were
noticed in this position one hour 26
minutes
G5 well now after F6 is only one hour
right Bishop C5 Queen D3
and F6 he's he spent some time on the
last few moves yes included novikov
novikov oh Slayers both players slowed
down acoubian still has an hour and 25.
well the copy and was walking around
like I got this i got this I want to see
what's happening there yeah let me go
check out everybody else so Igor spent
10 minutes on move Bishop C5 and 20
minutes on move F6 and by the way F2 F
pardon me F3 f4 on the board for uh this
is absolutely Wild
wild position
well vladimiracopian is still playing
fast one hour 25 minutes well my
question is where is Black supposed to
put his King I mean putting it King side
and a GH Rook G1 that looks suicide but
wait a minute castling give me that pawn
on A6 not to mention the fact that you
might be walking into something very
nasty leaving the king in the center
I think
I would just give up that phone I know
that's not what you would like to hear
Yesterday
make sure the king is safe but you think
the king is
the definition of a safety let me let me
introduce you to the Cairo Khan and the
and the Fort Knox variation of the
French defense uh this is I'm worried
about Black's King Igor's King here uh
Christian help us out where what's going
on yes yes but I mean I'm looking
through the lines this is such a crazy
position it's so difficult to play if
you don't know exactly what you are
doing for example yes we can go back a
couple of moves instead of Bishop to C5
at least to my eyes right now after G5
right the Main Moon should be Knight C3
yes right I'll go I'll I'll uh applaud
you for that yes now the question is
what do you do you go rookie one or do
you take on C3 I don't really want to
take on season you don't right I'm I'm
fearful that I'm exposing my king right
I was here as well yeah so let me let me
be crazy let me go F4 and you know just
pretend that the exchange sacrifice is
was intended
okay do you want me to go even crazier
you're not going to take I'm gonna
exchange I'm gonna go Knight C4
wow oh dear I I told you I didn't want
to expose my king and now you can see
what's going on uh boy I was hoping that
I was going to break down the center so
I could but you you're Landing just in
time and this is not the only move by
any stretch of the imagination but the
lines are absolutely wild questions E4
then finally you take on C4 and we go
into some sort of an end game
who knows how to assess this same game I
mean
the engine is saying zero zero as you of
course
theoretical draw nothing new
wow that's absolutely crazy
I'm wondering instead of playing F4 can
we just start sacrificing on D4 like I
don't know Knight takes D4 but did we
have we improved ourselves by have we
improved our
Castle
oh you can do that I can yes
wow
okay now I'm scared never mind no Knight
takes D4 well this long castle that's a
very strong move uh
yeah it's crazy and then you you might
be asking what about F6 and if you go
King B8 I have Knight C6 but I go King
B7 and there's nothing in that position
the bishop C it really is wild Bishop C5
uh maybe a lost Tempo F6 F4 and maybe
the initiative that white is enjoying I
can't say necessarily that Bishop C5 was
a lost Tempo
um it's developing it is developing it
does defend this D4 pawn and very often
as you were mentioning uh Cash Card
Knight takes D4 any sort of sacrifice of
the agenda might be unpleasant right so
you want to strengthen the sender with
Bishop C5 I think F6 was a bit uncalled
for F6 and it's difficult to call
uncalled for F6 right yeah
the center but you do lose some time and
F4 I think is a great reaction by a
copia the the best move in the position
instead of F6 would have been A5
try to start start your own counter play
on The Queen side you know this is a
move I understand
finally finally something okay you know
yeah I can deal with a check okay you
forced me to move my king but guess what
my Rook is actually you know somewhat
developed on the H file but A5 A4 golly
you know good old-fashioned also you
could also potentially long castles
sometimes and the pawn is not hanging
right the queen D3 F6 F4 I love this
Initiative for white quickly we're going
to go to Douglas root and Max uh delugie
because once again this is like an old
Indian uh it seems like the players
conspire together today to come to the
game and play uh stuff from the 1950s
and 60s but they are attacking we don't
see any boring positions not at all and
the move by the way uh the move F3 F4 is
Doug saying I'm tired of being a
punching bag I'm going to get in some
shots you know I'm not going to play
Rook B1 which I think a lot of people
would you know just defending the pawn
on B2 he's saying
uh
risk take the risk of capturing on B2
and maybe I'll try to trap your queen
after but wait can we trap it
immediately Knight A4 because the F1
took away the E5 Square which is so oh
excuse me you're right usually the
usually the queen
has E5 and Escape square but hold on if
I can't take uh oh then I've just got to
face the music that's coming with F4 F5
uh oh wait
uh
become a problem it's gonna be if let's
say I go Knight C5 Knight C5 let's go uh
Hog Wild let's go F5 so I do want to
take in The Rook uh attacks the Knight I
think I've provoked you to capture I
have to capture now I pause for just a
moment because there is a move Knight D4
I pause long enough to reject it
and I'll uh I'll Attack the bishop I
move the bishop away Bishop D7 or C8 I'm
not sure but Bishop d75 yes uh
you know this looks really
bad uh let's say B4 and
this King now I go Knight E4 dangerous
if I can get some compensation root
captures okay Tempo against the queen
I mean don't you feel drafty
a little bit like you don't have a King
shield Queen C7 not not so drafty yet
because I want to double up my Rooks
okay
help yourself all right Rook E7 Rook E7
I don't know Kate this is uh I'm just
feeling like the king wow and uh let's
just uh remind everybody about the
standings and where Doug and uh because
both Max and Doug are looking for
victories especially Max it's time for
the second place yeah he's saying come
on Gregory you can do it you can stop uh
Malik said and I'll be a point behind as
well if I can get a win but by the way
again I'm thinking uh the move F4 was a
really nice and fine move going to
finally uh Patrick Wolfe and Dimitri
gurvich looks to me like they've got a
theoretical position on the board I
remember Dimitri playing these
variations as black
through countless U.S championships he's
always liked these classical Sicilian
setups for himself and let me toss it
over to Christian and Christian what uh
what's caught your fancy well let's take
a look at this Arthur Sue versus Kirk
gazarion because he did take he did play
King B1 by the way take on C4 Quincy for
King to B1 best move in the position we
were discussing this exact line D6 G5
once again highlighting the problem over
the pawn on H6 this is the hook that I'm
going to base my whole play as white
around and this is exactly what he's
doing G5 Knight H5 this is the current
position on the board
thank God for them that they don't know
what the assessment is because Arthur
would be on cloud nine if he knew that
his Plus close to plus four in the
position right I mean this is absolutely
wild stuff
GTX H6 the simple GTX H6 take now I have
a plethora of options I can take on H6 I
can go yeah Rook G1 that's the one you
guys like oh I love that not only that
you're going to hint at potential uh
Invasion on the G file but also
you're stopping the knight from cycle G3
that's quite crucial in the position
um don't touch the opponent H4 as black
Rook to H1 or queen to H2 is going to
capture one of the pieces on the H file
you're sort of stuck in the position
how do you continue how do you develop
your pieces I'm looking at ideas to go
long Castle right yeah maybe with the
bishop on D7 this is going to be met by
E5 that's problematic as well you cannot
take because I think I have some Knight
to five ideas right that pretty much uh
put a cabbage on the position this is
game over right you cannot take you get
Chuck made it so Bishop to B7 makes the
most sense to me at this point and then
I can just simply take a pawn
play this position a pawn up if you
continue with Castle I go Bishop to G5
the Knight on H5 doesn't really have a
good way to come back into play in the
position I really don't like uh first of
all you don't have any counter play on
The Queen side you would love to do that
you would love to open up the position
with D5 not going to happen whenever you
go D5 I can go E5 first of all you're
losing a piece right now so maybe you
start with take take and now D5 but I
just simply go E5 where's your counter
play right you go E5 yourself well thank
you very much you're giving me a lot of
squares right you don't have a way to
create anything in the position it's one
of those weird Sicilians in which
whenever we say Sicilian we know that
it's going to be a back and forth Affair
there is no back and forth in this one
there's no counter play for black and
right now it's only white playing on one
goal and also being a pawn up after
taking on H6 and group to G1 and at some
point Bishop takes H6 is become so
artworks Zoo definitely in a great
position to potentially get his second
victory in this one you know Kirk
gazerian is not necessarily not in his
best shape but he's not very happy with
his last couple of games he had a
winning position actually he has
yesterday a couple of winning positions
against abimanu and against Justin Wang
I guess Justin Wang it was a one move
tactic against abimanu he should have
stopped and think in that end game
position and executed the best plan
which would have led to his victory he
knows that those last couple of rounds
are definitely weighing him down right
now
before we take a break I just want to
say the most confounding game for me uh
Kate is the game between Carissa and
Alice Lee our Marquee matchup in the
girls Championship a game that will most
likely to decide the girls challenge
because
yeah 34 minutes thank you so Knight
takes gifa all of these moves came like
instantly
then 20 minute think 92 20 minute think
and we don't have a response finally
Queen absolutely okay uh and that was
not the queen H4 move that Christian was
prescribing saying that that was the
move for Advantage and maybe this was a
mistake I'm ready can we capture the
Knight big mistake yeah yeah F6 was a
big mistake Bishop captures on G4 then
well she's done yes she has taken the
night yeah yeah
twice
I told you guys I mean that 92 despite
the fact that objectively was a bad move
a practical perspective really good good
move good decision and Alice uh has just
played Bishop takes G4 so this is a
peace sacrifice but I don't know we are
very happy to exchange Queens right and
either Force the knights to go
away or then we can
we can okay
we have to defend that night okay but
you're still in a kind of a pin right
because if your knight moves I've got to
check so right I'm I'm ready
I've got two pawns Bishop G3
[Music]
oh Knight H5
uh I'm just no I'm playing a rook down
this can't be good right like this is
ridiculous
I mean it it that's not gonna work yeah
of course it's ridiculous it's kind of a
funny position right because White's
pieces are a little bit everything's in
a pin but no Knight E4 now be careful
about background Checkmate exactly but
everything is in a a crazy pin one of
the thing is I can
Play Bishop G2 give you an exchange back
ah to take yeah that's gonna be a piece
for two pawns wow that favors why but
okay the current position
Carissa Carissa is looking good looking
no I think what
the assessment well the big question is
what's the assessment of the following
sequence you take on F6 you take Rook D2
and now 94 right
and now 94 right just go for uh go for
the rook and now Knight G3 Rook Knight
takes D2 and how is this position is the
question
two pieces two pieces for rook and a
couple of Pawns it's still very
complicated the engines are really
liking white but I'm not convinced is as
clear
gotcha all right we're gonna take our
first break of the day and as we do that
as tradition dictates we go and check in
at our friends at Q Boutique now for
those of you who've been following our
broadcast I have been highlighting the
seniors
the girls and the junior polos yes but
now we're taking a giant leap forward
they're doing it all at once
your shirts are the ones every one of
these shirts are available they are in a
limited edition they are perfect for any
chess enthusiasm uh the tournament logo
on the breast in the St Louis chess club
logo on the right shoulder show your
pride for the game and style and comfort
and all of these are available at cubic
St louis.com for all your chess needs
thank you and we're going to see you on
the other side of our break yep see you
soon
[Music]
thank you
I'd say don't give up keep playing and
also just play for fun not exactly to
win or anything just enjoy the
experience of playing every game and
hopefully winning
um I would advise that they enjoy the
game because I think that if you enjoy
the game then you will like genuinely be
able to improve naturally and uh your
hard work you will put in the hard work
um and just like to appreciate like
chess it's a really amazing game there's
so many possibilities like each game is
different basically and
um yeah so just like enjoy the game and
your improvement should become should
come naturally from there I think to get
better you just need to love the love
chess as a whole I feel like it's really
difficult
um to like get better if you have a lot
of trouble like trying to be
self-motivated or work by yourself so
I'd say don't give up and keep calm
probably just learn to develop your
pieces and Castle I still have trouble
with that sometimes so like just stick
to the basic principles honestly it's
just like enjoy this game like two and
to like not to like worry about like
what what others like you know like just
like play play your best definitely
tactics some even like above like
reading chess books or studying openings
and all that just mostly tactics
recognizing positions and then just like
playing in tournaments um playing
wherever you can that's really what I
did honestly I would say try to like
play chess on your own terms
um I know I struggled a lot with that
um just like don't
um focus on just trying to like impress
everyone else play it because you love
the game and actually enjoy it I'll do
plenty of tactics oh and the main thing
is that you have to play a lot try to
play in as many tournaments as possible
and also play online games which should
I would say you know if it's like their
first time playing Juniors I know it's
like a really almost like a stressful
experience to have your games be on like
um almost National stage
um and I remember the first time I
played here in St Louis and junior girls
I did not do so hot I actually did
really badly
um so I just say like kind of take it
easy enjoy the time you have here
um
yeah I enjoy the games that you play you
don't really know if you're gonna if you
like something until you try it so you
know chess really started to like become
really big during covid and you know if
you start playing an in-person
tournament that's when you start to
really figure out if you really like
playing chess so my advice is go plan
some in-person tournaments especially
since we're in St Louis this is the
perfect opportunity to come and play
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in-store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
tokorchonova I will be doing social
media for the U.S Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2 000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonova I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind the scenes content
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 thousand
Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
View chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of our national
championships here are the standings
with the girls Kate after round six we
have a soul leader honestly fantastic
performance so far Five Points Zoe tank
right behind her four and a half points
also a great tournament for her and then
a two-way tie for the third place
Karissa yep and ruyengian with three and
a half points each and Carissa and Alice
are in deep battle and the junior in the
generous we have a three-way tie for the
first place yes
and Arthur grow all have four points and
we have one of two of the leaders facing
each other today Andrew Hong and Arthur
glov and your pick Brandon Jacobson only
half a point behind and the uh seniors
seniors that's all about Malik said five
and half points out of six absolutely
mind-blowing performance so far and then
a four-way tie for the second place
Vladimir copy and Gregory maxing loogie
and Alex chabalov wow great stuff let's
just jump right into the battles as
we're going to pick up with the girls uh
with Carissa and Alice Lee when we left
it uh we didn't like the move that Alice
had just said she played the move Queen
F6 and we had been looking at the
engines top move Queen H4 for the
longest while and very difficult move to
find to understand Knight is threatening
F4 the queen is very active on H4
vacating d8 Square for the crazy crazy
lines Queen F6 was her choice it's a
peace sacrifice and the idea of Alice's
peace sacrifice was that this pin is so
uncomfortable that it ended up she ends
up winning an exchange and they've got
this material imbalance of two minor
pieces in this case two Bishops for rook
and two ponds now normally speaking we
like the two Bishops right but in this
particular case it's not like uh White
species are there right and so that has
some kind of Developmental Advantage
right right I can bring the Rook to d8
and then start pushing pawns maybe on
the king's side and the white still has
to figure out how to develop her pieces
optimal uh squares for the pieces yeah
well I can see that this bishop really
does want to go here the Knight does
want to go here The Rook does want to go
to G1 uh but uh I I like the minor
pieces because they are the two Bishops
but uh to my mind it's still a three
result game I won't say that you know
white is overwhelming or anything of
that nature also I wanted to jump
quickly to the game of Zoe because that
was actually a very intriguing position
remember we were debating it ourselves
uh I didn't anticipate the move Bishop
A4 I was looking at 9 bd2 G5 right right
you know the idea the conventional stuff
rookie won you know you get you're not
you want to put pressure on the E5 Pawn
ASAP Kelsey do that immediately Bishop
A4 attacking the Knight on C6 and
putting pressure on Pawn on E5 and
quickly they got to a very uh unbalanced
position as well mate takes Knight takes
two Bishops against bishop and Knight
but these double pawns very
ugly and she's played the move F5 and
white wants to maintain her attack on
the sponge she wants to play Knight B3
but maybe she was a little bit afraid
that her Bishop might end up being
pushed passively back so she did play
the move F2 F3 and were caught up with
the players kind of feel it's a little
easier to play White in this position
what's your take I mean no I'm wondering
if you know if I play Rook he8 like yes
you have to be a little careful about
your pieces the kind of Bishop almost
being attacked at night I can attack in
the future and whenever my group gets to
the second rank that can be very
dangerous exactly if I play you know a
lackadaisical move rookie one I'm
certainly crying because uh an F4 is a
threat yeah whoops I it could easily go
wrong so Rook on H I like this follow-up
so those are the two uh games that are
but a third game I wanted to say that
really blew up was this game between
Rochelle and uh Rose uh when we left it
I already felt that something had kind
of gone wrong for white after the move
F5 it felt like black had the initiative
and uh Rook G1 takes takes we talked
about this move Knight C4 Bishop takes
it here it comes Bishop takes uh I'm
guessing Rook takes G4 Knight takes G4
and Rochelle just didn't see what she
was doing uh H2 is hanging C4 is hanging
she decided to sacrifice upon and
pretend like you know this was all a
part of the master plan that was Pawn
sacrifice number two and now comes to uh
C5
um D5 and she's looking to play Queen D4
castles improve her compensation but boy
talk about a position that just got away
uh from us so the girls sections blow it
up what's happening in the junior
section Christian a lot of things are
happening in the junior section let's
take a look because I don't think we uh
gave a lot of attention to this critical
matchup between arturgo and Andrew Hong
this is the Battle of the co-leaders
going into the seventh round so big big
big matchup and we discussed at the
beginning this idea of early E5 and how
it was a very good opening surprise
because it's not easy to deal with it
over the chessboard nightwage five
taking the pawn after Queen to H5 and
allowing Bishop Queen to H4 Bishop to G5
A4 ideas not seeing immediately how
you're going to finish your development
can be quite difficult uh to do over the
chessboard so he took on E5
Knight takes C5 Queen to C7 he's trying
to find
a very quick development black that is
Andrew Hong that is which makes a lot of
sense from a practical perspective
the engine hates it the engine really
doesn't like what Andrew is doing right
now Rook to E8 A4 allowing me to stop
your counter attack on the queen side
and expansion with the move B5 perhaps
not the right solution this Rook to E8 a
bit too slow in my estimation A4 B6
Queen to F4 I like this move by white by
uh Arthur guo Bishop to B7 this is what
we currently have on the board
but how easy is this end game for black
I understand you have a tremendous
Bishop on G7 but it doesn't have a lot
of targets what what targets I do have
as white is your pawns on the queen side
especially that pawn on B6 so what if I
just simply drop back with the bishop
Bishop to E3 put a lot of pressure on
your opponent is that what he did no we
don't have a move yet no we don't have a
move yet but this feels very natural
right that is 1 F4 no longer has a task
in the position I don't want to get hit
by E5 so I might as well drop back right
Bishop to E3 how do you defend that
Bishop B6
and perhaps you guys can't help me
inside to go through the variations
together because I understand the
engines find some ways of potentially
prolonging uh this game but after Bishop
to E3 at least to my eyes is very very
difficult and I think Andrew is going to
start panicking once he sees that he
doesn't have a clear way of Defending
that pawn uh absolutely and so what do
you do after yeah Bishop E3 I was
looking at the prophylactic move Rook ba
correct yeah this is what I think is is
at least visually the most appealing and
then then I will take let's say I don't
know if it's appealing I think it's good
for white what else can you do right
right it's kind of a forced situation
it's just a bad end game so Bishop to E3
Rook to B8 right maybe we can put that
on your board
Knight takes P6 let's say
and now aha yes okay Bishop to C7
Bishop takes A6 our King takes G2 yeah
basically I'm a pawn up yeah and look at
those parts
look at those spawns look at that a pawn
coming down the board well I did you
look you don't have to I I pawn power
it's what it's all about right
I'm scared already this is really bad
Bishop B5 Bishop B5 I yeah Knight D5 I
mean this is okay but hold on yeah I'll
give some now I'm kind of feeling like
you're getting something no I don't know
I don't think no I'm getting no I I
think white is still for choice but uh
so maybe I should not give you any hopes
I will go rookie three something like
that yeah something of that nature
defend that night on C3 right exactly
and yeah I'm not I'm not uh I'm not
ready to defend against three connected
passports this is not fun this is really
not fun right but for Andrew this is
really a setback I mean he's coming into
this competition with you know really
high hopes uh tight for first three
rounds to go uh
he didn't expect this kind of a
challenge in the seventh round oh no our
Arthur is definitely feeling it right
now and I think you were mentioning uh
kashka yesterday that his uh Grand
Master elect absolutely in fact he's
been having a great teller Year yes he's
been doing really well in open
tournaments and right now he's showing
his stuff in this one I have to say
pristine opening preparation really good
really good stuff from Arthur go and the
middle game end game positions he's
doing really well in this event and he
has a clear chance that maybe
winning the tournament she knows that he
feels that through his play so he's
going to take full advantage of it okay
uh just going to the game of Mishra for
a moment because after the move C4 there
was this amazing move C5 which I thought
was really a kind of a fun move
so this was a fun moment and Justin
played a theoretically prescribed move
Queen A5 maybe C5 was more engine
approved but okay C5 for white and he
said take upon I took upon do your worst
so Mishra has a command of the open file
but the business squares e-cigs E7 E8
are all covered by the bishop and after
Bishop f8
Bishop F4 Queen A5 Justin's just clipped
the pawn and said again you know like go
ahead and kill me if you uh if you can't
don't go for Rook H3 uh I'm just uh
teasing you with that uh move Rook uh
The Rook on E1 will be hanging and it's
a challenge yeah I feel like I would
like to push G4 but black has just G6
and still very solid right well but
that's the kind of thing you need right
you need him to you need black to make
some kind of weaknesses in his position
so that you know you can go bang bang
bang and you are
disaffected I'm worried about the bishop
on the foreign
I'm actually kind of curious to see if
at any point the attack could succeed
the queen B8 or you want to capture I
just take uh Queen d8 is a a fine uh
move too we saw a move we saw is it G4
I'm not sure no just let me just refresh
the board for uh oops sorry that's not
the board I want to refresh he played
Bishop F4 to E5 okay kind of a safe
solid move
at some point you do want to release
this Rook right so whether you play C3
or move the Rook or King F1 can I do
that King F1 just to defend the Rook
you want to do something now from
Black's perspective he doesn't want to I
mean you give white enough time you know
why whether you play H3 and G4 you know
you're you're gonna blast open so you've
got to do something and maybe something
like B7 B6 to try to
well use your extra Pawn this is a game
that we're going to keep an eye on I
wanted to turn our attention also to the
seniors because of the huge game that's
going on between Gregory and malikset
again if Gregory doesn't win today with
the white pieces I mean it's it's
a home run right
to victory for Malik said can we come
back a little bit yeah what happened
because we thought there could be some
crazy things happening so in this
position we were kind of I was much more
attracted to locking things down with E5
C5 Rook A4 trading my H4 Pawn for the
pawn on B4 but Gregory had a completely
different idea he doesn't like close
positions much like shibalov he enjoys
open attacking positions he played
Bishop F4 98 Queen D2 King G7 what did
he do he opened up the position for his
two Bishops Rook G1
yeah sneaky little uh threat and you'd
mentioned in the previous uh iteration
of this game that the king might just
hang out on H7 but right now Knight
takes H5
and if you capture game over Bishop D3
oops
so there is an issue here Knight F5 as
well as Knight H5 how
how
um problematic
is Knight F5 you really want to grab
every single one you see well if if I'm
gonna suffer I might as well suffer with
something in my pocket right so if we
take I do appreciate that I've also
handled this guy
but is there a follow-up a moment ago
you were just killing me with the bishop
coming to D3
uh hopefully that's not the case
here
I can still go Bishop D3 right sure
but in this case
okay I'll I'll hang uh this is a crucial
game but I think you're almost forced to
take on H4 right
ah you see it's not just that I am a
pond Grabber something to do with the
Knights is that I don't have well 95 is
a big threat yeah so how do you defend
against it well it's it's a check right
it's it's not visually is a big threat
well it looks like it looks like it
kills you well it's a check it's a
bishop
okay so I go night
um df6 Knight d f I know I'm gonna
struggle uh
Bishop E5
Knight F5 I
sorry let me excuse me let me just kind
of make an executive decision here you
have even if you move back leave maybe
bishop C7 here
oh no yeah
okay let's have a look let's have a look
now these are the type of things that
Malik set is going to start being afraid
of that's absolutely whether it's a
ghost or not you start yeah you're
seeing them yeah you're right black is
surviving here I can't do that but it's
but okay uh let's just say that I take
command of the dark squares and I start
looking at f45
okay it's not fun no this this is not
looking good it it really is not fun
also
again Rook A4 how scared am I Rook G8
I'm not scared yet be scared be afraid
okay nice D7 right like be afraid be
very afraid
thump
now the answer is going to take the
pawns if you give it
it's not a shame
if you can't be Shameless
he's like
but let's take a look at their line
score as uh once again he's he's done
the trifecta what's four in a row
we got the hat trick the trifecta
I think well he's castled
but a fantastic five and a half yeah
it's absolutely unexpected performance
for Malik and for all of us so this is
one game in the in the seniors we want
to keep an eye on crucial crocheting
this for me is classic called chess I
just love this I mean I love the
maneuvering game that we're witnessing
between shabalov and Joe Benjamin and uh
when I was a kid I kind of soared to uh
the world champions Michael badvinic and
tigran Petrosian I love the way they
played they it just their logic was so
um
profound but
logical I mean they they play Beautiful
chess Knight to E3 okay I'm meeting you
you've got these two big pieces on the
on the queen side attacking my Pawn on
C4 so white meets uh that threat also
a a key kind of a counter blow for for
black in these positions is the move F7
yeah I think a really important job on
E3 absolutely Rook to E8 check this move
out Bishop E2 91 King F2 so the problem
is we've already played the pawn to H5
so if we Castle we're inviting Queen H4
and that tickle over there and we always
talk about King's safety right but King
safety doesn't always mean Castle it
means keeping the king safe and the King
on F2 is guarded by the pawns the Knight
is there and The Rook is doing an
amazing job on H1 so we want to keep it
there exactly and then uh one of the one
of the great ideas of Michael uh Bob
vinic that I just saw to is you know you
you're supposed to bring your Rooks into
the center right but many times this
bishop on C1 doesn't have a square so
how do you get the Rook involved
broke up on over Rook A2 and it's like
this combination of all of these ideas
for white uh shabalov has done them and
then
for Joe he kind of ran out of
improvements he's done everything he can
he's he's maximized his pieces like
where else can they they go if you go
Knight F4 well I'll drop back with the
bishop and I'll kick you back right so
F7 F6 and we've caught up to the players
and again I love these maneuvering games
how about you Kate honestly I'm going to
be super honest with you guys so this is
not my cupboard
but the game I really like is let's go
to take a look at parag wolves against
uh Dmitry girl jump because look what
happened just if we move one move back
we have a exchange sacrifice in
Switzerland and that is kind of the
classical chess I studied when I was
younger and I really enjoy exactly Rook
takes C3 really it's the exchange
sacrifice but it's almost like the
Sicilian uh sacrifice and I remember
a very important game from a U.S
Championship played here the St Louis
chess club and it was between Ray Robson
and Hikaru Nakamura and it was just an
exchange sacrifice just like that but
the bishop was on G7 and black went on
to win
um black is now trading Queens because
there's quinte's G5 wait
what 25 Queen C7 oh this year oh sorry
it's a tactic it's not positional
sacrifice I'm sorry I I just assumed
that we were we were trading Queens for
a second I thought you lost it through
nature yeah there's a bishop hanging on
G5 and you're just like overlooking it
okay I thought the whole idea was uh was
to go for this ending but okay what if I
do he takes G4 what
take on e4 with something maybe with I
was thinking with the Knight
takes E4 right specifically because of
what you showed uh if you take with the
bishop Queen takes E7 I didn't like okay
so Knight takes so just now we are
defending the bishop on E7 we are
threatening Knight F2 fork okay give me
the bishop and I will now write F2
uh I can't disturb you you can go H4 but
I have Queen F6 and I thought that
should be enough right
I'll take one of the Rooks let's say the
one on H one well you can
you can yeah uh oh yeah yes if you like
it wasn't going away yeah Queen D4 Queen
ah before you take my Bishop not yet let
me show Christianity
it's not easy to spot but when your eye
uh something to think about but he did
he go for it yes he did he did go Queen
takes G5 Queen C7 yes that's the what
did you think about this Ending by the
way had he gone Queen takes Queen takes
Pawn takes Rook over just a clean
exchange sacrifice yeah I kind of wanted
to keep the night on the board to you
know jump to D7 E5 which I'm worried
it's not gonna happen now because you
can always take yeah what can you take
now when you want are you by King D2
yeah you know it's not enough competency
no you have some conversation but I
don't think it's enough for equality and
I don't think it's the type of position
you want to play when you sacrifice in
exchange clear all right but we do have
this queen takes G5 Queen C7 on the
board and the players are in your your
chats actually I kind of prefer if like
the b-file is also open or slightly but
like I'm happy for that you know
exchange sacrifice or now it's not an
exchange takes E4 that's awesome we were
expecting
but it is an exchange sacrifice if I if
I take it it can also take only four and
take only yeah but if you take only four
Bishops
okay let's go Z5 or something D5 let's
go
it's a weird position isn't it
well I take on G2 I've got a runner no
with queen with Queen
Queen takes G2 yeah yes
wow I know
no no no no no I don't want to see Rook
C8 so no fancy uh no fancy uh attacks
coming on C2 I was thinking about Queen
C7 so what's the material balance well
imbalance I've got four pawns and
you have five so it's a exchanging Pawn
for a very good Bishop
a very good Bishop yeah and the question
is how fast is that a pawn right right
yeah the A1 can be running pretty fast
you do have to worry about a C file so I
think Queen C7 looks like a nice move to
start with well the problem I'm having
Kate is Bishop to d8 and just uh I can't
play the desired Queen G3 because that
does uh give back the exchange which I'm
kind of trying to keep in my pocket uh
difficult uh imbalance is going on but
there's so many games uh Christian uh
you've got the game of Igor speaking of
difficult imbalances and positions that
nobody has any idea how to assess right
this is one of them I mean look at this
one Castle was played by the way
probably the best move wow uh F takes E5
F takes E5
and right now what kobion is thinking
and really has a difficult Choice ahead
of himself because it's very easy to get
tempted by this Pawn on A6 right it also
comes
uh would probably spend 30 seconds and
capture immediately but it's not that
clear I go King to B8 and this queen on
A6 is a bit out of play now you allow me
to go ideas of E4 at the right moment
sure Maybe not immediately because you
have to worry about Bishop G3 the pawn
on D4 as well
but how do you play this position after
this queen to D3 come back say that you
got the root and now you're returning
home probably not I take I take and now
Knight C3 I have my own counter play
Brewing on the queen side as well the
king is not entirely safe I have to say
on C1 so and by the way this is on the
board Queen takes A6 was played King to
B8 Queen to B5 seems to be the best move
in the position in fact the only move in
the position to maintain an edge for
white but it's not easy to understand
why I'm seeing this move I see Rook f8
potentially maybe even Bishop E7 barucho
f8 ask some questions in the position
there's no more F6 right now coming uh
into play Maybe Rook to G1 take take and
King to business wild position I'm still
trying to understand who has the edge in
the position I see a pawn up white
probably should have the edge but it's
not clear right it's like one of those
Jackson Pollock paintings yeah Splash
here Splash here nobody understands
exactly what's happening so but it looks
beautiful it's beautiful absolutely it's
not necessarily my brand of Chess I I
think it's more of a kachka's brand of
Chess she enjoys this type of positions
this type of wild Sicilians but I have
to say very very intriguing game and uh
both of these players need a victory
right that's why they're taking so many
chances if they want to play for that
cavity title both of them need a victory
maybe navikov is a bit too far away from
that but
um a Cobian definitely wants a win in
this one all right and maybe this is
your type of position the game of
Douglas root and Maxim the loogie when
we left it I really like this decision
by Doug to go F4 and let's go I'm trying
to trap the queen exactly black is not
careful and captures the pawn on B2 by
the way that that is just one of the
those
moves that really should be hardwired
that your queen is suddenly like yeah
it's usually the poison one the
poisoning capturing it right but Rook d
a queen C1 okay he's basically saying
you know I'm ready to go with that 405
but I want to make sure that you've got
no sources of counter play Queen A5 let
me stop you
says the loogie let me stop you from
playing F5 no you don't and uh you're
right there's a problem if he takes
there's a traffic there's a traffic
problems is it 94 94 or 93 I wasn't sure
either but uh just that oops uh I'm very
happy you get that extra Pawn but I get
the file exactly probably your horsey as
well a horsey as well uh Bishop C8 and
uh we're we're up to speed and okay
people like this position for Douglas
right I did uh I'm just I I wanted to
see can I force for forcibly win it if
you may win a pawn no I was trying to
Checkmate actually Bishop takes with
Rook F3 with F6 and Rook F3 right
but I don't think you should take on C3
I I don't think you should I think that
this is like just two
um
actually right but I'm thinking you're
gonna go Bishop G7 back
seven back
I didn't even not even sure I saw that
but okay but then I went upon I don't
know your your king is really
if I your your King's really
but I thought if you move back maybe I
can capture no like take Stakes Bishop
G7 yeah oh sorry Bishop g72
and maybe I can now take the phone
Bishop takes F5 ah thank you
thank you okay good okay so I'll go
Queen in this case I have to defend the
pawn that makes sense
makes sense F6 is a move I can't oh but
I don't have to worry about F6 right now
because actually the queen is pinned
correct Pawn is pinned there correct
correct
but it is a pawn and that is a naked
King
um
you've got to prove
some compensation here it's not going to
be so easy
yeah that looks very dangerous for black
again for Max you know he's taking some
risk in this game but he's taking a risk
against the tail Ender but Douglas rude
you know he can he's a very strong
player yeah yes he runs to go you know
he can still have a lot of points so
it's gonna be his break well uh so far
it's an intriguing moment for sure and
will he grab the pawn or not
um I want to go back to Alice Lee and
pardon me Carissa Yip and Alice Lee
because
okay after takes I like this move that
Alice played because for for for me as
white I've got a crystal clear idea that
I want to go Bishop do three night right
bring my pieces out and I like this move
Knight E4 because it basically
interferes with my desired Knight C3
Rook G1 G6 Knight E3 F6 and I believe
we're caught up with the players so are
you like me one of those players that
just loves the give a check no it's not
not to give a check but developing with
Tempo I like to give a check you like to
give a check
with a temple and giving a check that's
it both of us are very very happy and
we're forcing King h8 right because you
don't really want to allow our Knight to
F uh five after King h8 give us your
take how do you assess these positions
it's two pawns and a rook for two minor
pieces it's really difficult to assess
um
well this is the current position yes
yeah on one hand I just like pieces I
feel the pair of Bishops we have to
trust them that they're going to do the
job that they are very strong but I also
see the pawns you know G5 H5 I know it
can be really scary to be playing
against these pawns yeah maybe I should
actually just start with the move h2h4
that kind of takes away the potency or
the potential of these pawns you're not
going to be rushing not not that I
really want to play the move H5 myself
either I just kind of wanted to take
away the impact yeah I really like this
H4 move
um likely the engine is going to save
White's a smidge better but I really
want to ask Christian uh what is going
on in the Carissa yeah versus Alice Lee
game in terms of the engine eval
practically can we say that this is like
still three-way yeah you guys were right
on on point uh H4 does give white a
slight Edge Just A Smith Edge though
nothing major fairly significant it's a
one point Advantage yes wow okay it's
already a one point Advantage after the
move H4 uh and I would assume it's not
necessarily because of the material
imbalance but rather because black
doesn't really have a good way to
continue
this position right and I have a much
easier plan I can first of all look to
play H5 at the right moment I have
Knight F5 idea due to the pressure on
the G file I have worked to place my
pieces I feel like whenever you go B5
and I saw that you point it towards that
move I feel like you're also weakening
your position a little bit right yes B5
can be met with Knight to F5 followed by
Knight to D4 at the right moment you're
creating some weaknesses right this is
what I'm worried about uh for Alice Lee
and I have to say this whenever you see
this type of imbalances an open position
I feel like these are the type of
positions Carissa really enjoys
especially after the last few rounds she
was really struggling with her pieces
right right remember the bishopone A7 oh
that was terrible remember that uh
exchange up uh game against rayamangai
mangalan I believe it was that game
where she was really really Under
Pressure managed to repeat the position
at the right moment and make a draw but
she's not been showing her best chess
that's because she didn't have the best
positions out of the opening right now
somehow she managed to counteract this
night brilliant Knight takes G4 with
night tweet why I like that from a
practical point of view she got a better
position and I think she's going to do
her best to take advantage of that so
let's say Carissa plays H4 that's a
great move stop in G5 and Alice just
makes a very normal move Rook d8 am I so
terrified of Bishop C7 here do I take
your Pawn I mean the Knight only three
can be hanging in the future I don't
know if I want to take your Pawn or not
right so if I go Rook D7 here and say go
take it and I want to have a night jump
somewhere where does when I jump
that's a very good question well it's
it's not intuitively obvious that it has
a good Square for example I mean I'm
just just to put it out there your night
goes away you might want to think that
geez my knight should actually not have
left uh and given up and that's why I
say she doesn't have that many square
for her by the way just for her pieces
the disruptive rookie won by just yeah
the bishop yeah just by accidental uh
chance that just happens that I cover
that so that means I have to play like a
four right right just move that pawn
away from a dark square and even though
I agree I'm going to create a weakness I
can go A5 B5 Rook C Rook theater it's
like and you know ask why you know where
is this bishop going to be effective so
I was thinking that if my Pawn was here
I'm kind of reducing
the jumps of the night a little bit and
also kind of you know keeping the bishop
uh under under
control I like that and again it it all
comes down to what's your best piece as
black and how can I get rid of it or at
least put some tension on it that is the
Knight on e4 of course yeah so I will go
Bishop G2 Bishop to G2 okay so uh one of
the things we're told whenever we have
Rooks against minor pieces nine to five
beautiful you you want to uh double your
Rooks you you know like if I just put
the other Rook on d8 I just don't feel
like
I'm putting my so I really sorry A4
Bishop G2 Rook E7 I really want to
double my Rooks so that you know like
I've got you know some ways of yeah
bouncing in the position but the move
Knight F5 is the disruptor right I mean
it's unpleasant yeah so somehow my king
isn't good on G8 so now that I created
enough tensions
King AJ that's fine and now I go Rook D1
Rook Dave you cannot challenge me on the
D file anymore because the Knight is
hanging right just a second uh this was
this is why we played H4 is kind of to
stop this move G5 let's take that take
take
open up the the long diagonals yeah a
little worried about it that I'm gonna
be on but let's say
Bishop H2 why not Knight here
can I go rookie one
okay but this is a
this is kind of like what I was kind of
hoping for which was somehow doubling my
Rooks right I have Bishop G3 yeah it's
the question is whether the Knight
survives us and now if you go something
like Knight E4 yes if you go Knight E4 I
simply move my knight like Knight yeah
yeah then you turn the tables on my yeah
I was trying to pin you and suddenly
you're fitting me but I do have Rook f8
uh gotcha one
good wow
Rook F1 and if I take you take huh now I
have Bishop D4 coming true is it that
scary though we have King G8 I mean
rookie eight right or ah okay like this
yeah
one of a wide position isn't it yeah one
of the things that I don't know if you
made this independent Discovery or you
just were told it is when we're playing
uh I have two pieces in a rook
and you have two Rooks
I should not trade a pair of Rooks right
like I need you to keep the two Rooks
and I'm the one and when I have the two
Rooks and you have two minor pieces you
have two minor I'm looking to trade so
in that position where we just went King
to G8 I kind of like hopefully achieved
what you wanted why is it uh why don't
we have to move on the board A4 Carissa
did not play H4 to stop the pawns on the
king side but she fixed the pawn on A5
making sure that she can attack it in
the future because it is on the dark
Square uh I think that's a good move too
uh I I like the move H4 maybe better but
I like the move A4 for exactly what you
said fixing the pawn on the dark Square
so you can't play A5 so I have a target
a long-term Target and again I'm seeing
three results in this game I'm glad that
the computer you know
who do you feel is better I like the I
like the minor pieces I like the two
Bishops yes you know uh just but and I
feel like the King on G8 is not entirely
safe right it's a funny thing to say
because it has a nice shield in front of
uh right in front of him but it just
doesn't feel like it's that safe Bishop
C4 if you stay on the G file Knight F5
yeah I don't know I'm just seeing all
this type of uh agree tricks in the
position agreed agreed agreed uh quickly
we're going to go to Kelsey versus uh
Kelsey Lou versus Zoe because Zoe is
doing incredibly well and when we left
it we left it around here and
check this out well check this out Jack
and Rook takes Bishop takes Bishop uh
D5 and you know we always talk about
these positions who's got the initiative
against the king and the Bishops of
opposite color position and it's about
uh Zoe's sacrifice upon to get some
initiative going
I think that was a clever decision but
can we do
yes so we'll take it take and we'll Zip
Zap zip you on and that's going to go
into some like drawy stuff right Bishop
takes on A7 dry stuff is right I don't
think it gets more trash than this so
yeah the the pieces uh get hosed off the
board but it's always probably happy for
this because
earlier
um uh turning uh turning the tide to you
Christian uh what's happening in the
Junior
take a look at this last move we're
discussing this position Bishop E3 go
for the B6 Pawn
the next move is G4 G4 obviously I did
nothing
whatsoever this is a move that shows
that you're confident about your
position you're confident about your
Play Because to my eyes practically
doesn't make a lot of sense you're
weakening up this long diagonal where
are you going with this G Pawn but it
seems like he has something he has a
plan in his mind and that is to weaken
and soften the score D5 for one of the
nice to land there and take a look at
this G5 Bishop to C6 G4 G5 Knight to H5
Bishop to E3 finally finally I'm
starting to attack that pawn on B6 and
we have Knight to E5
tremendous pressure piling up on uh
Andrew Hong right now and it seems that
unfortunately he's feeling it because I
don't see the follow-up after Knight
takes B6
how do you continue Rook to B8
I continue with Knight D5 I'm bringing
all my pieces into play and this one is
turning into a wild situation but how do
you get any sort of counter play the
only thing that makes sense is E6
try to destabilize my position but right
I'm gonna go in I'm going Knight C7
right sure you have a check but that's
about it right there's nothing else
outside of this check on F3 and all my
pieces and all my squares are protected
outside of that so I'm looking at the
position I'm taking the pawn on B6 and
I'm asking you I'm asking Andrew what's
your next move because my other night
that was not doing much in the position
is coming to D5 it's going to get
centralized you don't have any counter
play I'm a pawn up I'm probably going to
be multiple pawns up after I take that
pawn on A6 as well this one is looking
really good by the way guys this is huge
for the standings exactly this is the
Battle of the co-leaders right sure two
of the co-leaders abimanu is uh playing
Justin whack right but if Arthur wins
this one with the white pieces I mean
he's catching some fire
and and definitely I mean he's putting
his stake in the tournament and saying
hey I'm here to win it and the G4 G5 is
working yeah really nicely a move that I
uh he's taking me he's just asking the
question what's next what are you doing
I mean you're giving me this Pawn on B6
allowing my knight to get stable uh on
B6 this this is not looking good and
Arthur go has 48 minutes whereas Andrew
hunk only 24. lots of pressure on Andrew
Hong right now uh you showed us the
tournament standings there with Mishra
also in the mix Titan first let's jump
into his game against Justin Wang
because that was a game that Mishra
sacrificed upon or what looks like a big
build up on these guys yeah did he just
play Bishop C8 uh we just got it on the
board let me catch up C8 let me just
catch up with you Christian we we left
it with Bishop E5
and uh G6 by Justin Wang
and Mishra played the move Queen G5
looks right uh I'm ready to I'm ready to
play I was ready to play Rook G3 by the
way so I'm just checking it out Vision C
isn't this over after Bishop C7 yeah we
have some
things here oh
hold on Bishop Bishop C7 Queen D2
[Music]
hey you know I mean maybe old but you
know I got some ideas Bishop A5
Bishop A5 wow
following you look at that is the key
movie you have to see oh wow so easy to
miss that is so easy to miss
let's go back Bishop C7 Rook Queen A2
right Queen A2 I like that how is that
well if we
take on d8 take on B1 Bishop F1 Bishop
F1 there's gonna be a lot of pressure on
f8 I hate these Eternal pins oh I feel
so physically helpless when I now Rook d
a bishop D6 is coming
eight six oh and if you take on C7 take
a look at that if you take on C7 after
Bishop F1
oh sorry uh then I take on f8 and all
your pieces are actually going to get
lost it's almost like a dominoes right
28.8 all of your pieces that's just like
a puzzle Rush tactic our pieces are just
set up for this uh nice combination guys
we're having a big moment right now
right
both in this one but also in the guo
versus Hong game I mean you has a lot of
time he has 41 minutes
and by the way we do have a result we
were we were thinking that the game was
kind of finely balanced between malikset
and Gregory and it was drawn
and by the way
for Malik said this is fantastic I know
it's amazing incredible I mean but
drawing with black against one of his
closest uh pursuers
he may just have uh clinched at least a
tie right and he also like this position
I mean Gregory skydanov right so you
were worried about Malik maybe his King
being under attack exactly well he did
uh get his Knight to G7 oh this is
pretty that is a strange finish what a
time to make a repetition very strange
yeah I mean good times Malik said right
you are still enjoying your your lead
okay very good sorry you were telling us
about the Juniors though because also in
Arthur uh goes and Andrew well they're
following that line that we looked at
right but right Knight cd5 just Knight
C3 to D5 really looking good for a white
I mean all of my pieces are playing an
active role well the other nice thing
about Knight D5 is you are stopping
Knight F3 for them exactly
and by the way A5 F4 Bishop takes A6 I
see a lot of good knight C7 Knight takes
A6 I mean I see everything is a lot of
good moves forward white where is your
counter play
well it's all based upon some uh King
side stuff but it's only five is out of
play for the moment right yeah I think
if we move back maybe a little bit and
I think it's B6 one way for white to go
wrong after Knight E5
is to Simply capture tonight right nice
takes E5 Bishop takes E5 and now
actually you know if you capture even
Bishop takes B6 I have Knight F4 Knight
F4 and black maybe actually having some
dangerous stuff happening the bishop is
fantastic exactly
and yeah it's easy to go wrong yeah it's
easy to go wrong but if you do what uh
Arthur did just Knight takes B6 that is
a very nice move and
tonight as he followed up with Knight
c3d5 no he's still because that's a key
move I mean
A5 is also good but you know Knight F3
check there might be some counter play
but Knight c3d5 really stopping the
pieces yeah it puts a kibosh on this and
you know hey A4 A5 Bishop takes A6 maybe
even on a really good day they play F4
and I totally take over the entirety of
the position uh this way as well so uh
very very good and again did Mishra this
is this is the money shot right this is
the money shot this is the big one
Bishop C7 he finds Bishop C7 it's game
over and by the way I mean yeah I it's
sort of like you intuitively you don't
see this move because you're kind of you
blocked your vision the C7 square is
protected it's covered yeah you have to
see that the Rook is uh first of all uh
it's a good
um Discovery because once you discovered
that try is feeling it look at him yeah
he's ready
he's ready to go no he's reaching for
his age
he's done it he missed it he missed it
what a mess well but hold on a second
it's not really good I mean I look isn't
that a part of White's tragedy though
the great attacking chances still in
play yes yes I mean okay you see the
move Bishop CC but you're also thinking
yeah but can I wait only move I Love It
I Love Queen
I mean I just want to trade that Queen
to make sure my king is safe right and
it's something I I talk about all the
time uh whenever you trade think of it
as your marketplace where we're going to
make these trades together you know I'm
going to trade you a loaf of bread for a
pound of sugar and so forth and so on
we're trading queens and you always ask
yourself who benefits and the answer is
whose King is more vulnerable who's on
the attack in this case White's on the
attack so white would Robin not be
trading Queens because it reduces the
attacking potential so anything like
Queen takes d8 Rook takes d8 forgetting
the fact that black is a pawn up you
don't never forget that
but it's a it would be a great deal uh
for uh Justin to trade Queens but
Christian we have a guest in studio
Gregory first of all I have to ask you
did everybody that was on three and a
half take you out for dinner last night
get you ready give you a nice massage
for today's game and is absolutely
everything during the night what was uh
what was the feeling
um you know it was just a normal game
for me I mean I
prepare you know like it is a normal
game
um first of all I'm not very good
playing Under Pressure plus there
shouldn't be any pressure because medic
is so much ahead that you know even if I
win this game
yeah yeah yeah yeah very very slim
um however you know I prepared a lot and
my preparation was successful I got very
good Advantage after the opening and you
were blitzing up to this move and I
tweet too yeah right here right here uh
I knew that the move is Bishop G2
but during the game
um I thought that maybe Knight G3 is
even better so try to go for E4 yeah
that was any four so so Knight G3 is
basically over the board inspiration by
the way it has been played by some very
strong players oh okay okay I didn't
know yeah yeah it's definitely a good
move okay H4 E6 and now E4
and A5
okay G6
I think it was
how did you assess because we are trying
to assess this position as well we
aren't really sure I was optimistic but
uh cautiously optimistic so so because
obviously there are problems with my
Pawn structure right so I he also has
problems with the pawn structure he has
two weak points before A6 right D5 as
well
and um
uh so it's double edged basically but uh
I should be better with with the bishop
pair with his king is not very
comfortable yeah uh but I knew I need to
be precise and I spent quite a bit of
time here but I just didn't find the way
to go originally let's go back
originally my plan was just one move
back wait right Knight G7 you know 95 97
originally my plan was to play Knight H6
uh but then Rook H6 Bishop H6 Knight F5
and I didn't like my position I thought
black has very good compensation for the
exchange no more attack yeah right right
right so uh 93 also looked at uh but
there was something about 93
uh I think he's gonna play Knight of
fate and again I thought his position is
like super solid those nights protect
the king so well and uh yeah and so I
not easy to create anything against his
weaknesses right right right I I didn't
really want to make a draw I I wanted to
play for a win but I just didn't see uh
any way to make life difficult for him I
I feel like if I
would continue playing I can lose but I
I don't see how I can win this uh
strategically easy to go wrong right
right you need bhp5 F4 F5 somehow but it
just is not happening right right you'd
ask a Witnesses on before and A6 and
theoretically in abstract way if I trade
queens and go into some kind of end game
those weaknesses could tell but
uh just couldn't figure out how to do it
so
uh Gregory I need to ask you about this
position because we're looking at it
right now it seems to have simplified a
little bit simplified a little bit but
it was so crazy
out of the opening this was the position
I mean we didn't understand anything
have you seen this in your preparation
what is the opening
it's some sort of uh they they played in
a different room so
yeah so I didn't even see it it's a
sicilian right some crazy
variation of course you know they're
both experts in this line
eager plays this line his whole life as
black they played it last year as well
oh okay so it's some sort of a battle
going on here
right right I think in this position
after which page three he played 95 last
year now he decided to go for Knight P6
and uh this is what we have right now
what are you looking at their game at
all were you worried about no they're
playing different rooms you didn't go
there yeah yeah I didn't see I was much
more concentrated on the game because
Karissa and Alice okay yes because
it was very interesting because after uh
I was quickly played nightshades G4
um Carissa went into thinking and so it
was it was some crazy preparation from
Alice and a good response by Carissa by
the way so great game that one as well
Gregory thank you very much for joining
us and still a couple of rounds to go
still plenty to fight for yeah we'll try
to let you go get some rest thank you
very much a quick question for you
Gregory uh you played in the game the
two Bishops uh you you you opened the
position Bishop E2 and Bishop F4 and you
you played to open the position trading
on D5 subsequently but you had an
interesting option of shutting the game
down E5 I'm assuming Knight G8 C5 I'm
assuming Bishop takes H4 and Rook B4 so
in one hand you trade off the H4 Pawn
for the B4 Pawn was this a consideration
did you pay attention to this during the
game I I was optimistic that you were
going to play like this and I thought
this was going to be creating a very
intriguing imbalance
uh to be honest I I didn't look at this
I I didn't I didn't want to force
anything
uh and uh I felt like uh I don't want to
close the position if if I would want to
close the position
then I probably wouldn't play Knight G3
then even earlier yeah I I would play
just you know E5 earlier but uh yeah I
was looking for a completely different
type of the game so exactly that's why
it didn't enter my mind all right well
Gregory good luck in the remaining games
uh very very nice as uh for Malik said
what a wonderful result uh drawing with
the black pieces and let's take a look
at the results
result
of Kylie in this tournament after round
seven absolutely uh plus two lead uh
just quickly checking in on the game of
Douglas root and Max delugie I gotta
tell you I I love what Douglas has done
uh he first of all in that position
remember we were looking at this and I
was saying you know you grabbed the pawn
and you know Black's King
you know you're just a pawn down but
Black's King is also under assault that
missing g g Pawn means a rook uh a Rover
is really going to be in White's favor
and we're picking up the position after
this move Rook E8 again I'm I'm thumping
for Rook at four and you know this guy
bringing this guy into the game anything
where you know I get my my pieces over
to the king side I'm all for it it just
it just feels like Max is under
at a terrible person yeah it's very
direct for white but I just do a rook
lift to H3 to G3 one of those or even
yes
um G4 H4 Queen H6 and once your Rook is
on the G file Queen H6 yeah
on the board yeah it looks like to me
White's attack is just playing itself as
uh well it's all going well for white at
the moment and for Max I mean I know he
had the win but sometimes you take too
many risks with the black pieces to get
punished wondering can we do queen the
air just like that when he's doing
nothing there let's bring it to F6 and
try to survive I'm picking up a trend
here you wanted Queen d8 and uh mishra's
game
seizing the defensive
uh yeah no actually seriously it's not a
joke but I do I do understand why you
want to bring your queen over right I
mean I'm trying to play for 94 but uh
yeah I can imagine you know you're
suffering you're upon down but you want
to put up the best uh defense that you
can and I I think we need I don't really
see a way otherwise to be defending the
king side I mean Knight on A6 is never
making that that route it's not the
queen then then who but Douglas is
looking good in this one isn't he yes he
is a great great attacking chances for
Douglas uh picking up the game at
Patrick Wolfe and
uh Dimitri for a moment this was that
crazy game with Rook takes E3 and that
whole business we got to this position
H4 Rook F1 Bishop T8 Queen takes D6
we've caught up with the play uh First
Impressions very favorable for white
here uh again exchange up Bishop takes
E6 on tap Rook on f8 is under uh threat
because Queen H6 yeah okay I can go Rook
takes F7
oh wow uh yep yep yep this is really bad
if you take with the King yeah Rook F1
and the bishop F6 and that's a mate on
the board
true that I really like what why did
they just like these forcing moves if we
go back a little bit here we saw first
H4 forcing the queen to F6 right because
the queen has to keep uh protection of
the bishop so H4 Queen F6 another
forcing of Rook df1 again attacking
Queen we can't play Bishop F5 stopping
the attack that just walks into G4 all
right so I have a visual admission but
now you have to go to 87 and he had to
play Queen E7 only move only move
because this uh by the way Patrick got
off to a terrible start the worst you
can imagine and I think he lost his
first three games and it was like Wow
but
here you see the best of Patrick Wolff
because Patrick had first of all he's a
U.S Champion you don't win the U.S
Championship without being really good
and he is also the U.S junior Champion
was he also as well uh but
one of the things one of the features of
his play was he was really really good
at forcing lines I mean he calculated
incredibly well and uh you know when he
was at his best he he had a very very
forceful game and it was very impressive
and here you see him with these all of
these moves Queen these Queen C7 Queen
T6 H4 Rook F1 very impressive forcing
moves if he does get in this Rook takes
F7 that would be a spectacular finish
Christian I love that move he is getting
it he is getting he's getting it because
it's forced and you don't have a way to
defend against it right well uh I for
some reason a queen takes G2 I know I
think I go Rook G1 it might be water
type of trouble yes and I Bishop takes
e66 maybe now
sure Bishop takes E6 you have some Queen
takes C2 I don't know
There's Something Brewing for sure now
Bishop takes F7 is a big threat right
you have to be careful
what can I do here uh Queen takes
but can I just do it like very very
simple move actually just Queen D4
Rook G1 yes
Queen E2 just Queen D4 I want to be
attacking on G7
that's a nice and If You're Gonna Play
E5 yeah then I'm gonna play some Rook
takes at seven
can I do that my goodness okay
taking H1
King A1 A1 sorry
no Checkmate no I have nothing oh
and Rook G8 show me what I missed
beautiful
that that's uh like the Paul morphy uh
Opry game the only thing you're
checkmating me with is what you've got
left on the board uh a rook and a bishop
wow I don't want to see how you want to
be different thank you exactly before
because I'm just targeting G7 bad stuff
happening to the black king guys wow
it's really bad right now it's really
bad and I think Dimitri is starting to
realize that he missed Rook takes F7 in
all these lines there's something
hanging on F7 at some point I think he
underestimated that perhaps missed it
entirely the nice one is right here this
Rook takes F7 and I've got a feeling
that uh Patrick is alert oh he's an
opportunity he's sort of like uh wait a
minute wait a minute okay so let's try
this is what's going to happen yes with
a rook yeah take on E6 with the bishop
most likely and now I go something like
I don't know Queen F6
does that save me in any way shape or
form or I don't know like how do you
continue right now
can I go Queen D7
you sort of a cat that's a Chuck mating
threat
so okay ah but now
I take and you take the bishop and your
your material uh winning easy enough
easy enough so Bishop takes E6 can I
move
this bishop somewhere no because I have
Queen B8
is amazing Queen B8 oh that's nasty
oh that is absolutely nasty that was why
that was why we were looking at Queen F6
huh Queen G5 well this makes it
well I could have gone Queen E7 the last
time too so Queen E7 uh Kate is there a
club
after Queen G1 maybe I can start with
Rook F1 what if just Rook D1 here this
is a nice one I just want to capture the
bishop
not just that is like the uh you know
destruction destruction is going on here
in this year too many things hanging too
many things hacking you don't have a
counter counter play at your hands I
mean this is an amazing game again
apologies but I do feel that the Alice
Lee uh versus Carissa match up that is
going to decide by the way that's uh Zoe
Tang versus Kelsey Lou yeah and they did
go into it equal they did go wow yeah I
think this was wasn't this our variation
though um well I thought it was Rook F2
but actually I probably prefer Kelsey's
play which was rookie rookie one this is
nice because you also activate the Rook
you can capture I don't know I like this
professional uh get in one extra check
before uh well two extra checks uh get a
minute on the clock Rook takes now we
can expect King G1
G1
and I'm assuming I have to then just be
captured upon the A7 with the bishop
pretty pretty even I'm going to say oops
sorry although you know the structure
maybe there's something to play for but
sorry you we got completely excited
I'm trying to get to the Charisma game
but I'm not getting there we left it
with A4 King h8 and we were we're trying
to say that maybe Alice's King was
somehow a tactical Target right we were
some variations we were playing Knight
F5 and other variations you want to
activate your bronzo knight
C4 and Alice played Knight C5 okay I'm
Alice is looking to activate her Rook
she's also asking about this question
what about the Apon Bishop E3 on the
board and I think we've caught up
who's made progress what's your team so
but I can capture Pawn on A4 but it may
be sounds
yes I'm learning
okay yes uh you're ruined uh okay uh but
aren't you aren't you kind of leading
your night a little bit in the okay if I
go B3 Knight C3 I've given you a square
bit if I go Bishop here first with the
with the double threat of Bishop takes
check and B3 right
but you do have a check I agree and if
I'm just like Rook on d8 as well but I
cannot do that right now I know that's
too many things at once not allowed
according to my theater handbook so what
king G7 King G7 okay B3 uh Knight also
on my agenda right but now I go with
Rook d8 oh Rook d8 important Tempo
ah Rook d8
gosh darn it that is a very important
Tempo uh
I will have to play Knight D6 first then
so that I'm giving myself this checking
square and I'm looking at B3
this is double edged stuff uh Christian
clear our cobwebs here uh who's improved
their position since we last took a look
the assessment hasn't changed that much
it is still white who is ahead but
indeed completely double-ish stuff after
Knight takes A4 unclear who is going to
come out on top out after this bishop to
G2 sure your knight is a bit out of play
so far I will be able to go Bishop to D4
later on in the position double edged
white is still better but I have to say
it's all going to come down to the last
few minutes of this one because I'm not
expecting any sort of crazy imbalances
being created and
um the advantage swinging both ways I'm
expecting this one to stay close up
until those last few minutes when some
big blunders will happen because the
position is so difficult and so complex
vital to our standings because Carissa
needs a win
game if she gonna win against honestly
she's slowly catching up to her with
half a point behind and if Zoe makes it
throughout the day yeah then she's gonna
to catch up with Alice going into the
final two
huge matchup guys but for those who are
joining us like first of all shame on
you for joining us light but what was
incredibly humorous about this game is
the first 14 movement so fast uh Alice
gained five minutes on her clock and
then it was that moment where G4 Knight
takes G4 came Alice had played
everything instantaneously uh up until
that moment
Carissa went into a deep tank thing she
played 92 and then yeah so uh Alice
Alice also caught up on the clock as
well she went into a tank yeah in that
moment if you left for one hour and then
came back there will be only two extra
moves
played between them actually and it's it
are the times a factor now after that
burst of energy in the opening I mean
the position is going to be more and
more complicated right with the pawns
running and kind of attacking the light
pieces and both have less than 30
minutes so they have similar time 26
minutes for karissaib 24 for Alice Lee
but they still have 16 moves to make
yeah nerves could be a factor easily uh
but that that that key move Knight takes
A4 and she's taking that she's taking
the pawn now I was playing Bishop D4 and
the crazy part was uh Christian was
saying the engine likes Bishop G2 I was
trying to explore avoid the night
off-site yeah yeah I had an idea after
that Bishop D4 that we played so Bishop
D4 King G7 okay and now you wanted to
play Knight to D6 and if I give you a
check on E1 I forced the king to go to
the e-file correct and then I let's say
play Rook E6 attack the Knight
on my next move and by the way Bishop D4
she played King yes on my next one I'm
gonna play Rook da to make a pin for
that Bishop okay so first of all this
guy is hanging so I've got to give you a
check
I can move to F7
F7
so I go Bishop C4 you take my knight
and this Knight wow okay Rook E1 what's
um
shaky hands I'm not sure I know what I'm
doing you could go Rook d8 like no then
you pick with check oh my neck is gonna
be trapped
all right let's go Rook E8 Rook EA oh
but then your knight is trapped but I
have C5
ah thank you that clears them ah could
you be in an eternal no you're not in an
eternal pit that's a funny one you know
how how those wishes work right
um
C5 oh I have a lot of quants as black
for sure you do so Rook
to E6 Knight check King F7
hmm
looks right Bishop C4 you took a knight
looks right
and your your your key saving move is
the C5 move
here Rook here
um
not seeing it I just ran out of get I
ran out of ammunition I I was can we go
on B3 now which one B3 yeah but B3 is
what I tried and she and Kate hit me
with C5
it's a big hit big hit and she was
saying that you know like the black got
a lot of Pawns and uh hard to argue with
that things I
if I would have a Pawn on F4 just stop
you those pawns yeah that would be so
nice I know it's like one of those
Eternal pin moments but uh not to be so
here this is sorry uh I I'm going to
just refresh my board for a moment uh
this is
G7 this is where I like that move yeah
this is where I went Knight D6 because
if I played the desired B3 you hit me
with Rook d8 right right
very serious I think 96 makes a lot of
sense at least practically and then Kate
was very forcing she was very consistent
she she wanted me to put my king
along the D file so that
Rook d8 would come uh okay so let's try
it's night night takes B7 sure why not
let's try it out because last time
Knight F5 just didn't work for me I mean
I don't know what's wrong with you yeah
sir I'm not taking calls I mean it's
something is wrong it's been it's been
uh it's been a long tournament you're
starting nothing anymore what is this I
I'm questioning my my starting to be
worried about you right my instincts
here so let's go Rook V8 Rook to B8
and now when you captured opponent A5
I'll go Rook d8 to pin that Bishop which
was my initial plan exactly
exactly
so here is like one of annoying really
very very annoying
I'm not getting the grip on the position
so if I go Bishop C4 you go one if
rookie four some King D3 and now you can
just take on D4 and take on B7 that's
not good
yeah I'm very happy with two extra Pawns
and it's like right it's not just King
with somehow your knight is safe and she
took that pawn on A4 did Alice and said
okay show me what you got
not that easy really not that easy
now we kind of start to understand why
Bishop G2 a moment ago was like okay I
have an idea yeah can we go
into that main line that we discussed so
Knight D6 rookie one
now I go Knight to five first
yes that was our initial thought and
then can I give you another check on H6
so now we are playing for a draw no no
no I'm not so my idea was that whenever
you go King G7 now I go Bishop C4 and
there's no more Knight hanging on D6 and
if you go Rook D6 I have Knight F5 that
is true but I can capture the Knight and
then pin the bishop Rook d8 you can
absolutely
why would you just
then I was not sure what's happening
after Knight F5 again
well a lot of pieces
be careful yeah sir let us show yeah
the new chapter in Christians look what
he asked her it's very nice pattern you
have to show you show the pattern
seems to be going towards a repetition
and a draw this was it the Bishops of
opposite color position
um it's interesting Gracie is very low
on time she has only eight minutes but
she just needs to make one move
and yes they are claiming threefold
repetition Chris bird is there
let's see if he what are you going to do
ask Chris by the way there's another
really interesting game
um Rochelle Wu Rose Atwell Rochelle is
really attacking now
when we left it we left it at the
position we're after D5 and the position
had well and truly blown up at this
moment Castle's short how about that D6
Bishop okay King was going alongside the
short side well yeah but the the I mean
uh Rochelle's King is still in in the
center of the board what is this
cheap by the saying this bishop by the
way is kind of like an ambush right yeah
that's an amazing thing about Bishops
they can be really really far away and
then they'll be absolutely amazing job
across the board h7h6 fortifying the
pawn on G5 and we've got a mess but like
Rooks I mean Bishop C4 now I'm I don't
think about the black king and some
sacrifices on G5
I don't disagree I'm just trying to
still get the Zen of the position King
H7 maybe bishop F5 is on Black's agenda
it's a mess Christian what do we got you
you're like a frustrating somebody
missed did Patrick Wolf missed that Rook
F7 business no it's on the board
actually here it's on the board let's
take a look Rook text F7 just happened a
beauty by Patrick is he's he's shaking
off the rust so it's refresh yeah h
oh sorry I'll refresh all right
um
this is when we left it we left it after
age five Dima played Queen G5 Rook F7
Patrick will not be denied and that is
the money move uh we just think it's a
winning variation this one is looking
good guys very good
uh Dima
kudos to Patrick I mean he's really
getting his hits in in those last few
three games I think two two and a half
out of three if he wins this one exactly
we're looking at oh he takes E6
uh taking the attacking The Rook
attacking the bishop we're Reckoning
Checkmate only eight yeah it's actually
threatening check the most important
threat of the position
Queen he ate mate uh Queen E7 and I
loved your Rook D1 idea so that you know
we
it's kind of uh like one of these puzzle
rushes right you see all of all they're
good for like three points each time you
know these tactics is just so important
to see so the whole position kind of
comes together we were also looking at
Bishop takes E6 I don't know if there is
difference between these two moves I
feel like both should be winning a
little bit
no there is nothing Bishop takes C2 and
queen takes G2 no yeah this should both
be very good and queen takes E6 on the
board
yeah this is a very nice game for
Patrick absolutely
oh definitely feels like it belongs in
that best game collection if he gets the
finish that he wants you know some
beautiful either a check mating finish
or just collecting pieces uh Christian
what what's caught your attention well
there's a lot of action sure section
guys let's go they actually followed uh
Arthur Go versus Andrew Hong big big big
Clash for the top position and take a
look at what happened Knight C7 we were
discussing about this position right
right and I said E6 makes at least
visually the most sense because you want
to kick this Knight away and get some
play on the king side Knight C7 and I
really like this move A5 you can play
Knight takes A6 absolutely no problems
but then you give black something to
play for right this exchange sacrifice
the knights are starting to swarm around
your king jumper you don't want to see
it on the board why would you want to
see this on the board when you can just
simply kill the game kill the counter
play with the move A5 now whenever Rook
takes B6 I take back the bishop stays on
E3 uh guards this entry for the Knight
on H5 uh controlling the square F4 this
is really beautiful chest by Artur go
right now and Knight to F3 was played
Knight takes A6 Rook B7 he doesn't even
want to touch that Rook on D1 there's no
counter play I have two extra pawns I
have pushes deadly one that's going to
get pushed down the board of course we
have so many ways Knight C5 is one way
Rook to D3 just simply moving The Rook
away is another way this one is looking
like it will be over anytime soon and I
have to say and look at Andrew I mean
the body language says it all yeah on
Andrew has
yeah his his over this game he knows
that he's in big big trouble it's very
unlikely that he's going to survive this
one well I just push him baby b2b4
[Music]
take take any exchange that you want and
you know speaking of Arthurs and pushing
Palms crazy games
uh when we left that game we uh Kirk was
in Dire Straits actually we thought that
uh it went back to that whole move with
King B1 and he the best move in the
position right defending upon A2 he did
capture the pawn but he didn't follow it
out with that move Bishop G5 which the
computer engine you know easy for us to
talk about it we're sitting nice and
comfy in the studio and well okay some
some kicking by Kirk is going on here H5
I'm not sure about kicking right now he
takes E6
two pawns are ready to be pushed okay a
little more forward you're sacrificing
two pieces right because that guy's
hanging and that guy's hanging
so let's see let's take on A4 right well
it's like one of these visual moves uh
you get into a position like this in
your opponent castles and it's like like
is that even legal
you know you're stunned you notice
is a fantastic position just putting
pressure as wide you know kind of
guarding the open files and my opponent
long Castle on move like 29. and I was
just like is that
issue look at my security she never
moved the king and actually the position
was somewhat equal afterwards I had to
fight another two hours to actually win
the game but I just I just stopped
thinking about castling that was this
great game that Larson was telling me
the story so he's in a sicilian and his
opponent has captured on F7 and it's
really double edged he took back on F7
and Vladimir Rich did something else and
he put his King back on an E8 so villain
mirovic really started thinking about
what he's supposed to do and then he
made a move to prevent his opponent from
castling and then realized that he had
forgotten his opponent had forgotten
that he had moved his King
so he wasted the turn to stop being bent
from
forgetting that he couldn't but uh okay
what's going on in this crazy uh game uh
between Arthur and Kirk I like White's
position someone that's uh Kirk is now
winning from an objective point of view
yes I like all the attacks I mean I
understand why it does not have that
many pieces around the king anymore
you gave up okay come on it takes A4 is
not the right move it's not the right
right there is only one move in the
position and that's Queen to B5
after root of G6
wow okay that's don't ask me why well
again you know I understand sort of you
want to be in the queen of the D file
right trade after it's actually
difficult to find a square for the king
for the queen that's also right because
if you go to H3 I make a fork if you go
to F3 I have discovered it yeah well if
you go to F3 you've got a discovered
check right right and then the other one
was if you go to H3 I don't think you
want to exchange the Queens that's right
no that's the problem but Queen H3
what's Queen H3 whoa you just known
Knight F2 there's still the bishop on V6
yeah the vision comes back okay but the
problem is is you you your queen on D3
and your Rook on E6 were very nicely no
maybe you can go Queenie too right
you can go on the attack yourself
Queenie too and to guard the H5 Pawn
[Laughter]
let's say if the black queen captures
the Knight on A4 you start to think
about Queen takes 185 and I mean double
Checkmate right the yeah right so it's
not just taking the pawn it's the
aggression but it is part of your school
like you should be proud of me I am but
just hearing you say you know and
guarding me you're you threatened Maiden
one but you also guard the H5
uh I really feel bad for her oh he took
the night he took the night so what's
the event evaluation after capturing the
Knight is what's back in the game I'd
say Rook takes E6 yes that's the move
right yes and the valley zero zero no
classical drawish position the the crazy
part is I know we were asking about the
evaluation between Alice Lee and Karissa
yep those uh the the crazy uh two
Bishops versus rook and two pawns and if
he had said triple zeros I'm ready to
greet now we give a position where
you're two pieces up and it's triple
zeros it's like yeah oh come on and by
the way Arthur he recaptured with the
pawn I thought about the capture with
the Rook guys this is absolutely wild
stuff yeah he should have recaptured
with a rook taking with the pawn is is
how do you do that how do you take with
the pawn that's a good position so I
thought we wanted the pawn to push and
The Rook to maybe of course we did now
we have Queen B5 oh this doesn't make
any sense yes this is really bad now
Queen B5 finishes the game and we've
taken a piece and we've got that great
chance to opportunity wait what did he
miss was he looking for some Queen D7
after Queen B5 yes but then I just so
Queen B5 Queen D7 check
well the crazy part is that if you take
with the pawn on D7
you know you might be thinking that
after King F7 somehow your Rook is
protected
you know because the pawn should be be
changed
uh but no this is two extra this is two
pieces but to be to be frank the
variation was absolutely wild take a
look at this so or maybe we can put it
on your board okay C6 yep
what do you do now
that's let's say I really don't know F6
is a big problem yes so you should
probably go King F7 now I go Queen C4
makes sense right okay I like it threats
have double Checkmate or something yeah
exactly so you have to defend against
that with probably Queen to B5 attack
that Queen
and and the the king marches oh the King
goes out but you probably want to take
on E7 okay
you just simply don't have enough time
for sure in in that one Fair
which is not clear okay but let's say
you go into the straight line right 26
king of Fate okay another is only once
again one move not easy to spot at all
no Queen G6
not even looking in that direction
exactly you're not looking into that
direction you're making use of that
God forsaken Pawn on age six that's been
there for many many you know days and
finally it does something Rook G8
this is an amazing game and now once
again H7 the only movie oh yes
and then we get into some sort of
Perpetual in that position but they said
you just gave up the 496 for for free
it's absolutely crazy yeah wow
um perpetual and you cannot go Rook G7
because I go F6 it's
this is almost impossible by the way uh
it looks like a handshake on the board
as all I see is naked Kings and a bishop
out of that crazy position wow wow draw
between Vladimir kopian and Igor novica
sorry I I do want to go to the game of
Arthur and Andrew
look how happy they are both of them
just analyzing chess yeah this is uh wow
guys are completely winning for uh
Arthur Carissa or versus Alice that's
the big one right yes for the girls
Championship the girls section
and it seems like Carissa has been
leather spray by this by this
complicated situation right now she
played The Rook to d8 Bishop F2
and by the way B3 this is all her uh
this is where all her problems started
yeah Rook to d8 and she was supposed to
find this very difficult move Knight to
E3 okay only move that kept her in the
game because we're looking for you you
cannot take on D4 because of Knight F5
yeah now I have to go something like
Rook to E4 and the position continues
okay she played Bishop F2 but retreating
is not an option
because after Knight C3 you take Knight
T2 and I'm
forcing some very favorable exchanges
for black right exactly where is your
attack against my king I mean my King
was always in danger you don't have the
two Bishops anymore you're not
controlling both the light and the dark
squares you're in trouble right now
because I'm picking up the H2 Pawn okay
eight winning
rookware A8
and you're trying to to take one what if
I go Bishop C3
okay that's a good move never mind
capturing the pawn on H2 continue right
I mean rookate and probably it's fine as
well Rook H2 is just a simple way out
you take on B7 I go Rook to D5
controlling the Knight and then I start
pushing my pawns it's going to be a race
but it feels like the race is going to
be favoring a black by quite a
significant margin guys if Alice wins
this one oh yeah
in the bag yeah man first of all she's
going to be a point ahead most likely of
Zoe who I'm I haven't checked in a while
with two rounds remaining with two
rounds to go I mean this is huge for
Alice if she manages to win this one I
mean I have to say she's looking Prime
the junior Championship
I mean she's black today with karisaya
but then she's playing Mo and mangalan
with one still three points so they're
still doing somewhat well but the good
point lead that's a that's a great spot
to be in for Alex and I I did check
Kelsey versus Zoe that's a complete I I
nothing is going to happen in that one
exactly by the way this position that
Alice has I for me this is formidable
but I wouldn't even want to go into a
raise frankly I'm just thinking you know
I'll depend upon you know you've got to
defend this pawn and for sure I'm gonna
get two connected past bonds I mean even
if you play H4 uh there's no race you
know the pawns are just going after
after you and it's unclear to see what
white is going to be doing here right
your goal is just to be stopping them
that's the whole job right you're not
you you're not getting a passer on the
queen side I'm going to go h6g5 King G6
and what you're going to do one day is
you're going to start bringing your your
your minor pieces over to try to you
know Slow Me Down on the on the on the
king side but I'm I'm looking at Alice
and I'm really liking a position you're
saying Zoe is making a draw uh
she's got a board full of pieces we
haven't uh we haven't given her game a
great deal of attention but she's
actually doing very well in the
competition as well
this looks like it's one of those uh
nidores with G3 and Bishop G2 one of the
quiet before controlling C5 Square
well but
a little bit unexpected usually that
point is
starting C4 square like what and it
isn't the whole idea to like jump to D5
one day like why not jump there she
played B4 Bishop
and we've caught up with the players but
I don't know what's going on you tell me
am I supposed to take this guy and if
you take I might jump well but Bishop G5
I mean my dream is just to control
everything nicely with c2c3 but Bishop
G5
um
I'm wondering if I can play like okay
maybe H4 stopping Bishop G5 then Bishop
B2 and then jump on D5
makes sense what is the European B6
probably crashing the queen size yeah
what is my plan I don't know if I have
uh good plans in these positions
um
B5
I don't know
I I don't have a feel for these I'm not
an E4 player by Nature by white I I'm
more of a sicilian player for for
as black
maybe your H4 is kind of confounding me
because you're you're weakening your
king side but you're taking away my
Dynamic idea of Bishop G5 my queen on A7
kind of menacing that diagonal maybe
hitting E3 you know as an x-ray
um
tough position tough position
yeah but uh
you know we we just had this end game
where where Igor and Vladimir have
traded down to naked Kings basically
right and these people they traded
anything I want to keep my Bishops in my
pieces you know holding on to everything
uh Christian back over to you what uh
was caught you lots of action in the
junior section guys I have to say a lot
of decisive results on the horizon take
a look at this one Rook to G6 Queen
takes A4 F takes E6 that was a very
questionable move of course Queen to B5
immediately spotted by Queen to H3 and
queen to E2 just landed on the board I
think this was the move that he missed
the move that Arthur missed in the
position because not only that is the
tax but it also defends The crucial H5
if I manage to get the queen on this
diagonal the the king is checkmated
right so do not allow the key the queen
to get to H5 that's exactly what he's
doing after Queen to E2 it's almost
resignation time you are a couple of
piece two pieces down and you don't have
any attack going on in the position so I
like this move Rook dg1 that's fine I
just go Rook to F1 I understand you have
a check uh on the board on G8 but Rook
to f8 just kills your attack can I just
go H7 you can you can try ambitious I'll
I have some checks as well all right I
move where do you go King A1 if you go
King A1 I have a very pretty way of
finishing the game Knight F4 yeah
exactly made on uh there's some maids
and you don't have a way to get back to
that there are no pieces around my white
king exactly where's my knight on B3 or
something what is the palace guard right
yeah and the thing is look you are not
threatening to go Queen h8 whenever you
go Rook to G8 I covered that with Bishop
to F6 so you're still many moves away
from creating something tangible in the
position it just doesn't look like um
Arthur will be able to do anything in
this one and Kirk probably will get
should I say deserved Victory I'm not
sure I mean this game was absolutely all
over the place but I have to say I mean
Arthur had an incredible opportunity out
of the opening and
he tried he he definitely took some
risks and unfortunately his decision
making was just not 100 precise he
needed that unfortunately for him he
didn't get it and right now he's
on the receiving end of the attack yeah
Kirk was very unlucky yesterday when
Mishra was able to defend that really
horrible looking end game so maybe today
it's coming back and he's not only
defending his very bad position but
actually making but guys we haven't
talked about Balaji that much and he's
been stringing some victories together
I'm not 100 sure how many points is
behind the leaders but I believe he's on
Two and a Half out of the last three and
looking to get another Victory today
right against Jason Liang and that one
is looking pretty good for him I mean
there's an attack brewing in that one
take a look at that he's on three points
if he wins this one yes he's getting
close yes
definitely a big big game for Balaji
yeah this tournament is still open for
for so many players to try to to win the
event exactly the junior says the doors
open uh the door is closed as far as the
seniors I just wanted to check in on the
game of Douglas root and Max delugie
because when we left it it looked like
Max was in real trouble he did try your
defense Queen to d8 Knight F3 inviting
Rook takes E2 Max said well I've got
nothing else going for me
F6 very important move Knight G5
Bishop E6 Queen H7 and we've got the
good old-fashioned
uh
King hunt going on here Douglas wow
getting his first V3
before Oh I like that oh that's nice
alert alert don't don't don't reach for
the queen and after B4 Knight takes B4
Knight H7 I'm preparing a really nice
Checkmate yeah oh yes oh
that's a visual is is this is that
Unstoppable when you have no Queen E5
you get checkmated I think this is over
guys yeah no you you can't you can't uh
oh that B4 oh
so nice nice right nice Nate uh almost
announce it but let's just see why it's
so important because I if I don't play
before and I try immediately with Knight
H7 the same trick
wow so this B4 move I just give up the
pawn you can capture with the queen and
once you captured with the Knight yeah
you are no longer threatening the E1
square right very nice way to finish the
game for Douglas get his first victory
in style right
great game
wow and for Max by the way this this is
quite the tumultuous
last three rounds have not really gone
his way at all and
yeah if he was to lose this is the
opposite of the hat trick it's castling
long you're getting three zeros did he
lose his last three I thought he lost
his last two yeah well we we know with
this one it would be his last right
acopian yesterday no it was the four
that was the aliens the longest Pawn
chain Invaders yeah
on the chessboard in this tournament
hung in there I mean we kind of thought
it was oh
um he took I do why I think it was Rook
well Rick Rook D1 game over right but he
saw that there's a there's a traffic
accident hanging there is uh yeah a bit
of an overstate uh yeah no this is over
for sure okay
Christian back over to you while I'm
still looking at the Juniors because
that's where the action is and this one
is huge for the standings abhimani
versus Justin Wang right I think we left
it somewhere around here
um Rook to E5 was the last move or maybe
after Rook takes E3 and I really like
what black did Justin the next sequence
of moves take a look you have to do
something with black you have to create
some counter chances this one is over
and Max seemed Lugia signed and Douglas
gets his first victory in style I mean
97 beautiful beautiful way to finish the
game
getting back to this one take a look at
this F4
you cannot take because of Bishop to G7
on the pin lose the piece game over Rook
to E5 Queen to G4 let's trade Queens I'm
an extra Pawn on this side right but I
have to do something because you're
checkmating me you're coming H5 and if I
allow this pin to continue on the G file
I'm in trouble so I have to do something
I really like the sequence defensive
sequence uh that Justin Wang found Rook
28 F3 Bishop 25 yeah F takes G2 Queen
takes G4 Bishop takes G4 kintech G2 and
we entered this end game
which I have no idea
I was expecting this great explanation
really look the engine is saying 0.1 0.3
and I'm not 100 sure what's happening
right now I see Bishop to F3 followed by
Bishop to E4 but I still see this very
annoying pin on the eighth rank to be
honest despite the fact that he's a pawn
down I still see abimanu as the
Practical favorite in this position but
I have to say the way the trend is going
and the way Justin is finding every
single defensive task I have to say he's
he's doing well in this one and
abhimanyu still has plenty of work to do
to get some sort of an advantage and
this one and he's risking as well he is
a pawn down that a pawn if it stays
alive I mean that's going to be a
dangerous weapon in Black's head
thank you Christian I just think there's
a little too much honesty from Christian
I don't know what's going on
[Laughter]
is it going for Basics wait wait a
minute he's reaching he's done it he's
played D7 all right B6 B6 okay I
remember uh annotating games this is the
period before computers and when you
didn't know what was going on you would
say with Dynamic chances for both sides
both sides stand well and that's the
problem yeah with this position you play
B6 very natural move but now after the
move F4 for example you don't have a
clear way of simplifying the position
anymore
um yeah these Eternal pins this work on
EA yeah as you say really likewise
position the bishop on E5 extremely
strong the spin on the back Rank and
I trade the Bishops and then maybe
recapture one of those pawns with my
Rooks exactly somehow Justin is just
super relaxed I mean you see him joking
around B6 no problem played a la Tempo
just think for like 30 seconds why not
I'd like to turn our attention to the
game between shabalov and Joe Benjamin
because that game really blew up uh when
we left it uh it seemed like both
players had kind of reached some kind of
uh maximum if you will you know they and
uh Queen F1 I mean Joel had been putting
a lot of pressure on these double pawns
but in the meanwhile uh why does somehow
he's got the center he's got space and
if you don't hit well you know there are
things around your king H6 F4 D5 C5
ideas
bam F5 Joe wanted to force uh the action
and they've got this position Trey trade
I mean I'm so happy now for the bishop
on B2 I feel like that Bishop was very
useless for so long well they're funny
the bishop of B2 said uh actually I'm
worried about Queen it takes F5 and 93
check ideas let me kick you out I just
go back okay let me let me get this this
night on H6 away at night on G5 away G4
look at this this is crazy stuff that's
going on takes takes but now two pieces
are hanging right see this is when you
know shabalaf gets his kind of game
you know where where where where
tactics you know are Paramount
[Laughter]
crazy stuff happens
I don't believe it I think shabalov must
be winning I just I mean that's just
it's a check wait why can't you just
capture it with the queen I understand
but I'm
I was
you take I wanted to keep I wanted to
keep the light squares yeah but Bishop
E3 I have extra night
well
Maybe
Bishop E3 you have extra night
yep I'm not going to argue that that
looks very
good
what can I say I think you have
something better just moving the king
away that was my first thought yes
because I think we should move to Arthur
Gua versus Andrew Hong just because
I feel a resignation coming
uh
Arthur was enjoying very nice position
yeah that was the three connected past
bonds game and he's getting the push of
baby strategy yeah yeah yeah yeah make
it simple pushing me okay before I take
C4 that's going to be Knight takes an
exchange up you're not getting any
counter play and I'm pushing my pawns
yeah the promotion
also Andrew only one minute left on his
clock
still nine moves to make nine moves to
make bath the clock is not his biggest
problem
the passers
the passers yes yeah one has to be a
little careful about some background
checkmates just kick kick some you're
right I mean my knight on C4 is not
needed the pawns were going to do the
job right just gotta kick those Bishops
out of the way a bit uh so that uh and
to cover the back rank mate you have
another idea here Kate
um no one I think I think white is white
is winning for sure uh by the way that
you you mentioned
Balaji and adjacent but you didn't
follow up on why Balaji was winning
well he's doing very well because I mean
I'm taking on G7 very soon and you're in
trouble yeah I mean you're getting
checkmated on the king side first I
think the only way out is to sacrifice
The Exchange but if you do that
I I don't see you coming it's not a it's
not a happy happy Route 66 is the only
move right position is it H5 can I
can I try that you can try throw
something in the in the mix well will I
go Queen G6 or will I take on H5 right I
was just wondering
I I can't be disruptive right
you certainly can
I don't know what I'm doing frankly I I
think I'm just losing uh why I don't
just capture that pawn exactly I'll just
I was thinking I was uh Knight takes G7
maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh trying
to throw uh some and by the way we do
have a result as uh Patrick Wolfe uh won
a very nice game it wasn't the
spectacular finish that we'd hoped for
but it was a nice win yeah I mean that
Rook takes F7 really important tactical
trick he found it yeah a beauty for sure
um we didn't see the game between
Josiah and Brandon Jacobson and I think
Brandon was she European yes yes brand
is my pick what's happening with him
um
looks evenish I want to say I think
Brandon is down to his last minute
that's the only problem wow but he
already he needs one more move to make
40th move his last move was in fact
Knight on E1
to C2
so when I get yeah Rook C3 then I get my
Bishop out
well I mean
maybe blacks for Choice here actually
right
today if you can play Bishop Bishop at
night you're a happy camper uh and no uh
not
not doing well for uh Josiah here uh but
uh we have a special guest with
Christian Douglas a difficult tournament
for you up to this point but finally you
get that breakthrough what an incredible
Victory congratulations tell us a bit
about your experience with this game but
also with the tournament as a whole oh
made so many blunders I'm hoping I
finally did this game no
uh yeah I'm very fortunate to have won
and uh
I'm really happy it looked like a nice
game I haven't had time to go over it in
any detail yet
Alexi your wife who is also here with
you as your second she did say that you
had to dust off some uh rust off your
shoulders but now finally that you did
that you produced a masterpiece I have
to say and I want to go towards the end
this was the critical moment when he
found this move B4 very beautiful tell
us a bit about the story of this move
why this works and what were your
feelings when you found this move from
afar oh well I knew I had my thread of
Knight H7 and queen h8 check followed by
Queen f8 me
but if I wait too long then he might be
able to consolidate and so uh and he was
at the moment threatening to check me or
or at least a very bad check with the
rookie one check I'd have to which I
would have to give up my queen with
Queen F1 to avoid me but um
so in order to
gain time for my intended Knight H7 I
could play the interference move before
and like a study situation right now he
can defend with Queen E5 because the
Rook d8 everything is kind of yeah just
uh connecting very well for you yeah
this one Douglas congratulations uh big
game for you guys any questions for
Douglas yeah Douglas congratulations on
a very nice game uh we really liked in
the studio the sequence right F4 kind of
making the B2 Pawn
um poison and then Queen C1 and F5 was
that the moment when you started to feel
like you know you have the game in your
hands very comfortable at this moment or
did you still think uh you know that's a
fighting game
uh I thought that I had a uh good attack
at this point
um whether it was winning or not I I
couldn't say it this early for certain I
hoped it was but
it looked good to me and so I I went uh
for this uh exchange I
um I thought he might actually uh take
on F5 with the bishop after uh oh after
G takes uh F5 he takes F5 Bishop takes
F5 uh in which case I have uh moves such
as Knight D4 because the bishop has been
to the Knight and uh then uh rookie five
and uh I was considering G4 at this
point which looks strong to me at the
time why not yeah yeah no A3 I think is
the best but G4 looks very promising as
well beautiful yeah yeah sir very nice
game and spectacular finish
congratulations absolutely
and here are our results in uh the
seniors as uh one game remaining only
one game so we have rude Who won against
Boogie right Drew against kachin Patrick
Wolf won against Dimitri greenevich also
very nice Victory right and akabi Andrew
with Navica and the one one game that
was the most spectacular ends in the
draws like what yeah and uh the
remaining game shavala Benjamin that
looks like it might go into a decisive
game as well I wanted to turn our
attention to uh Carissa and Alice Lee
because this is going to decide the
tournament and well I don't know but so
rooking it happened as I predicted but
maybe not there was an inclusion no no
there wasn't one important conclu
inclusion and that was first Rook E1
remember because okay now she went for
this and this was a some strange
decision making going on here this move
I I found you know I was sitting there
explaining when you've got at the two
Rooks trade one off no she didn't go for
it and she's turned it into a bit of a
race I mean I don't doubt that black is
for Choice after F4 is he though but
right is it is it I mean because Knight
d8 96 I mean 96 95. yeah if the Rooks
were off the board the pawns are really
running fast exactly with the Rooks on
the board not so sure Alice has got this
one in the bag uh but a while we
actually have uh Patrick with us and he
says he's scared but he's scared you
scared for who if you were white or if
you were black I'd be scared if I was
white because I think I should be
winning this position but I'd see all
sorts of ways I could lose it
that's true I mean it's so difficult to
assess right exactly I know like you put
it into the engine and it's just all so
easy but um
yeah
no question at the board and White's
Pawns of nowhere right now not yet
absolutely yeah so I don't know
yeah interesting one still plenty to
play for in that one but Patrick I mean
another victory for you yesterday you
played all the way until the last final
yeah it was a tough game I was actually
pretty proud of my game yesterday I
thought it was a great game by the way
sorry to interrupt this one is over I
think Kirk got another Victory a
difficult one I have to say he was
completely losing out of the UK but
Patrick back to your game yeah this was
the big moment right here when he
decided to take Rook takes C3 yeah how
did you assess it at this point how
would you decide to go for this queen C3
Queen C7 okay were you worried about
that I'll so scroll back two moves yes
okay right here right I played Bishop C4
after a long thing okay and I did not
see Rook ac8 Bishop B3 Rook take C3 and
then and then I played the move and I
was like oh no and so while he was
thinking I was thinking even though I'm
walking around I was like I spent like
whatever it was 15 minutes thinking
because if you have to take with the B
Pawn yes yes I see right yes so well if
I if I take with the B Pawn I think I
lose immediate with Knight takes E4 but
um but um instead what I I thought I
could play Bishop takes F6
um Bishop takes yeah exactly I thought I
could play this position but I didn't
want to play this position yeah so I
look at the eval bar it says it's equal
forget about it but I you know I mean
these these positions are often okay for
white but Black's having all the fun
yeah but then I saw Queen take C3 and
the more I looked at it the more I liked
it
um and it works I I think it just works
it does yeah and this was the critical
moment at this point
he got a bit greedy to keep the Queens
on the board Queen to E7 was the only
way to continue this game yeah that made
sense to me and then I thought Queen E5
yes
25 I go back Bishop F5 were right yeah
and even here like I could even go Rook
takes F5 I think that position like
maybe it's not completely correct I
don't know but it's a very it's a much
easier like white is better for sure
because eval bar yeah yeah like white is
always better you put the pony yeah yeah
yeah
so I wasn't afraid of this and then he
played Queen G6 and I saw this Rook
takes F7 tactic
oh wow oh yeah this is over after this
oh I didn't realize it was that good
when
sitting in couch
encounter Unstoppable yeah Rook F7 is
just uh killing yeah that tactic with
rookie one is very pretty I was very
pleased when I saw that yeah yeah this I
calculated all the way and then I I also
if you go back there's this he can also
try this bishop takes C2 check at the
left Point uh yeah so you can like here
yeah but I think so I can take with the
bishop yes but I can also I think take
with the King okay let's see
Queen takes and go up and go up yeah so
the eval doesn't like it as much that's
interesting it just thinks the position
of the bishop takes C2 is winning so you
have to go yeah
king of okay some crazy moves yeah king
of faith is the only way to not die no
no but well but you you do die right
because it's Queen
right that's the only way not to die
well Bishop takes F7 yes Queen F7 oh
yeah yeah yeah sure sure we play this
position yeah sure sure that's right
yeah yeah it's not that easy of a
conversion right I mean yeah is still a
bit weak
although I suspect it's actually not
that bad but anyway I think but if you
go back it looks like I had better
um I mean this is the nice thing is like
I don't have to worry about it I can
just let him move and then I'll decide
but if you go back instead to one move
well yeah uh yeah Queen takes E6 Bishop
C2 check
and does it just want me to take with
the bishop yes yeah yeah it's just that
it's just that good huh I mean it looked
like it was going to be very good yeah
um and I guess the only question is what
to do after king of Faith right yeah
because if he goes into this end game
this is hopeless yeah yeah yeah but King
f8 it seems like Rook D1 oh my goodness
Rook D1 is just winning
so easy when you've got this well I know
no but I mean I knew this position was
very good right because his light
squares were infinitely worse than my
dark squares
um and um yeah it was really interesting
how somehow it became a Sosa and I mean
Dimitri and I have played so many of
these classical Sicilians sometimes
they're rousers and in the old days I
mean 30 plus years ago they were sozens
and we must have had five or six dollar
mirrors attacks so it's very funny that
somehow this became kind of like a Susan
but this Rook takes F7
um yeah and Yasser was praising your
style saying that you're extremely good
at direct play what is working better
that's a very very nice way to say that
I'm very one-dimensional
that's really beautiful great attacker
what's the difference in the second part
of the event compared to the first part
of the event what's working better you
know I mean I I make I've been making
this joke for the last couple of days
that I've been shaking the rust off and
I feel like by the time the tournament
ends I'm going to be ready to play and
um I think I was just really rusty and
um you know my first game against Kai
donov I literally I mean he surprised me
in the opening he played he played
Bishop E3 which I did not expect in the
night of and I just forgot the lot I
just totally forgot the opening and then
against Max I had a perfectly good
position and just like really didn't
like stop at the critical moment Queen
takes D4 was terrible right Bishop H6
was very good and then against
um uh uh shabalov well I played the
opening battle he out played in the
opening but then on top of that
um I played this movie Bishop takes H6
which is right idea wrong execution
completely what I should have done is
play Queen E3 first yeah membership A6
and I realized afterwards you know part
of getting back into the rhythm is being
sort of aware of like the tension in the
game and like the critical moments and
the emotion and just sort of like and
this it's hard to explain with words but
anyone who plays chess sort of like just
understands this right you just sort of
have to get into the feel of it and um
you know I I the last couple games I've
gotten into the feel of it Mike I was
very very happy with my game against
Joel because he completely surprised me
in the opening and I played my line but
it's a position I've never played before
I I thought really really hard
um I got slightly outplayed a slightly
better position at one point than I was
slightly worse but I held and I saw I
was lose I was I was low running low on
time I managed the time pretty well I
checked it afterwards I think it was it
was a very well played game by both of
us actually I don't think there were any
real mistakes that gave me a really good
feeling you know and then of course I
just hope for the best I prepared for
the game he completely stepped out of my
preparation and we got a fight and my
one-dimensional Approach my very direct
play was very uh was very uh successful
in this game so I was very happy Patrick
congratulations thank you great Victory
we'll see you in the next three hours
thank you very much I hope I'm back
thank you Patrick indeed we have a
couple of results including Michelle who
just made a Perpetual check uh Rose
picked up a bishop on H2 but there was a
pipette in the position but we have a
number of uh games going on that are
really wow uh super tense incredibly
interesting including the game of Alice
Lee and Karissa uh still I I do think
that Alice stands better but I do think
it's also a three result game which is
like really uh crazy and look at the
clock Alice has one minute 30 seconds
one minute and by the way this looks
like a like
I won this game a matchup of our leaders
uh as and he's our current leader right
very important oh you know it would help
if I knew what was going on in this game
I actually thought it was uh Carissa to
play and I was like why is she thinking
why isn't she not just playing Bishop at
E5 chat and you know forcing the king
back because if it was white to move
let's say we just play very very bad
move but if it was Carissa's on turn you
know she could easily set up for this
has 45 seconds how many moves to make
[Music]
Rook E6 move 36 okay
foreign
I told you I thought nerves might play a
role in this game at 40.
all right doesn't this invite
a draw by Bishop at this point I think
Alice is happy with her draw I'm not
gonna lie I think so it's more
complicated of course Carissa came in
needing a victory like it's absolutely
crucial for her
to play for a win okay so Bush P5
followed by rookie seven is there any
way I can play for more with black
so king of seven that's very dangerous
right
just to avoid any kind of King F7 I
guess that might actually work as well
well
it takes
okay
push push that push that guy Jack you're
inviting my pieces maybe I can weave
something here do I do I go King E7 King
seven King E6 I don't know
let's go
push them baby push them baby
Jack King d8
I thought kinky six no you might check
maybe yeah
I'm scared there
why would you
play this risky uh with the black pieces
I mean are you playing you you think
you're winning yeah I'm playing for a
win I don't know I'm winning oh wow okay
I misunderstood I thought that black was
trying to draw this game no okay I have
fun on F2 I'm recording okay okay
I understand uh
what was going on okay F7
Alice agrees with you
I'm I'm not sure if that's a good way to
go but that's the way to play for win
right because King G8 again if we take a
look at that you said Rook E7 right
after that yeah she's played King F7
we'll stay with the game position for
just a minute oh and we have a result
and he wanted to this tournament I mean
the stars but a great recovery uh really
bad sorry I think he was like maybe one
out of three or something along those
lines right it's a long tournament so
yeah he's back
bounce back so okay so King uh went to
F7 check
oh no I thought we were taking the pawn
okay
Carissa gave check well now you go back
and now you're a really really happy
camper
because we don't have rookie seven a
moment ago we had rookie seven but
Carissa that looks like a mistake but
maybe she wants to capture it upon after
and you don't have F3 push
right no uh okay if I capture
immediately then my knight gets to
return with check oh okay that's an
important okay I return yeah my night
I'm what's my night doing on BC B7 in G8
okay no uh Carissa this is a blunder
right Christian I have no idea I'm not
oh you don't know because we do have a
guest actually with us maybe he can help
us with with analyzing this we have a
Kirk gazerian after uh crucial victory
for him Kirk tell us a bit about this
game that we're watching right now can
you discern anything in the position
what's happening
well he doesn't have you don't have it
on yourself otherwise black should be
winning yes yes but on the other hand
it's not clear how white can avoid the
exchange of Rooks maybe Rook takes C6 F3
Rook C7 but then there's
at least Rook F7 for black
at least you say okay at least maybe at
most as well
but maybe there's also Rook at five I'm
not sure Rook F5 there's again this
check Rook C8 and if not look f8 if I
try King F7 uh Knight D6 check King E6
Knight takes F5
uh you can't play F2 because of Knight
E3 and if you play King tix F5 there's
Bishop D4 and ff2 Rook f8 so black
should go for a draw yeah in that case
yeah yeah
wow okay
and Alice is 11 seconds
this one was a group draw great by the
way defensive skills by Justin Wang no
question about it yeah he was under
pressure and we have a soul leader in
the Juniors right now it's Artur Goa yes
all right let's get back to to Alice
perhaps just to
well close the last few uh moves before
the time control rookie eight okay
okay I'm really having a hard time
understanding what the heck is going on
in between these players Rook EA why
does Alice doing Bishop D4 maybe I mean
isn't she helping white coordinate her
pieces I don't know I don't know what
else sir Knight is coming with the tempo
she used to make just last move to get
then the extra 30 minutes one more move
okay one more let's move forward
how much she she let her cloth take down
to what 10 seconds 10 seconds right 10
seconds and F3 and she's good
and she's made time control yes wow
well let's talk to our guest uh
Christian back to you well yes sir you
weren't understanding anything that one
but we didn't understand anything from
this game with the engine is much easier
to understand things but tell us your
perspective Kirk well okay I was out of
book quite early in this game I think
after age six I didn't know what to do
because I didn't expect this line when I
played the time on off
um
I mean something like this yeah yeah I
played Knight C4 quite quickly but I
suppose it was a mistake I I realized
quite after my position was extremely
difficult to play yes but these
positions are also never easy it's very
risky opening both sides always in these
open Sicilian battles when did you feel
like you're starting to turn it tight in
this one
it's hard to say I mean I think I was
completely lost at some point in this
game I was very lucky in the
complications the positions spiraled out
of control for him and by the way by the
way instead of B4
um I was thinking maybe I could play
something else I was thinking of Knight
D5
95 Knight takes D5
maybe B3 let's say queen C7
yes I expect this this is the problem
white just eventually crashes through in
the long run yeah it's just if white
just keeps sacrificing forward black
cannot defend the main problem is
there's no side of the board where
Black's King is safe exactly and he was
trying to do that he was trying to crash
through yeah he actually understood the
spirit of the opening he was trying to
play in this sacrificial Reckless manner
but the problem was uh you also have to
be precise exactly as well exactly
take take by the way I saw after Queen
D3 I could go Queen takes D3 yes and go
into that end game and I saw of course
now I'm no longer lost but this isn't
any game I cannot win at all so I was
just rather going to into the
complications and go to the same game
where I can't win keep the pieces on the
board yeah give him some room to make uh
errors yeah I was actually not surprised
by the evaluation during the game I
thought it could be something like that
but if he can win by force uh the
position still complicated and I'm a
piece up and I think this is the only
move did you spot this move during the
game this queen me too let me remember
um what if if Knight F6 Rook G7 it just
keeps consuming right the attack yeah
and if Queen c6f takes C6 hanging A4
yeah okay but I wasn't worried about
this yeah yeah this is impossible to
play over the board and he played Bishop
to B6 and finally at this point you're
starting to why is Queen B5 stronger
um there was some problems after uh Rook
G6 if you take he could have taken with
the Rook yeah this position is so
unclear because there's so many moves
going on I wasn't sure and my opponent
was getting low on time completely wild
and that was part of your strategy of
course right F takes C6 Queen to B5 and
after this
you're finally stabilizing yeah
stabilizing kind of a way to to say that
yeah King to E6 Queen to G6 she he he's
just running away of fire running out of
Firepower and he will look up nicely
done
Kirk you've had some difficult games in
the last couple of rounds you had a
beautiful position against Justin Wang
out of the opening yesterday against
abhimani how did you recover after those
hiccups I mean I was actually quite
lucky in today's game I would say that
the position spiraled out of control and
I I won the game but balances out a
little bit yeah definitely balances out
uh my earlier games uh I mean my game in
round four was quite painful I died
without any counter plays just complete
Suffocation
um yeah my game against Justin Wenger I
missed this 95 possibility Bishop takes
uh F6 followed by 95 in the opening so
that was a missed opportunity and yeah
in my game yesterday okay I I see that I
had a chance to win but I was less upset
because that position was very difficult
to win already for White and the whole
time I thought it was a fortress but
it's a very useful concept to know about
in the future that maneuver yeah that's
great well Kirk congratulations always
taking something positive out of your
games congratulations we'll see you in
the next couple of days thank you and
our congratulations to you as well uh
Kirk nicely done and uh results of the
Juniors this month yeah a lot of results
so Mishra Drew against wank you lost to
gazarian
the one against Liang and guo won
against Hong huge win for a girl as he
takes a clear lead uh with two rounds to
go a half a point lead and we'll just
pop in uh to shabala who is seems to be
winning his game against
um Joel Benjamin as well the soul game
remaining in the seniors tournament let
me just see when we left it what
happened after that Knight E1 yeah it
was the 91 move that was the one that
really uh caught our eye he did take it
and he said just like you uh Kate I'm a
piece up
what's wrong with being a piece up and
nothing
uh Joel no no there's no
Joe's desperate now he just sacrificed a
rook
but
no he's it it's there's no dark Square
Bishop to really attack the king yeah
and Christian uh
uh you have a guest in studio absolutely
we are right now with the sole leader in
the junior section Arthur first of all
congratulations just an incredible game
it was a matter of preparation in this
one you caught him out of the opening
and he started earring very quickly tell
us a bit about this opening preparation
of you yeah so basically I knew he plays
in Niger I didn't want to go into it um
Bishop B5 I saw he played Knight D7 once
against the other Arthur
um so I knew he wanted a game
um I think this G6 line you have to like
know it straight down you really know it
yeah because E5 is the most testing and
if you don't it's it's it's trouble for
black and he immediately went into yeah
yeah instead of D takes E5
my preparation was Knight takes E5
Knight takes you yeah okay Knight takes
a night 97 Knight takes F7
the computer this computer says plus six
but my stronger computer back home says
it's equal the ship takes yeah Bishop
takes D4 this is hard to find Bishop
takes F2 King H1 Rook takes d8
Bishop G5
Knight F6 Bishop C4 deep stuff yeah King
G7 Rook D2 and then you have to find D5
which is just like insane like
impossible yeah no no not D5 here Bishop
C5 rookie one and then D5 okay otherwise
the positions just collapse yes and once
she once she started thinking at this
point you knew that yeah you will
probably have the upper hand yeah
and uh you did just that and I have to
say I really like this idea of yours of
G4 G5 oh yeah I think you missed this
um if you could go back to one of the
other critical moments after B6
I mean we both for like a few minutes
thought like black was equalizing but I
think he missed this queen F4 idea which
is just like if you provoke E5
the D6 squared comes weak I didn't think
of Queen H4 but I thought it was just
better for one you're just getting them
exactly yeah
um but yeah even in this end game I
thought of Bishop E3 here instead of G4
which computer says the top move I think
they're kind of interchangeable I think
so too yeah yeah no I really like G4
from a practical perspective it just
feels like you're posing more problems
for him
Bishop C6 it's also a move that shows
confidence somewhat right
because you are weakening your king a
little bit and you have to calculate
quite precisely and he collapsed
immediately after yeah you've been
having quite the tournament so far tell
us a bit about your routine what do you
do during the day do you call your coach
what do you do you have a coach no I
don't have a coach so I just prep by
myself but
yeah I've been just I mean I do prep go
to sleep prep when I wake up watch a
little TV in between
um that's pretty much it yeah keep it
simple and it's definitely working how
do you see your chances to get to that
elusive title
um I don't know I mean like it's it's
fine right now at least I think Abby has
a chance tomorrow so I mean there's
plenty of people that can catch up
plenty of uh just to be played in the
last couple of rounds congratulations
for your Victory we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
and Kate you have a question yeah so you
have a very successful year you have you
are a Grandmaster elect Right
congratulations for that as well uh
what's been happening with you this year
that it's so successful
um honestly I've been asking the same
question myself I honestly don't know
I've been stuck around like 24.50 for
like two years
mainly because I've been focusing on
non-chess related things
um but this summer like I played like I
went to Europe right after school and
got my final two Norms there and then
got over 2500 which was you know a
confidence boost and that definitely
helped in this tournament
so far at least
Arthur inquiring minds want to know you
said uh I've got a stronger computer
than this one tell our viewers what
computer you have I mean this is whereby
yeah sir this is just stockfish 14. this
is yeah
I have stockfish 15. I know a 16 came
out but I've yet to buy that one yet
and uh your your laptop do you use a
specific uh video card on your laptop
for your engine
I honestly don't know
but it's it's it's been working so far
so well that's all I need keep up the
good work and congratulations and two
rounds to go uh so yeah Championship
rounds Dead Ahead well done
I sounded like a techie what I was
talking about who was that guy yeah you
are planning to play the USA
that's impressive we're gonna take a
break here but more Championship chess
Dead Ahead see you on the other side of
the brink
[Music]
I think just the biggest thing is just
to you know love the game you know
that's the big thing why I've continued
for like so many years now
um yeah just finding passion what you
love you know there's always times when
like chess feels kind of boring or you
just don't want to stare at it for hours
and hours
um but always what keeps me coming back
is just that I love the game I love
winning and yeah hopefully I continue
that here
um well I would say you have to love the
game because if you don't have any
passion then it's very hard to improve
so first learn to um enjoy the process
and then once you've figured that out
you can improve quite easily for me at
least for me when I was growing up I was
just playing the game just for the
passion of it I didn't really have any
clear goal in mind and um I'd say the
same just uh play the game if you enjoy
it you don't know where it'll take you
and just uh see how it goes I would tell
them to aim high but I wouldn't say to
that go too much I would say just focus
on improving whatever you need to
improve at the time and just try to play
For the Love of the Game not for like a
title you might be chasing or a rating
you might want I'd say the first main
thing in in order to become better at
basically anything is to enjoy the game
otherwise everything will feel like
torture so my advice is enjoy the game
and work on the areas which you feel
that are not up to up to the mark and
yeah work hard and everything else will
will come your way I think the big thing
is you have to be self-motivated I know
a lot of young players you know their
their parents push them well which is a
good thing
um but I think in the end the people who
make it really far are the ones who are
always hard on themselves and pushing
themselves to be better regardless of
what level they're at I think that's the
number one thing just that sort of
attitude of being tough on yourself and
always pushing yourself to get to that
next level well I mean I've solved
around 1200 or 1300 hours of Chess Tempo
when I was a kid and that helped me
immensely and one of the things I regret
was not having a solid repertoire from
the beginning um during my game so it's
a very important to play very solid
openings from the beginning of your
chess career because if you get an
opening trouble uh repeatedly you'll
find yourself under more problems during
the game in early in your career you
should try to be familiar with different
positions for example and also like the
different approaches I think it's really
important about really enjoying the game
enjoying playing enjoying sewing puzzles
enjoying practicing
and especially with the availability of
resources nowadays with streamers
engines all these resources it's not
hard to improve but I think it's
important to kind of find that
motivation when you begin to kind of get
better and the more you enjoy the game
of course the farther you'll go I think
like passion and trust is very very
important especially for young kids and
so I love that these days there's so
many resources to to get into chess like
YouTube You've Got streamers like Gotham
chess and ikaro who you know are fun to
watch and I think the problem that kids
face is that they get bogged down in the
opening Theory or these like theoretical
things that they feel like they have to
know but it's important for them to
First just learn the the fun things
about Chess the tactics the fun the
exciting the attacking chess so I think
that's the most important thing
thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
Tucker jonova I will be doing social
media for the US Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I am women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonova I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind the scenes content
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 and 50 000
Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello and welcome back these are the
results for round seven yeah round seven
girls junior is very peaceful around so
far we have all drafts who drew with
Atwell Leo Drew with tank and mangalam
Drew against prasanna the huge tension
remains in the game between Carissa and
Allison what about the junior
championships in the junior Championship
we do have some really big results so
first Mishra Drew against wank Zhu lost
against gazarian dagupati won against
Liang and their Queen for guo against
Hong absolutely and in the seniors we
have a clear leader clear leader so the
results root won against loogie very
beautiful game yes Kay danov against
kachin draw wolf won against grevich
this really nice sacrifice group takes
F7 and then we have a draw a kopian
against navikov but that draw between
Gregory kaidanov and kachian that all
but secured a tournament victory for
Malik said there we have five games
remaining and like I said a lot of
tension remains in the game between
Carissa and Allison in fact the way I'm
looking at it it's a three result game
Anything Can Happen the last move was 96
rook f8 and for example in this position
if I'm in caressa's shoes I'm really
really happy because I'm thinking that
okay I've got at least a pet
or rather repetition not a Perpetual the
repetition I have with something like
say rooked to uh C7 with the obvious
threat of Rook check you're gonna have
to play Rook F4 you know you gotta
tickle my bishop and get out of uh those
mating Nets and I have a check you got
to go back and we can go back and forth
or in this position I can go for a crazy
uh line where
um it's it's a race now at first blush
it really looks like not much of a race
wait a minute you know you're just ready
to go and you can take the pawn but okay
let's say I go here and you can start to
see what I'm talking about let's put
another move on G4 B5 this is the kind
of thing I was saying in terms of well
it's it's a race and results these type
of end games are absolutely impossible
right easy to calculate impossible yeah
so uh three result game but and just a
footnote you know Carissa she spent 20
minutes on this move so far because she
had four minutes remaining then she lost
though for those four minutes got
another 30 minutes and then and now
she's making the time control she has to
go for it she's really thinking Hardware
she wants to go for it still thinking
for 20 minutes she has to go for it
because if she doesn't I mean she's
almost out of contention right right
if they make a draw she's going to be a
point and a half behind Alice with two
rounds to go
her faith is not in her hands and what
about also I mean the move Rook C7 yeah
I find that the most attractive but how
about 94 for just a second just uh uh if
you play F2 right well here's a race let
me take it I will take yep and uh
who's fastest let's put it like that it
should be white right yeah because you
have to recapture that one on A2 and I
pass the midline I guess that's an easy
way to kind of look at it you you say
the midline it's interesting I say the
equator I've asked the equator right you
know you're half of the world my half of
the world I passed it first I should be
first there you go uh so for Carissa I
mean she's
and wow uh I thought that she was
seriously worse let's put it that way if
we if we were to go back to that moment
where I think it was well it was just
about here right
I thought that this move for for me just
clarified that well Alice is going to go
H6 G5 King G6 very very slowly but those
pawns March right
right they March slowly but they they do
get there whereas what happened in the
game it kind of like blew up right now
suddenly the imbalances are all over the
place I didn't know what was going on
and uh we caught up with the players by
the way Rook C7 is my move uh
um Carissa is considering Knight E4
she's considering Rook C7 jumping over
to you uh Christian what should Carissa
play according to the engines well I I
wasn't watching that I wasn't checking
on that I think the eval was somewhere
around equal but definitely Carissa has
some chances to continue the game right
to make it into a race right and this is
probably what she should go for what I'm
struck by is the situation in this game
between Josiah and Brandon and this one
is quite important because if Brandon
wins this game then he's getting closer
to the leadership position right he
needs this Victory he's had a difficult
time with that game against Balaji he's
not been finding his uh play in this one
but he has a golden opportunity to do so
against Josiah with the black pieces
important game take a look at this I
think we left it somewhere around Rook
to C3 and we said sure black is better
but white should be uh close enough to
equality to establishing equality Bishop
to D2 Rook to D3 Bishop to E1 now I'm
starting to threaten ideas of Knight to
B4 Knight to C6 Rook to B3 Rook to D1
Bishop to G5 it's one of those positions
in which it's so symmetrical right it
feels like white shouldn't have anything
to worry about but
black has one idea and one idea only in
this position and that is to attack the
pawn on e4 after the move G6 and F5
it's a simple idea but it's a very
useful idea and very productive idea as
well for black in this position because
right now you're creating some tension I
have ideas of Knight to F6 to force you
to take on F5 and in fact he took
already on F5 which is sort of a mistake
take take H4 this is what we have right
now Knight to C2 and F4 and I'm looking
at the position I don't see how this
Knight is getting involved into play you
would love to jump the Knight to E4 good
luck with that you're not going to be
able to get there look to A1 but Knight
to F6 how do you defend this Pawn on D5
you go Rook to A5 I would assume but
after Rook to B1 check
King to H2 Rook to B2 oops I think it's
time to resign right yeah you're losing
a piece and losing the piece so in fact
after Knight to F6 you go okay seven I
take on D5 and defend the bishop on E7
at the same time right you don't have
any more compensation you don't have any
more counter play in the position the
only way defend it is with Rook to D1
but after Rook 2 B5 you're losing the
pawn exactly this might actually just be
over from a technical perspective
for Josiah and for Brandon Knight F6 if
Brandon finds that move shark
keep an eye on the clock because Brandon
has been having some difficulties with
his time management
before the first time control right now
he's down to his last seven minutes as
well still a conversion task ahead of
himself but I have to say after Knight
F6 the position is simple enough that I
will give Brandon great chances to
convert this one and take the full point
home
yeah no Knight F6 is a is crying to be
played you centralize the night you hit
a pond what could be uh simpler I I'm
still having uh troubles uh
understanding what's going on between
Carissa and Alice Lee she did not play
Rook C7 as we expected she didn't play
Knight E4 I mean 94 to stop The Rook C7
94 these she played B4 SM that's what
you keep saying just yeah but in this
case you know you you're on B3
your opponent's on F2
it's not a race so you got to stop you
know you gotta you gotta play 94 or Rook
C7 and Alice played Rook T to D2 give me
the bishop I want to push the pawn and
Bishop C5 and well
don't we just go F2
like oops you've got to take right yes I
believe so but maybe my phone is running
really fast so I capture right you
recapture and B5
right
so take a palm B6
and let's see uh who's You're Gonna Go
B7 right right and Rook C8
um
but I mean it's black playing for the
win right
I mean there has to be black playing for
the win here
now the only question is is
what should I be doing to play for the
win uh okay I I play badly yeah I also
think you
you otherwise I can play Knight C
right kind of stopping group from it was
strange the other the other line I was
looking at was Rook H uh
for you know to to to bring my Rook
across so Rook B8 I'm assuming can I
play Rook C8 here Rook C8 here takes
takes
oh boy don't tell me are you capture
don't tell me I'm not in time to to to
get to the pawn hold on what is going on
I again this move this position really
is confusing me I don't understand
what's going on F2 takes takes B6 takes
no you guys are on the right path Rook
B8 yeah and then uh Kate wants to play
Rook C8
right that's a great move yeah Rook
takes C8 Knight takes C8 yeah and
there's only one way to to get back stay
in the game right now it's Rook H4 okay
followed by King B3 I would assume and
now I just go Rook H1 and we make a draw
yeah but the question for me was what
happens if she goes C3 I guess it's just
check checking Rook H1 again it just
goes back and and we may see this on the
board because we have Bishop captures F2
real captures and B5 okay there's one
way to continue the game for black and
that is take on H2 B6
mm-hmm
and I'll perhaps go Rook to F2 first
Kate mentioned Knight C8 or yeah Knight
C8 Rook F7 yeah the other Rook is going
to go to see so actually either of those
yeah B7 is probably the best in our B8
that's one way to continue this game
it isn't black playing for the win now a
black is playing for the win I would say
so right so B4 is just a blunder right
it was yeah right really of course I
mean I'm trying to create something
no nothing makes
it wasn't that easy and that's
straightforward and I wouldn't
necessarily call it a bladder like what
what would you have played Rook C7 right
and Rook F4 and Roxy and roxy8 and get
into this end game I think this is what
she was afraid of take take Knight to E4
right and now Rook takes H2
and isn't this like just a complete mess
well Rook H4 oh then I have some Viking
C3 I understand I think it's G5 how is
that in game
and that end game is most likely very
close to equality yes
well first of all you cannot take on G5
first why not you mean right now right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah you take on G5
F2 and
take on H7 well I mean but I can't why
can't lose
but I'm trying to survive right no no
wait a minute hold on no no where's the
person is trying to win Karissa is
trying to create some imbalances at all
costs but you cannot win that end game I
go King E7 I don't take the Knight on H7
first of all you can lose the ending you
can definitely lose the ending because
Larry Christensen lost that ending of
King Rook versus bishop and two pumps no
no but that's the thing you don't get
the bishop I go King E7 after Knight H7
I don't take the Knight okay so you have
to give me the bishop and I think Knight
and two pawns is not it is very
difficult
we're talking past one another
let's keep going let's try it again yes
I mean we are trying to survive as
Carissa right if we can play for when
great but most likely we are trying to
to survive after before we may be not
surviving I think Orissa is playing for
a win even after with before I'm trying
to say I think Orissa is trying to find
a way to complicate things and play for
a win okay hold on let me try to sum up
my thoughts
uh
yes we are waiting B4 is a blunder
that's all the Christians say but now he
said I'm not sure if it's a practical
perspective 94 or Rook C7
we're better moves but that's that's a
draw
but there are better moves I'm saying
yeah maybe I think that this is actually
kind of playing for a loss
Carissa could lose this game very easily
now
she took and but maybe she can oh sorry
no no no no no no no no that's our
analysis yeah
um
what's got your attention what do you
mean what's going on I mean you're not
I'm wondering
let's take a look so let's refresh this
position to just make sure we are on the
on the up to date yes okay okay so here
we are yeah now we are looking at uh
Bishop take H2 but maybe white is fine
there
no Bishop they I mean sorry Rook takes
H2 yeah okay B6 and Christian you wanted
to go back or yesterday
yes Rook hf2
and now I have to go B7 I have to be
very precise with white otherwise you
lose otherwise I lose yeah
and now
the best move and maybe the only one is
to go King C3
and you're telling me that this is the
way Carissa should be playing if she
normally has one move that doesn't work
she's not going yeah I mean King C3 is
such a difficult move to make so if we
go Rook C8 which is the move that is
kind of more logical but that's what I
would play yes Rook of fate
the only move but very strong one of
course yes and now if I run with my Pawn
I am slower because your g-pawn is just
faster right
no question well first of all not only
that but I have a big threat after
Rooker fade and that is Rook takes B
just to take the route
[Music]
yeah you don't you don't promote the
pawn you didn't tell me the pawn is
paint sorry well that's why he wanted to
play King C3 which is otherwise makes no
sense he's just trying to avoid this
situation all right so now I understand
King C3 yeah you're just getting out of
the queen it's a stupid move though not
only that but I think what he's trying
to what she's trying to do with King C3
is to also get closer to the pawn
so perhaps at some point we will have
transitions where I take on B8 I
exchange a pair of Rooks and I reach
your Pawn with my king
wow that variation
oh sorry first group to B8 and now King
C3 and I somehow you end up running over
here wow just to give you an example
maybe G4 okay
King D3
and I assume I keep going let's say
if Rook C8 I've got to go back yep
look at fate
and now maybe take that one or maybe
take the Rook on B8
I think take the Rook on B8 yeah okay
that makes sense
and then you're in the Square yeah King
E3 and you go G2 I go King F2
complicate itself very very common we're
gonna stay with this game but can
again because either there is a genius
move or a blunder
we're gonna stay with this game can we
go to Iris I'm sorry
okay Gene G okay what do you have so yes
who was a rook ahead for last few moves
has won his game against Joe Benjamin
well that's that's a big result does
that mean that he's right now only one
and a half points
behind Malik which means that the Malik
hasn't secured
clear first or a tiger yes yeah there's
no not yet secured the tie break so
still a lot to play for King H2 Queen B4
H5 can I just capture Knight takes G4
check and then the bishop on B2 is for
grabs yep or do you want to Checkmate me
here somewhere
uh
I don't have a lot of
material to Checkmate you I'm gonna have
to play like a quiet move or I thought
maybe you capture on G6 capture on G6 I
probably have to recapture in Rook G1 ah
of course but interest D5
that's extra horsey right
yeah The Rook is this defending nicely
the G6 I take but Rook F6 looks like a
D6 okay maybe we are running
uh I don't think so
D7
what else D7 let's go yeah and the funny
part is once you capture on F2 let's say
I just told King H1 and there's no uh
there's no check on the light squares
yeah sure
right away King H1
not sure about that one no maybe so
though I mean you still threaten Queen
takes G6 can we see the standings for a
second because I know that ruyang has
been winning a lot of games well no she
she is right in the mix there uh Zoe
Yang are putting some pressure on Alice
but does this H5 move it's not necessary
I think that's just
sorry uh I
we we were here I'm not
sure that uh
D5 it looks like it's a it's it's a
complete uh winning your your piece up
right right I mean not to allow D6 I
mean no don't don't allow no tricks
right well or at least maybe in this
position play Rook C4
right something like this so
use your extra piece
okay still no move by the way uh from
Alice in that game after B5 but uh yeah
age five seems to be just
I think just a blunder
well but she was down two pawns right it
wasn't but you can just move oh E4 is
hanging too okay maybe it's just a very
bad position for white two extra Pawns
uh very cool uh
so by the way we have all the results of
the seniors right right all games are
done and by the way whitewash three wins
for white no uh wins for black and in
the junior section
and we have standings for seniors after
round seven all games are done so we
have a clear first Mele catching six out
of seven still fantastic score uh second
clear Alex shabalov with four and a half
and then a two-way tie for the third
place vladimiracopian and Gregory
kaidanov with four points each exactly
and we do have more moves they're going
straight into that line take on H2 B6
Rook 2 F2 back
right
and right now it's that B7 Rook B8 King
C3 that Carissa has to find
in order to try to save the game which
we're I I have my doubts frankly that
this is very difficult B7 is the move
you make but King C3
very tough move to make and you have
only 13 minutes you can see the rest of
the games is very very difficult I
I don't I don't want to call it but I
don't see her finding it well it's just
it's such a difficult concept
we're getting the king in front of the
other Pawn that you're trying to push I
mean it does make a lot of sense well
coming into today's round we felt that
this game would determine the winner
should Alice win this game I mean for me
that's just
incredible incredible result uh beating
caressa scoring so well she'll have this
event but I'm really confused by by this
game this game over
uh oh my gosh Rook F2 so why tell us why
King C3
uh once again uh was it a check in King
C3 or was it B7 or B8 and now King City
immediately yes
I mean if I if I drop back with my Rook
yeah you're gonna have to play Rook C8
aren't you I don't think so okay
can I go King D3 for example well that
was my question but I just started
running G4 or H5 yeah but now H5 maybe I
can try to go for C5 and pick up some
pawns but Rook C5 you have root d8
Rook C5 Rook okay so let's get closer
with the King but after Rook did you
always have Rook C8
but that's what I want to try to induce
okay so sorry what uh Christian King E3
what do you do now King E3
um
I'm just I'm flabbergasted I don't know
why but now I go Rook C8
you need to stay close they want to
capture The Rook on f8 and then blade
Knights
one of those tricks
yes clear now it gets in again into a
race yeah it turns into a race once
again King C3
look that's the money movie if she finds
that move in that variation I mean kudos
to her but it's such a difficult move to
make
by the way in juniors in the game Josiah
Stillman and Brandon Jacobson Brandon
managed to capture that pawn on D5
exactly it should be technically winning
that uh game as the question was
mentioning there's this D5 extra Pawn
the only thing that can stop him is is
the lack of time
um but even that he's up to four minutes
right now and the position is just too
simple
right king of five
can I go King H5 just to pick up the
number you want to take another Pawn
Yeah that's why not
because if I traded our Square Bishop
then my knight will land on E3 fantastic
Square true yeah yeah now that that one
is
for for Brandon and where does that put
Brandon in the standings
uh what I was gonna say it could be tied
for a second a half a point behind uh
Arthur right everything to be played for
in the Juniors that's what I mean that
that that's the that's the tournament
that feels wide open whereas uh the
seniors and uh
and the girls the doors closing rapidly
but we have a guest with Christian
Studio Alexander has been a topsy-turvy
game this one and previous game as well
but he got it done very complicated
middle game Yasser was saying that this
is what chess should look like tell us
about a bit about your story
well for me and then I'm like totally
misplayed the middle game and I believe
at some point
so got better and according to him he
was close to winning and really he was
at what point and when he played F5
yeah he said that instead of F5 taken on
D4 and just taking on D4 and just
sacrificing the piece on e4 that's what
he spent his time on close to winning is
a maybe yeah maybe it's an exaggeration
it's like uh yeah but
definitely didn't look very convincing
for me okay but F5 I believe it was just
a blunder
um
I don't know after Rook C2 I think black
is already close to losing
probably better but shouldn't change
that much yeah it's a liability five
should be better now yeah so again if uh
even if Joe doesn't do anything instead
of playing F5 just standing there I
don't think I can do anything
on
no I don't know about my conversion here
I was chosen which piece to live for him
bishop or a knight and uh maybe uh made
her own choice I think the conversion
was clean enough yeah yeah stabilize the
position don't get checkmated then it's
right so
so
uh yeah but uh another game ended up
unfavorably for me yeah
big
hope uh Gregory and just I
couldn't couldn't do anything against
Malik Malik just was uh much better out
of the opening again and playing
incredibly confident right now and so my
only chances to win tomorrow and maybe
set up the but I have to say you're
playing against Malik in the last in the
last round yeah so if I'm down point
it's going to be a really a really fun
game uh but for that I need to win
tomorrow everything to play for
absolutely in the last couple of rounds
Alex congratulations for uh an important
Victory guys thank you our
congratulations
uh definitely uh we love exciting last
Rounds Around Here a crazy game just a
crazy moment just happened in the game
between Iris and Rue Yang I don't
understand what's happening that
everything is hanging we could I mean we
thought Roo Yang would just simply take
the bishop take the bishop and
convert right instead she took a pawn
and attacked The Rook on D2 and with the
bishop hanging The Rook hanging you know
okay all in let's go Rook picks
and that pawn is three times defended
but I'm opening up the bishop because
the hero capture with the Rook like some
complications may arrive right and
you're just thinking why did I make it
messy why did I give my opponent a
chance to make it messy and maybe I'm
missing something but taking on G4
taking on B2 like The Simple Solution uh
getting late in the tournament late in
the round and is there uh did did white
get in a bolt of lightning what's
happening I feel like white is
complicating stuff definitely this is
really good position I was very worried
for Iris if black captured that bishop
and another Bishop on B2 but right now
like if you capture let's say either The
Rook or the bishop whatever you want to
start with okay what's your capture here
I captured The Rook on C6 right
yeah yeah
I capture on e4 okay that's a tempo as
well I kind of want to capture on e4
first
just so that maybe if you take on D6 I
have some Rook takes G6 at some point
hanging in the air
and I mean I'm just two pawns down
that's good
out of everything that could have
happened what's the phone on H5 is very
tricky there are some some tricks in the
position yeah sure yeah looting
potential little white is alive I like
it sometimes a factor as well well and
it's 30 minutes and Iris uh more only
five minutes but again I think iris is
getting 13 I think 13. 13. but this book
Rook takes D6 was
definitely a shock move I mean what else
did she expect Roo Yang expect after
Knight takes E4 I'm not sure but I think
she just missed that the bishop is
suddenly open on their diagonal yeah
well Bishop B2 takes E5 check I mean
that's what white has been playing for
probably for the last day it doesn't
move over to you uh Christian what do
you have for us well I mean a lot of
things have happened in uh the Alice Lee
Carissa game so maybe we should move to
that one just try to understand what
transpired because Carissa went for the
much more logical move Knight to E4 okay
instead of all this nonsense
yeah that's not gonna happen Knight we
for keep that pawn in check on G4 do not
allow it to go to G3 I like what she's
doing
connect the Pawns
is there what's next for black right now
well I'm just wondering if there's like
some uh checkmating patterns with the
two Rooks right like if I go here I take
that yeah check go up uh
no I wanted you to go back so that I
could get you my you know wanted so you
go up I think I go up and I go check
let's say kc4 there we go we might take
I go B7 37.
and then we make so now you can try a
rook F4 yeah and in case I go King B5
Rook B3 now I have to defend the Pawn
King A6 and you've got your Chutney
that's amazing pattern there you go I
was trying to mate you on the first rank
not on the side of the board uh but okay
we don't do that of course so the
current position over to you Christian
what's going on well it's completely
crazy uh rookie five or Rook F4 tried to
destabilize that Knight continue
promoting or at least trying to promote
that g-pawn
but the question arises whenever you go
Rook to F4 she's paid okay five E5 which
allows Knight F6
well that's kind of like those
variations where I was getting the two
Rooks on the open on the open boards
just for a second ah you go King G7
you don't take on F6
no because I think she's trying maybe
for some checkmating patterns to take on
F6 and make a draw okay
uh let's take on G4
where is the mate
well I don't know if there's a mates
King C3 yes let's keep going up
okay can I first attack the night Rook
A4 uh with or without check with Chuck
which this disposition yes okay so we're
looking okay can I go Knight F6 now
yeah
say that uh those two pawns are very
close to promotion no I think what she
wants is after Knight F6 to take on F6
and make a drop
take Rook takes C5 Rook F4 probably
look at F4
and now if you go H5 maybe I have root
B5
or B4 excuse me if you go Rook B5 King
C3 then we make some sort of a draw
right Knight G3 G3 whoa
oh that's losing but now I can go Rook
F3 right and I do have the pattern why
is it losing oh my goodness six was the
way to uh to equalize to hold it to hold
now you can go with your pattern oh but
Rook F3 I don't think it does it work
because
yes that's a big problem all right so
that is a big problem I'm not
threatening the Knight and threatening
Checkmate Checkmate in two Rook so oh no
Carissa missed Rook to E3 right
because if we don't go Rook E3 but we go
Rook F3 which was the my first idea to
just attack the Knight karisa can go B7
correct right and you promote with the
check but the Rook to E3
she only focused on black trying to take
to capture the Knight on G3 but in fact
what I'm trying to do is set up the
Checkmate absolutely and after B7 Rook
to F2 I don't touch the Knight because
of Rook to C8
and she played it yeah very good move
rookie three yeah Carissa missed this
and with this Alice Lee is going to take
it I don't think there's any doubt at
this point there's no way
to defend you can go Knight H1 but G3 is
just going to be all she wrote in that
one and here is what the rest of the
tournament looks like for Alice
she's winning with the maybe tournament
favorite although Alice is definitely
one of the favorites as well against
karisayev and then she has two more
players Mo and mangalan
that's what she needs to well she has a
point Advantage yeah well I definitely
saw uh Carissa as being her biggest
rival but this blunder Knight G3 well
that just basically gifted the
tournament but this is what we call it
in tennis an unforced area a really a
bad because you have to there's no
pressure on the clock you have 10
minutes
you have two big options and Knight F6
is the most forced one you have to
calculate Knight F6 I think at this
point she just wanted to win this
position too much
maybe Knight G3 she really hope that
there's still something that could
potentially give her the full point in
the position
maybe what she didn't expect was that
she's actually going to lose this one
she's getting checked Maybe
well indeed that's exactly what's
happening roof F2 and rookie one made uh
Zoe how is Zoe doing because uh she's
been nursing an extra Pawn for some time
she's trying to get the pawn past that
dark Square Bishop that has been kind of
a gatekeeper
we we prematurely called it a draw I
think some time ago
gate and
yeah
I still think it's probably a draw but
I'm not sure what's happening now in the
iris mode game that got really
complicated well it totally confusing to
play Knight takes E4 Rook takes Rook
takes Bishop takes Rook F6 on the board
and that's sneaky move eight six
H6 check also on the board you know that
it's something about that pawn I
probably rather not take it I'd probably
like to hide my king behind it and like
you take she did it she did play King H7
you take the rook and okay sort of like
yeah I I have to figure out how to
re-win the game but you know something
like 91 I'm not interested in taking
this bishop but you know yes I'm curious
what if I don't capture that Rook on F6
okay
but I play
Oh I thought Rook did sneaky but that
doesn't work okay some mating patterns
it's crazy right Rook d8 yeah who did
yeah what's happening in this one
Bishop takes on the board
E1
91 already it's like trying to get a
checkmated yes A move from the Crypt
right well this was like uh I thought I
was uh getting in with a check but uh
maybe not but actually can I play The
Rook d8 sorry I don't want to capture
The Rook just Rook d8 right now
so I'm a okay
missing I'm a
I'm a rook up
I mean I'm having a hard time just
counting what's going on uh but she took
on F6 she did that's already yeah Cape
that's already been played Rook datas
fascinating I mean it's just like what
but boy did Ru Yang really give her
opponent a chance here this is uh this
is chaos so let's let's go along with
this 91 idea right of yours
on
on F6 Queen takes F6
and queen C3
I'm sure this is her intention and we
think Alice's game is about to finish so
we're gonna uh return to it
uh this is the big one yeah as
after rookie three
Rook
to D6 takes C6 is on the board
every time I think I'm gonna call the
game's over like it's easy uh
okay so let's finish it off how do we do
that so Rook F2 check King C1 only move
check
on G1 or G1 I think G1 and we capture
the rook in G3 no
that's it and C7
I don't know I'm
I'm going with a check
yeah B7 G2
yes
that's it I mean this should be winning
completely
it's an extra girl
extra Rook actually sorry but are we
sure about it yes okay so let's go to C8
uh B8 loses because of Check Yes yes so
C8 Queen
check okay let's stay King somewhere and
we go check so now we've covered yes and
then we just drop our doesn't matter we
just drop our Queen anywhere in the
center and we just make sure that
there's no perpets
we're Rook up and we have another pond
that's running and we have another Pawn
you want the one more Queen right yeah
that's good enough so essentially from
the current position Alice has a forced
win with Rook F2
can we find something cleaner yes I
thought I I didn't see uh that I thought
we were going to go check right right
right right and you
after King like something like a mate
and
you know what I mean we just something
like that so I have to go King B1 right
after Rook C3
Rook C3 King B1 I think is the only way
to check
King A1 or where did you want to go
question
I wanted to go see one but
see one
really not liking it any other way
so take on B6 I go C7 but you don't take
on B6 I'm you're a tricky guy I'm
waiting for you to play C7 and then you
give me another chance exactly and then
I'll go this way yeah yeah this one
seems to be over okay
um choices okay is that a really cleaner
ledges
but I like the the extra Rook I like the
extra Rook uh personally but uh
she has options
by the way is it just me or is it camera
it just looks like Carissa just kind of
sank down yeah the body pasture she
knows she knows yeah she's got she
realizes she's completely messed this up
yeah I'm really curious whether she
didn't play Knight F6 because she was
worried about draw or if she missed that
move
because this 93 that yeah
yeah came over
The Rook F2
look Kudos you know she
she put up an incredible fight
starting from the opening
through the middle game and even this
whole end game calculation I mean this
was such a difficult game
for both players
to calculate the spawn races is one of
the most difficult things in chess
but I I'm really confounded by the
decision to play B4 not to play Knight
E4 coordinating the pieces
stopping the pawn from going to F2
the the for anybody who's joining us
late right about here this move B4 was
really really for me a stunning move you
play Rook C7
and you play Rook C8 and you trade Rooks
or you play the move Knight E4 you don't
even have to trade Rooks you make a draw
if you want to right Rook C7 Rook C8 and
you just stop at the pawn from going to
F2 right but this move B4 got her into
trouble and she she wasn't losing after
the move B4 and it was right here this
was the losing moment right this was
where she did have the move Knight F6
check and the chess engine set draw but
Knight G3 and now she is losing
and by the way this is our second uh
national championship for the girls
Alice I mean it's it's hard to believe
that she's they're what 14 years the
second second appearance in the U.S
Women's Championship because she will be
getting that ticket to play in the U.S
Women's Championship she qualifies by
reading yeah
there shouldn't be a discussion about
that but she is as the champion she will
be getting that ticket to the US1
Championship well as Carissa said she
was playing for the ten thousand dollar
scholarship as well she was like looking
forward to that that's the big one by
the way I have a question if you win
like 10 of these do you get like a
hundred thousand by the time you uh you
go to college because the Wayne is
agreeable to that this is only 13 years
of age so how many of these has she won
already
would this be her first title of U.S
junior girls yes I believe so okay so
that's a good start she still has like
five years right exactly exactly exactly
yeah well what's your cutoff age but
also you never know when she goes to
college right these young superstars
they can start college yeah like 15.
maybe she's already taking college
classes she is actually which is
ridiculous well we were joking with
Alice because she was giving this
interview where we were talking about
her her stream you know Alice's Pond
Palace we were talking about her
academic career and we were saying you
know the governor's campaign
okay it starts next week campaigning for
governor uh what what would be your win
would you would I I'd go for the extra
Rook I'd go Rook check yeah I definitely
go Rook G1 take G3 but Alice goes
through A3 yeah checkmate
exactly that was the other thing would
you go for because we were looking at
this line right where we were going to
check and then playing G3 so I guess
let's look at King A1 also we didn't
look at this one right I'm sorry uh
after King B1 Rook B3 and King A1 I
think we checked King C1 but we didn't
check King A1 King A1 I see yes sorry
so now
can I
it's like it's a it's funny I I was
trying to mate you on the first rank
first and second rank now I'm trying to
meet you on the uh the side that seems
decisive yes I can go rook d8 and Rook
A8 but that's not going to help me much
no
this is Alice's fourth appearance we've
been told in the U.S junior girls and
she hasn't won it yet so definitely
winning this one Victory it's bigger
it's big first appearance was when she
was nine yes incredible that's crazy
incredible crazy exactly
Rook
IE okay all right
we haven't even considered this move
for uh whatever reason
yeah well actually I didn't consider
Rook A3
I mean why wouldn't you be forcing and
do it with it now she plays Rook C3
check Rook takes C6
yes that's very icy
yes yes
support the little little guys uh King
G7 that's I'm all about supporting uh
the guys
yes
wow amazing game this was really like
crazy preparation and then unequal
pressure is crazy because uh this was a
center counter with Queen C4 a very very
obscure line uh in the opening and it
was like Alice had prepared it like how
could she guess incredible yes I mean
this is just absolutely how could she
possibly have guessed that Carissa was
going to play this really offbeat
opening I'll tell you one way so
there is a story from the Olympian the
woman's just Olympiad uh last year that
was played in India last year okay and
the women's team was not doing great
for the first four rounds okay and then
we decided I was coaching Becky and she
was in uh on first board just to
interrupt this one is uh we do have a
result yeah beautiful beautiful game
um
and I told her hey we we need to to do
something
you're not getting the type of positions
that you want the team is not doing well
we need to uh we need to do something
drastic and I told her to play this E4
E5 D4 just see how it goes and we looked
at this line with Queen to C4 in fact
and it was Carissa on the third board
that played the same thing in 45 default
so they both played e45 D4 so probably
from that
um experience you kind of draw some
inspiration because she wasn't doing
that great in the tournament she needed
something drastic and perhaps that's how
she came to the conclusion to play this
e45 D4
but she played it before and maybe
that's why Alice was already so well
prepared for it well prepared gotcha by
the way uh Rue Yang Yan I think she's
spoiled uh what was a pretty smooth
Victory uh because the current position
I think uh White seems close to equal
right yeah white is just uh
very very very very very happy Iris uh
saved this one and wow and I was just
also one of the youngest participants
only 13 years old exactly
Rook F3 on the board
I think we can handle that one thank you
too
just protecting the F2 oh can I do B2
afterwards
uh King G2 B2 and I'll get uh I have to
sacrifice my actually I don't I could
play Bishop A2 but I would play Bishop
takes G6
and uh get rook and pawn versus real
life draw uh what else what other games
are going on we we have one more Disney
Junior
Jacobson still going Brandon is enjoying
two Pawn advantage
yes
very very big advantage that must be a
technical win yeah I think that's the
that's the big one we should probably
stay with this and so just because it's
so important for the standings right
right if
um if Brandon wins this one I mean he's
back in the mix right half a point
behind the sole leader Arthur agua and
I'm actually kind of curious to see
the next round Perry yeah yeah the road
ahead right for Arthur and for Brandon
but you know what talking about
important
we have in the girls or
so attacking uh Alice Lee so that's
maybe a game we can also take a look at
but that seems to be equal right
we've been saying that for two hours not
much has been happening I think
in that one
look there is this Pawn on G6 is it that
equal
like now why are you serious about
running with that only Pawn on the board
so we go Rook G1
yes six
right
on the
on H6 right anytime I need to
I really want to play uh after Rook G1
King F6 I really want to play this move
uh Rook G2 yeah just to trap my
everything I know I know it's like some
kind of a funny business
uh to trap The Rook but you okay but
this should be winning right if I
capture in Bishop H2 because the pawn is
running
all right let's take a look at the
pairings for round eight in the U.S
junior Championship a peek ahead huh
right round eight wank against Jacobson
hung against dear man Liang against goal
gazarian facing dagupati and Mishra
against Juju
Mishra versus
Zoo that's a big imbalance in terms good
for that with a white pieces definitely
a big chance for him try to score a
victory
and the girls parents the girls we have
Advil against prasanna Yen against
mangalam Lee against moo tank again see
if that's gonna be a big match right and
who against Liu
but it's all about Alice as she's doing
just fabulous and finally the senior
parents
here we have loogie against navikov
Benjamin against acopian curedevich
against shabalov katian against wolf
another very big game and Route against
kaidano well the way Patrick sounded
he's he's upbeat he's looking forward to
this challenge of stopping the runaway
train I think the whole field wants
Patrick to you know get back exactly and
steal some points for Malik exactly
exactly so as we have three games
remaining Iris uh versus again we
expected to draw Zoe's game with Kelsey
we expect to draw there but Brandon we
expect that he will win with his uh two
extra Pawns
these spawns are just running yes they
certainly are
for uh Josiah it's like Josiah has a lot
of time yeah 26 minutes Brandon only two
minutes but a giant advantage on the
board right
yeah Jose is not happy about his
position no
no he's he's had a rough event so far
and I mean yesterday's loss out of the
already that was less than an hour you
never want to lose like that
that leaves a sour taste in your mouth
totally yeah I have to say he shouldn't
have lost this game either
position was more or less equal but
there was still some pressure he just
wasn't able to handle it very well
Bishop C5 chat kf1 and H3 an H3 that one
is that's scary that guy's going yeah
even though you know age three I take on
F4 King takes King takes Knight D3
you're still winning I think but
takes on F3 yeah actually
yeah because there's Knight takes E5
some sneaking well even that I should be
winning uh King G3 but yes yes
yeah King takes yep he goes right Knight
D3 check King G3 just a little bit more
accurate I would say
big victory really big victory for
Brandon important victory for Brandon
he's gonna see handshake very soon
stylish finish I like King G3 yeah
yeah oh
plays on
that was a surprise
yeah I think we're going to see the
resignation right now
a spite capture
Spike checks I get Spike captures that I
can always say I was pissed up in that
game but I lost oh so close so close
wow so it actually uh in the Juniors it
was a split 2-2 two white wins two black
victories and uh four out of five I mean
the decisive games in these national
championships have been through the roof
uh across all the tournaments by the way
I mean it feels like victories Galore in
this event yeah maybe only in the girls
section we're gonna see a number of
draws
yeah the players are just so solid
I think we're actually going to see a
repetition very soon in the game calcio
and Zoe tank let's jump to it I feel
like they already repeat it a few times
yeah I think that one is close to being
over and just Rook F1 Rook E1 Rook F1
rookie one
doesn't seem like there's a lot of ways
to to continue but it's like one of
those games that somehow
20 30 moves ago I wouldn't have been
surprised if they found a repetition but
they played you know like an extra five
hours
just to make sure yeah Iris she's the
one who can be very happy for surviving
it's a very difficult position and gets
rui again yeah it was that shot Rook
takes D6 it was like a joke that's a
game changer right here we go Rook F1
check
they've already repeated a couple times
right so G6
so King Essex so that's one check
that's two checks
yeah
King E7
yep yep can you sell one
so we're expecting something like would
you want one and now I think she's ready
to you have to bring the king back stop
the classics
and then you know say that King F6
repeats the position three times right
after Rook G1 yes Rook G1 King F6 yeah
exactly
yeah Zoe is just making sure if she
doesn't have a way to maybe play on
because she does have an extra Pawn but
that pawn on G6 is just very Advanced
yeah true
well somebody's got a very neat score
sheet there
very nice handwriting
I think they need a score sheet I I mean
I pal benko and Victor course now I
belong into a separate class a terrible
terrible terrible writers but I think
Peter laco belongs into a class all of
his own I mean his scoresheets are
somehow you know works of art
uh Gary Kasparov score sheets through
the first 20 moves were fine but they
got progressively worse
and they're not claiming to draw they're
just playing on repeating right
right and in the meanwhile uh as this
repetition unfolds we do have a guest in
studio with Chris
Alice back and forth game but finally
you come out on top but I have to ask
you what was this opening preparation
how did you anticipate E4 E5 D4 coming
from Carissa
um yeah so I think she actually played
this recently in a Charlotte super Swiss
um that was a week ago and against I
think the middle married off so I saw
the game where she played like this
queen T4 move so I uh that wasn't in my
file so I had to do like my coach sent
me some lines there some new files yeah
so after
um so I like sort of anticipated this
also the G4 line because I know that the
US like women's Olympiad team like plays
this D4 line and I think there was a
game in the Olympia where uh Tata of
abrahamian played G4 so I was able to
like look uh over uh the lines there
um and with 1954 I knew this idea before
the game although of course there were
like a lot of other lines I had to
review so I didn't review it like
um it too deeply like I missed this 92
move right and this 92 move is not liked
by the engine but definitely poses some
serious practical problems right yeah
because uh here so I know after C4 there
was Queen of six so I thought after
um after 92 I could try Queenie queen of
six also though like of course it was
kind of annoying for me because I can't
do 906 the right C4 yeah
um so queen of six I think Queen H4 was
the only move or I didn't really
consider queenish but I was just like
calculating to make sure that queen of
six didn't like immediately lose yeah um
but yeah I guess kunesha was the best
one and then you got into this end game
how did you assess this one
um yeah I I had no idea like how to
adjust this but I thought um I mean I
thought it was probably objectively
equal although I did think that I could
try to play for something I guess the
engine syncroid is slightly better what
the authors love to call Dynamic
equality yeah oh yeah I found 93 here
and then I wasn't sure what to do I
thought maybe uh yeah like because if
we're taking for Knight F5 so yes
um I really wouldn't enjoy what to do I
guess even darker if I didn't exchanges
even this is fine yeah I have a three
pounds
um and perhaps this would have been the
way you would have played but this was
the moment that kind of baffled yeah all
of us yeah no I don't I hadn't I have no
idea what I was doing here like I knew I
had to be better especially after I got
like 92 and
um maybe I should have just like done
work texts who was playing for a win in
this moment I feel like she would claim
for the win because she always had this
option of like after Bishop D4 F3
um she can always like repeat I guess
like if she wants like work she works C7
and then uh yeah I'd like work back but
I don't think she wanted to draw so she
went for this before but I sat here
um I mean I thought it should still be
okay for me because at the very least I
can there are some lines that I was
calculating that I can sacrifice my
Workforce tonight and the bee Pond and I
think perhaps this one was one of them
right at this point when she had Knight
to F6 you already sacrificed these yeah
I was pretty happy here like I was going
to do birthdays F6 in the nursery
five it'll probably be a troll but
the extra there's still some
Place absolutely
yeah but she played no G3 and then I was
like oh wait I have this idea of rookie
three and then I'm certainly in Rook of
two and rookie one so I was so then I
thought that I should probably be
winning here do you think that this is
what she missed yeah I think though I
think maybe she had like calculated some
lines here with like B7
yeah something like that I mean 92 but
then she probably realized that I can
like take on E2 and then I think that's
uh
um I think I was putting the F work in
number 53 reviews oh no Rook C3 Rook B2
uh and then I get the two connected two
bombs yes very nice very nice
absolutely
nicely calculated yeah and uh after that
I think it was quite clinical from
Europe takes C6 get the two points X-ray
and just win that one yeah Alice is this
the first time you uh win against
Carissa yeah
um this is the first time I think I
actually played over the board so it was
something like really new for me and I
would like going into the theme I
thought the draw would be fine
um but I definitely wasn't expecting to
win and it was just like really great to
be able to win against such a strong
player and this definitely has helped of
course like with my tournaments while
I'm sure you're welcoming this uh
surprise let's say yeah guys any
questions for our leader in the junior
girls our congratulations to be sure
Alice I just had a quick question for me
uh the move B3 B4 was a surprise I
thought it was a mistake from Carissa
and I was actually curious just to get
your opinion uh what what did you think
would be the result after Knight E4 did
you oh yeah because that's the most
obvious move I thought yeah I thought 84
with
annoying but I'm not sure what I was
planning to do here I think like
um
F2 probably white is white is pushing
for a win probably what was my feeling
as well that white would be better if
you played it yeah so I think also I
need to play
in like rookie two Rook E2 okay
and if like on 1985 F2
uh other like
um
I mean I still thought like this would
be like slightly worse for me wait but
Knight takes G5 F2 C7 how is that and
then I think maybe I can move my Rook I
work up for
uh-huh
she still has some Chaos on the board
going on yeah like I'm not sure if like
Rick Rook C8 uh then Rick f8 repeat
right so
it's good I mean it's like white always
has a draw in her yeah well it always
has to draw where she wanted yeah with
Rick C7 okay so just Knight E4 was it
was a part of your calculations as well
yeah all right Alice you've got two very
big games to uh still play keep your
mind on the tournament and our
congratulations for a very very big win
today thank you absolutely what a great
performance
it stands out doesn't it yeah I mean you
just
wow and really fighting games this game
I think was super interesting starting
with that preparation about it I mean
imbalances throughout and then the end
game where you have to be so surgically
precise well I'm sorry I'm so stunned by
the opening where uh Alice plays the
first 14 moves and grabs a five extra
minutes on the clock and it's like wow
how well prepared did you have to be so
yeah we're going to see this again
somehow
got uh Rook a night that's a that's a
that's a stunner I didn't think that she
was going to get this but she did
achieve it and we're going to be here
for another three and a half hours so
let's take a look when was the last time
that there was a capture just so we keep
track of that 50 moves rule once I
claimed 40 move Rule and then the
Arbiter said so you completed 40 moves I
was like that's a draw seven it's like
four move so it's 50. or only three
moves into this only three moves only
three moves we're here for another 47.
oh wow that's a
that that that's really good
you know I won this end game once
against a pretty strong GM oh wow did
you I did yes against the
I believe Azerbaijan yes that's my
teammate from Webster
yes
confirmation on this one this was in the
Pro chess League approaches with very
few seconds left on the clock for either
for both of us
but uh it's it's playable I mean you you
can win it if you make a few mistakes
I remember you want to pin the night to
the King right that's like the easiest
way to just make a draw I I think I drew
it a few times
just if I can grab my Rook put it on f8
and your king is always kind of stuck
and uh as these two players will battle
this out we do have a guest in studio
Christian over to you Brandon after the
accident against the Balaji you're back
in this tournament with a crucial
Victory how important was for you to get
a victory in today's round
yeah no I I mischance with pretty much
every game
um against Balaji I I kind of got over
ambitious with Queen B6 I had no reason
to lose that game and then against R3
yesterday I had a big chance with E4
instead of Bishop C6 and then it kind of
fizzled out um so it was definitely
important I keep missing all my chances
but I think the main adjustment I made
was just trying not to be upset with
myself about mistakes because I think
normally my issue this tournament has
been like once I'm making an accuracy
I'm getting kind of upset with myself
not able to psychologically adjust so I
think I did that a lot better this game
and kept focused the whole 100 move game
and another aspect that I noticed is
that despite the fact that you want to
win you need to win you're still not
playing this super sharp lines you want
to keep the game long was that part of
the strategy as well well yeah so in the
opening I played this bishop t7 move um
so the the best line or sorry starting
with H6 yes instead of H6 I mean the
main line it was taken Bishop G4 which I
assume he prepared but I remember it's
some it has some pretty dry positions so
I mean it's the h637 it transposes the
kind of something that I've analyzed
it's kind of interesting because
what you did against Bellagio right
right I've analyzed some positions where
White's actually sort of down a full
temper because he went Bishop C so like
he went D3 T4 the bishop on C2 and then
A4 yeah like in some position in a
normal Roy where he could Bishops on B3
he gets D4 and one moves then A4 in one
move so it's like he wasted me with his
Bishop yeah but the thing is that is on
F1 instead of G3 which could actually
help him in some cases because he goes
through so I need to think exactly so
I'm trying to figure out the differences
now I'm not sure if what I did was
correct but it felt like kind of the
principal way I think it was yeah
because so the point is if if um Queen
takes away forms that ever takes A4
um C6
and the point is now if C4 I'm in time
for Knight B7 I was or night I suggest
same thing and and he can't cook Queen
takes his Queen gets traps and now he
can't go the point is he can't go Bishop
B3 to defend now because E4 is hanging
so this Knight to see yeah
so
yeah so C6 dc6 and now I think Queen B6
might have been a bit I'm not sure if it
was actually the correct move
um all right it will computers yeah all
right I thought maybe he should try like
let's say queen C2 instead of um 93 yes
uh Queen takes C6 and Bishop E3 is a
little bit afraid of this because then
he just goes Rook A1 next and okay at
some point I can go D5 and I'm probably
okay but I don't know I'm gonna win this
game and also I mean A5 is always is a
week long term I think if you're only
gives point three but I felt a little
bit dangerous it's a bit unpleasant
right you play 93 which makes a lot of
sense but I wasn't too afraid of it
because yeah I think I'm pretty well
placed for all this yeah for Queen D2 I
felt like I might have missed a chance
around here um was Queen B3 any good
maybe instead of Queen B5
no apparently not all right because I
was thinking maybe Queen B3 and if okay
if you take side and I have six and you
can't defend upon his issues so Rook A1
and then F6 here but I guess you can
just play some of the queen C1 that's
not yeah and I think this was getting
Knight to D2 was critical for his
chances throughout the game like right
especially when uh he played Knight F6
91 that was the mistake that was
supposed to go Queen A2 and then I did
two and then yeah it's kind of hard to
do that because I mean I can give Bishop
B7 Bishop T and keep the pawn exactly so
yeah yeah I figured it probably has some
accurate would equalize here but I
thought at least was trying everything I
could try of course seeing how that goes
yeah so anyone I kind of felt like I
might have let it slip a bit before the
time control but I I think I did a good
job of keeping pressure the whole game
even if even if it was a draw at some
point
um by the way he found this nice idea
with Rook A6 I'm of 30 um because the
issue because like I think it's actually
a pretty nice defense because I can't
get Rick C2 now because I mean like I
can but Queen takes C2 Queen E1 King H2
Queen takes E3 and yeah he can go Queen
C7 Queen C7 I guess I can see a lot of
draws but yeah I thought simplest
between 27. can I play my queen is kind
of shut out okay seven yeah right you
have to so
so yeah I think what I did was the most
principled
um I'm not exactly sure where he went
wrong but like my only job was just to
keep putting pressure even if it was a
drug exactly so like every I mean it was
actually kind of simple for me to play
because like I was just playing the move
that I felt like kept the initiative
going every move and like I didn't
really have much of a choice I think it
was still equal still equal I'm
surprised somewhere around here but this
is already starting to become extremely
uncomfortable right yeah exactly and the
issue is pieces are so jumbled up as
Rick can never really get active because
pieces are so loose I think this was the
question yeah I thought he should try
waiting yeah yeah I can't have one so
the point is that his night like the
night in The Rook are kind of like it's
like kind of like a mutualism because I
don't want to let his Knight get to an
act this way before like if you always
have like 983 for example but 3c4
exactly so it kind of makes sense for
the way yeah Enrique when I think it's I
guess he's in time for his currently but
that's already very difficult yeah
um and yeah I think in the game like H4
H4 felt felt wrong but already it's very
uncomfortable I thought he would play
like King F1 and ic2 and just sort of
place but I think eventually I will win
the d-pawn and okay I'm up upon the game
goes on but I think practically it's
very difficult for white and yeah I mean
once the pawn is fixed on H4 I think
it's pretty much game over your
tournament the Juniors is very very
tight at the top a lot of players are
vying for position Arthur guo is
definitely one of the surprises I would
say of uh this event how would you uh
anticipate the last couple of rounds
play out
yeah it's tough I mean also I think like
Abby's Half Point behind yeah so I think
you know it's kind of hard to say
anything right now like flano Arthur
will win the last two games there's
nothing I can do so all I can really do
is play my best chess the last three
games and see how it goes but it's
really interesting and I did not expect
like I knew it was going to be close but
I didn't expect it to be this close like
it's really anybody's game at this point
guys any questions for Brandon
yeah Brandon I have a question so two
rounds to go are you gonna take risks
like play it you know risk position even
if it's a draw that you don't want to
draw because you really want to go for
the first place or are you just happy
you know if you finish second third
you're not going to be risking that much
well I don't think I should answer that
question right now but I mean I think it
sort of depends on on a lot of things
right it depends on the positions they
get into the opening the position you
know how everybody else is doing but in
terms of my strategy there's not really
much I can really do besides play my
best and see how it goes because I think
it's a bit too soon to go all out to try
to win when there's still two games left
and anything can happen
absolutely thank you well out
congratulations Brandon good luck in the
rest of the tournament to do more rounds
to go
round seven I'm just looking it's a
dream a result for Alice Lee she's the
only winner in her section and uh wow a
standing speak for themselves yeah let's
look at that standings at around seven
in the U.S girls junior Alice Lee the
Soul Leader six out of seven absolutely
fantastic performance second to play Zoe
tank Five Points
Four Points uh third place also a
surprise and in the Juniors this is the
wide open tournament we've been talking
about right but we do have a solid
Arthur go very important win for him
today to lead the tournament and then a
two-way tie for the second place Brandon
Jacobson and abimeo Mishra with four and
a half points Andrew and Balaji did
something outside somebody please stop
Arthur and we may have a playoffs but
tell us about the seniors I mean the
seniors we have medical
six points one half points ahead of Alex
chabalov who is second and then two
players dying for third vladimira kopian
and Gregory kaidanov with four points
and uh Christian as we close our
broadcast sum up round seven just
incredible chess uh all throughout the
three national championships and I have
to say Melissa kachian still is looking
alike the man to be caught but I have to
say it's going to be very very difficult
nevertheless Alex chabalov we know he
never gives up so in the last couple of
rounds everything still to be played for
Alice Lee is just impressing day after
day and in the junior section anything
absolutely anything can happen but
Arturo right now he's playing the chess
of his life preparation Stellar middle
game and end game execution just uh
pristine so definitely still a lot of
things to be played for and in the last
couple of rounds everything will be
decided we'll be here to call all the
action absolutely Championship rounds
rounds eight and nine coming up to
tomorrow uh join us at the same time
same channel same place yeah and tell
your friends where you're hanging out
and we are expecting a lot of exciting
games all right see you all tomorrow bye
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited